his call
so i i want pups granny to go back red
okay let's go to tommy tommy in belcher
kentucky democrats line
uh yes uh i keep hearing these people
call them them democrats family
republicans i'm an american first
and i do not believe
that these
senators
that are
voting the way they vote
and everything else on the republican
line they are more feared about jeffrey
epstein if they ever check in on it they
find how how many republicans flew
around exactly how does that relate to
yesterday
because how can they vote
wrap
the right vote if they are
knowing that they've had villains with
jeffrey
we'll go to we'll go to david in los
angeles california independent line good
morning
uh freedom and justice for all is in one
of our anthems and i think what's being
manifested in this cell do this just
because congress didn't act but you can
uh the president can act if it's within
his authority and he believes it's
something in the public interest
thanks i want to switch gears a little
bit i was encouraged earlier when you
said um that the department's purposes
uh are to make sure include among them
to include to be sure that both the
powerful and the powerless are tweeted
treated equally i want to talk about one
case where that obviously hasn't
happened and that's the case of jeffrey
epstein and his many many victims
of
domestic and international sex
trafficking obviously he evaded justice
for years and when the department did
ultimately partner with local
authorities
it allowed charges to be brought that
didn't befit the seriousness of his
crimes
infuriatingly
he was allowed to die by apparent
suicide in federal custody despite the
fact that everybody knew he was a
suicide risk and many people would
benefit from that outcome and then most
recently his state has failed to pony up
to make right on all of their
obligations
to compensate his victims
what do you think went wrong with the
department's handling of the epstein
case
senator so
my position as a judge i'm and also my
previous position as a prosecutor i'm
all
always been extremely careful not to
comment about uh something without
knowing the facts
uh the facts i know about the epstein
matter are the ones i've read in the me
in the media and then i've seen on
television so i i don't think i just not
in the past we can those are
disgustingly embarrassing about how weak
the department's pursuit of this evil
man is absolutely but you asked me the
why question and i i can't answer the
why question but on the values question
i can answer this is just horrendous
um and uh he obviously should have been
vigorously uh prosecuted uh uh
substantially earlier but i don't know
the why and and he has co-conspirators
who are still um being held and pursued
and as you and i discussed in private i
hope that we will make sure that the
department prioritizes resources for
this
uh scores and scores of the women he
victimized
are just in their 30s now but they've
had so much of their lives stolen from
them and obviously sex trafficking is a
scourge of our time and i really would
hope that the department continues to
do an after-action review on why we've
under-invested there i've got more
questions on the department's china
initiative but my time has expired so
i'll follow up with that separately look
forward to it thank you
senator blumenthal
thanks mr chairman uh i want to welcome
you to the committee thank you your
honor and welcome address at 9 00 pm
eastern on c-span online at cspan.org or
listen live on the c-span radio app
federal bureau of prisons director
michael carvajal testified before the
senate judiciary committee on how the
prison system is responding to the
coronavirus pandemic
including testing and vaccinating
inmates
this is just under two and a half hours
here
oh
[Music]
um
today the senate is holding its first
oversight hearing of the federal bureau
of prisons first time since 2019
director carvajal thanks for joining us
to start today's hearing i'd like to
show a short video that offers look
behind bars for the more than 152
000 people in our nation's federal
prison system
in 1993 at the age of 23 olton mills
received a mandatory life sentence with
no parole
for a non-violent drug offense
ones have to ask themselves
why
did they give a young
man the age of 23 years old
a life sentence
on a per capita basis the united states
has more people behind bars 2.3 million
than any other country in the world some
of the biggest covert 19 outbreaks in
the us are in the prisons and jails that
house more than two million people they
literally leaving us in here to die we
just look it's just looking grim it's
only a matter of time before we all get
it we just in here look andrea highbear
died tragically in bop custody after
delivering her baby while on a
ventilator they hadn't called me at all
to even let me know she was sick or
where that they were sending her to the
hospital i haven't heard from them at
all knowing that this virus is out there
it's hard to imagine
you know the layers of frankly ignorance
and neglect that would have to take
place for that to happen and then just
the lack of concern for humanity
i wasn't there to see them graduated
from high school
see my grandkids they're failing to
protect the people who are in their
custody that they have a constitutional
obligation to protect they are failing
to protect their staff and the people
who work there when she was
crying out for help you know um
i know they had failed her
you got to be a church
because there's other people like me
on the inside
they got families
got children
they need to be home
i might just add that i know alton mills
gentleman who was
just on the video here
sentenced to life in prison at age 23
for a non-violent drug offense
he was released because of the work of
this committee and changes in the law
that have taken place i thank senator
grassley
for joining me
in that effort senator cornyn was part
of it as well
and signed into law by president trump
alton mills
has a job he's worked ever since he's
got out of prison he's reunited with his
family
he is no threat to society he is
making a positive contribution
for years i've sought to
address the injustices and challenges
that impact the lives of incarcerated
families
along with the staff who are responsible
the men and women who go into these
federal prisons and work there
their health and well-being is our
concern certainly as much as if not more
than the inmates
now i've worked across the aisle as i
mentioned with senator grassley to pass
bipartisan legislation like the fair
sentencing act and the first step to act
to reform federal sentencing laws and
help inmates successfully return
i've held hearings on the conditions of
confinement
i think some of the most memorable
hearings of my life were in this room
with those who had been held in virtual
solitary confinement some for as long as
a decade
and i've dealt with the issue of
treating incarcerated individuals with
mental illness
i i think over and over again the
sheriff of cook county tom dart is a
personal friend of mine
who says without any challenge from any
side whatsoever
he runs in the cook county jail the
largest mental health institution in the
united states
so many of these prisoners are suffering
from mental illness
we still have a lot of work to do
when the pandemic began many of us fear
that borrowing
immediate and decisive action our
nation's prisons were headed for
catastrophe
march of last year i joined senator
grassley along with 12 of our colleagues
in sending a bipartisan letter to
director carvajal and the former
attorney general in it we urged you to
use your authority under the first step
act to swiftly swiftly transfer
vulnerable inmates to home confinement
we sent that letter out of concern
for the health and well-being of the
inmates as well as 37 000 americans
working in our federal prisons
at the time we sent the letter only
three inmates and three staff members
had tested positive for covet 19.
what happened
in the months that followed tens of
thousands of federal prisoners tested
positive for coven 19.
at times the infection rate for the
federal prison population
has been nearly six times higher than in
the community at large
as a result 230 incarcerated individuals
at least have died from covet 19 nearly
all of whom had pre-existing conditions
that made them particularly and
obviously vulnerable
several were within months of being
released
and 55 died after their request for
compassionate release was denied and
while the request was pending
one preventable death was noted in this
video andrea highbear
eight months pregnant when the bureau
prison official sent her to the federal
medical center in carswell
she came down with kova 19 and gave
birth to her premature daughter while on
a ventilator
nearly a month later miss hyber died
without ever getting a chance to hold
her baby
thousands of bop staff members have also
contracted covet 19
at least four have passed away
including roark mack macarthur a 42 year
old correctional officer at the federal
penitentiary in cotton thompson illinois
these were preventable deaths
it's clear that the bureau has been far
too rigid
in approving transfers to home
confinement and compassionate release to
reduce prison populations and to prevent
the spread of coven 19
unfortunately this is part of a broader
pattern the bureau has failed to
implement many of the first step acts
reforms let me give you an example the
first step act required the department
of justice and the bureau of prisons to
develop a risk and needs assessment
but the pattern tool that the agencies
created is deeply flawed
the trump administration itself
forecast that the tool would result in
stunning racial disparities in inmates
security classification
in december the independent review
committee appointed by the trump justice
department released a report that found
the bureau of prisons has failed to
develop and i quote a fully integrated
and comprehensive needs assessment
system to diagnose the programming needs
of individual inmates a system the first
step act requires you to develop i might
add that part of the first step back was
constructed by senator cornyn and
senator whitehouse
on the prison reform side of the
equation
the law also mandates the bop provide
all prisoners with opportunities to
participate in programming to prepare
them to return to their communities
however many inmates still struggle to
access programming to help vocational
skills and receive mental health and
other services
the simple fact of the matter is and we
know it the majority of federal
prisoners today will be out in society
at some point soon in their lives we
have to anticipate it we want that to be
a constructive positive experience and
not create another crime victim
the legislation also requires inmates to
participate in programming through
earned time credits but the bureau
prison's proposed rule for earn time
credits severely limits the ability to
earn these credits and that undermines
participation
the bureau's failure to implement the
first step act reform speaks to a
broader issue of mismanagement that has
impacted everyone in our prison system
from the incarcerated to your own loyal
employees
for years the bureau of prisons have
been put by plagued by chronic
understaffing it has been worsened by
the previous administration's decision
2017 to implement a hiring freeze that
led to the elimination of more than six
thousand bureau prisons positions today
there are still thousands of vacant
positions
to compensate for staff shortages the
bureau has come to rely on widespread
and often mandatory overtime as well as
augmentation augmentation is a practice
that forces
non-custodial staff like secretaries
teachers and librarians to work as
correctional officers
the council of prison locals which
represents most bop employees notes in
testimony for the record today that
quote the staffing crisis in the bureau
of prisons not only creates a large
clear and pleasant present danger to
every employee inmate in the community
at large but has made the response to
covet 19 pandemic nearly impossible
the americans working in our prison
system are overworked over overextended
and under-supported
as a result incarcerated individuals and
the communities to which they return are
put at risk
simply put our prison system at the
federal level is failing it's failing to
fulfill its fundamental purpose the
rehabilitation of incarcerated
individuals
as i said most of the individuals are
going to return to society instead of
preparing them we are failing them and
failing american people who want of
course safety in our communities part of
that failure includes the excessively
punitive and unjust practices to
maintain order in our prisons practices
like administrative separation or
solitary confinement
following my hearings in 2012 and 2014
there were significant reductions in the
use of solitary confinement but i am
troubled that the number of federal
inmates in restricted housing increased
significantly over the last four years
i'm gravely concerned that during the
pandemic the bureau has a used extensive
solitary confinement as a means to
enforce social distancing you just can't
separate people 23 hours a day without
an impact on their mental health
this oversight hearing is an opportunity
to get a clear accounting of what's
going wrong in our federal prisons and
what we need to do to fix it
we can start by vaccinating our inmates
in a timely manner
not only for their protection but the
protection all the men and women in the
federal employment who maintain these
prisons
i'm eager to hear about the bureau's
plans when are we going to implement the
first step deck how are we going to
build the reform on the reforms that we
passed on a bipartisan basis signed by
president trump we can't keep wasting
valuable resources and taxpayer dollars
to let people languish in prison
more than wasteful it's inhumane
too many lives have been lost too many
spirits broken by abuse and mistreatment
too many families turned apart torn
apart let me turn to senator grassley
before i start my statement i want to
make two points one would be to ask
without objection for
the record a statement by the national
association of assistant u.s attorneys
be included
without objection and then uh you
reminded me of something when you talked
about senator
cornyn's involvement in our first step
act you and i keep referring to your and
my cooperation on it but we have not
forgotten i know you haven't uh senator
cornyn senator lee senator booker is
here now and i don't i'm proud of the
white house i'm brian
yeah and i'm probably leaving somebody
out but at least those and then we got
to remember when you and i were starting
out with a small group of people uh on
this that when it finally passed it
passed 87 to
so we wondered where did all this
opposition come from for so long a
period of time with such an overwhelming
passage of our legislation but i make
these points because too often you and i
refer to each other and we don't we
neither one of us intend to leave out
other people that cooperated you should
always mention those other people one
time for sure yeah okay and no more than
one time right
okay
let's go to uh
carvalho we welcome you
we thank you for being here i look
forward to your answers to committee's
questions as the issues before us are
very extremely important
the committee last held an oversight
hearing
uh with the bureau of prisons 2019
that was pre-covered and before the
first anniversary the first step act
uh
and
and obviously as senator
durbin has said a lot has changed so
it's about time that we dig in discuss
these issues
in december 2018 president trump signed
the first step act getting the first
step act passed was a very difficult
effort as i've already referred to
it required buy-in from nearly all
members of congress the white house the
federal agencies including your agency
chairman durman and i
uh teamed up to get the first step to
act past two and a half years ago
and i'm grateful for the continued
collaboration that i have with the
chairman uh working together
i consider the passage of the first step
act as one of my uh
good things that i've done since being a
senator
it's because of the hard work and
overwhelming bipartisan nature of the
first step act that i'm disheartened
with lackluster
implementation it seems as though the
justice department and within that
department the bureau of private prisons
are implementing the first step act
as if
they want it to fail i hope this isn't
true but actions speak louder than words
and the inaction of the justice
department the bo
p
on this uh i think paid
a very difficult picture
i understand that the covet 19
pandemic
hijacked many of the implementation
efforts
but
your agency must do better and follow
the law without excuse
an example of half-hearted
implementation
is the
prison programming
programming is critical for inmates it
prepares them
to successfully re-enter society and
allows them to earn time credit towards
their sentences without effective
programming
inmates will leave prison unequipped
and
possibly prone to reoffend
but the
agency has been slow to resume programs
for prisoners in light of kovi 19
restrictions the lack of programming is
sending
inmates up to fail
also
the justice department still hasn't
issued a complete needs assessment tool
as required by the act
the risk and needs assessment system is
critical in evaluating inmates
individual recidivism risk
and tailoring appropriate programming to
combat those risks
without complete needs assessment tools
the law is only partially fulfilled
so
another failure of implementation
lastly a current
justice department position on home
confinement fails to comply with the
spirit of the first step act
march 2020 attorney general barr
responded to calls
by
this senator and chairman durbin
to increase the use of authorities in
the first step act to place inman
inmates and home confinement to mitigate
the risk of
the virus spreading
earlier this year the justice department
released a memo
stating that when the pandemic hands
nearly 4 000 non-violent inmates who are
currently at home
in confinement
will be returned to
the prison secure custody program
this means that almost 4 000 people who
have abided by the terms of home
confinement will be removed from their
homes and returned to the facility
obviously
if they can stay where they are it's
going to save the taxpayers a lot of
money
and it would also help people who aren't
prone to reoffend
and allows inmates to successfully
re-enter
society as productive citizens so mr
director i look forward to our
discussion on how you can re-examine and
prioritize
this important legislation we must also
at this time discuss the bureau of
prisons response to covet 19 pandemic
as of april 14th 230 federal inmates
and agency staff members died from covet
people are incarcerated to pay their
debts to society
but they shouldn't have to pay with
their lives
i urge you to use your position as
director to ensure that
not one more life is lost
from the virus and i hope that this
hearing allows us to look forward
i'm encouraged
by your optimism mr director for the
future of the bureau of prisons your job
is difficult and often thankless and i
suppose i've haven't been very thanking
to you in my remarks
but it's credibly important for the job
to get done the weight of success of the
first step act is on your shoulders and
your leadership will undoubtedly be
critical in navigating federal
corrections in post-virus world finally
i want to remind you that the bureau of
prisons has responsibility to respond to
all congressional inquiries including
those from the minority in a timely and
complete complete manner i sent you a
letter in march 2020
and it's been more than a year with no
response
and that should be considered by
everybody including you is unacceptable
when i was chairman i made the same
point on behalf of my democratic
colleagues
that responsibility
falls to you the justice department fbi
need to have a real
problem with that responsibility
seem to have i strongly urge you to send
a letter answer the letter i look
forward to working with you thank you mr
chairman i'm sorry i took so much time
no that's just fine thank you very much
senator grassley let me tell you today's
hearing
after i introduce and swear in director
carvajal we'll have a five-minute
round of questions
i'd say by way of introduction
of the director
michael carvajal began his career with
bureau prisons as a correctional officer
in texas in 1992
in july 2016 he was promoted to regional
director of the northeast region and
became the assistant director for the
correctional programs division in 2018.
former former attorney general uh
general william barr appointed him as
bop director in february of 2020. so
director carvajal would you please stand
to be sworn
do you affirm the testimony you're about
to give before the committee will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so happy god
let the record reflect that the
director answered in the affirmative and
now please be my guest and make your
opening statement
thank you and good morning chairman
durbin ranking member grassley
could you check your microphone maybe
pull a little closer
that's great thank you
should be a red light there okay good
morning chairman durbin ranking member
grassley and other distinguished members
of the committee it's my privilege to
speak today on behalf of the 37 000
bureau prisons corrections professionals
who work day in and day out to support
our critical law enforcement mission
i am committed to ensuring that these
dedicated men and women are guided by
the core values of respect integrity
correctional excellence and courage
i appreciate this opportunity to discuss
the bureau's response to the pandemic
along with our efforts to provide
inmates with the necessary programming
to return to the community and to their
families
i have spent the majority of my
professional life in career service to
this agency
after serving in the united states army
i joined the bureau as a correctional
officer and moved up through the ranks
to my current position as director
i care deeply about our work
and the personal sacrifices the bureau's
law enforcement officers make and have
made during the pandemic and more
importantly our way forward
coveted numbers have dropped
significantly across nearly all of our
institutions even as inmate movement has
resumed
and despite communities reopening
we are taking the steps to normalize
operations and stages as safely
and with security permits including
inmate movement food service and ramping
up programming all of these efforts will
have a positive effect on staff inmates
and the bureau operations
as we have throughout the pandemic we
continue to assess and adjust our
operations as guidance evolves and more
importantly to incorporate the lessons
learned
in close coordination with the cdc and
federal government's covet 19 vaccine
therapeutics operation we pursued an
aggressive strategy to administer the
vaccine
all staff have been offered the vaccine
and by mid-may we anticipate all inmates
within our institutions have been
provided the opportunity to be
vaccinated the bureau has also assisted
administering the coven 19 vaccination
to other doj personnel
we worked with the doj leadership in
planning two vaccine clinics one in
miami one in new york
to assist the dea fbi and other law
enforcement components
received the vaccination through these
clinics more than 1100 law enforcement
personnel were vaccinated and while it's
been an extraordinary year with many
challenges we continue to move forward
and advance our priorities there's been
much discussion about the bureau's
staffing needs and the use of
augmentation and overtime to accomplish
our mission
we're committed to addressing these
issues by increasing our staffing levels
nationwide and retaining our staff
we initiated a hiring campaign focused
solely on external hiring to maximize
staffing levels and we're using all
available recruitment and retention
incentives marketing strategies and
social media
to reach potential candidates
in the last calendar year despite the
pandemic we hired 3 800 staff
in the past eight weeks we've hired over
500 new staff into the agency
our aggressive hiring initiative our use
of incentives along with a revised
method for calculating bed capacity
will provide clarity transparency and
have a significant impact on our
staffing efforts moving forward
our staffing efforts are central to the
successful implementation of the first
step act
i'm pleased to tell you that despite the
pandemic we are on track to meet the
requirements of the first step act
staff positions allotted under the first
step back have already been utilized to
expand capacity in our female programs
our drug treatment and vocational
training
other innovations are underway to
enhance programs such as life skill
laboratories to teach the skills to
basic inmates with the greatest needs
provide stem career technical education
for female offenders and modernizing our
inmate education platform to include the
use of tablets to make programming more
accessible
we are committed to successful
implementation of the first step act and
its impact on reducing recidivism
finally a key priority where we're
squarely focused on is our work with a
government accountability office related
to the management of staff and resources
in an effort to accelerate this work
i've established a cross-agency task
force to develop an action plan to
resolve the issues in a timely manner
our work will focus on strengthening new
programs and initiatives that will help
inmates prepare success for successful
return to the community we're working to
develop stronger data analytics
platforms which will enhance monitoring
and evaluation of our programs and
spending to this end we're engaging
external organizations to assist in
assessing a broad range of operations to
further these goals
on behalf of all the staff who are
working tirelessly to carry out our
important mission i thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you today for
your continued support to move these
priorities forward
chairman durbin ranking member grassley
and other distinguished members of the
committee this concludes my statement
thanks director carvajal last march
senator grassley and i along with
bipartisan group of 12 additional
senators wrote to you
and to the attorney general william barr
to express serious concerns about the
health and well-being of prison staff
and inmates at the time the number of
infected
prisoners was reported to be three and
staff another three
that was at the earliest earliest stages
of our realization that coveted 19 was a
serious threat to the public health it
didn't take a degree or dr fauci's
resume to realize that our prisons
were
particularly vulnerable because of so
many people gathered in such a limited
space
well we know what happened as a result
of it
we came up with the first step act and
other policies which established the
opportunity for home confinement and
compassionate release
to reduce overcrowding and to allow
those prisoners who we perceive not to
be a threat to society to have a chance
to leave that prison setting
let me tell you the story of one of
those prisoners
forbes magazine reported a man named
jimmy monk
jimmy monk
was a young man a first-time offender
he was convicted of a nonviolent bank
fraud offense his term in prison was
less than a year
he collapsed in a shower and died from
covet 19 at the minimum security
talladega federal prison camp the bureau
of prisons reported he had no covet 19
symptoms
but his emails home and reports from
those inside the prison tell a much
different story
the reality was that he had multiple
symptoms received no medical attention
after he passed out in the shower his
fellow inmates rushed to help him but
the guards ordered them to leave him
unable to even sit in a chair without
the help of others he fell
hit his head and died on the floor
why was a man like jimmy monk a
first-time offender convicted of a
non-violent bank fraud offense with less
than a year to serve not placed in home
confinement
were you given orders from above in
terms of compassionate release and home
confinement to restrict the number of
opportunities that would be offered
no chairman dermott i was not given any
direction like that on the contrary i
was issued two memorandums by the
attorney general
that directed us to consider under the
cares act everyone eligible for comb
confinement in those memorandums with
specific guidance for criteria i assure
you that if that individual you're
speaking about i won't speak about
individual cases but in general any
inmate that is eligible under the
criteria presented to me by the attorney
general is on home confinement as we
speak
what keeps them or prevents most cases
or that they fall under one of those
non-discretionary hard criteria if you
have a primary offense of violence a sex
offense of terrorism or a detainer an
order for deportation you will not be
placed on home confinement as the
statute is written home confinement
wasn't made for long-term placement it's
a re-entry program as you're well aware
senator six months 10 of your sentence
12 months in the community uh at this
point in time we've released inmates
under the cares act with with more time
than that which is appropriate but
that's why the criteria is important so
we follow the criteria senator so what
is the population i mean i i no one's
going to argue with the groups that you
have excluded from consideration for
compassionate release and home
confinement what is the remaining
population that doesn't fit into those
categories among prison bureau prison
inmates
an easy let me give you an example
senator that when karezak passed we we
ran a roster cares act is a medical
placement
we ran a roster at that point at that
day there was approximately 27 000
inmates eligible for home confinement
under the cares act when we applied that
criteria that number was reduced to 4
000 just by those four criteria okay and
the other that we had discretion to go
beyond that excuse me can you clarify
you said 27 000 out of the total federal
prison population who had at least one
coveted risk factor which is what
specifically the keras act told us
silicon and inmates who are vulnerable
for covid if you're clarified please the
total federal bureau of prisons
population at the time was over 150 000
that is correct
and so you identified some 27 000 who
had at least one covid risk factor
and
of those you excluded many for the
categories you mentioned of crimes we
followed the criteria issued by the
direct by the attorney general at the
time and you said there were four
thousand eligible in the federal bureau
prisons the 4 000 was after applying the
attorney general criteria
i can explain beyond that well let me
ask you i want to stick with the numbers
for a minute how many were actually
released or placed in home confinement
we have we have released over we have
transferred because they're still in our
custody we have transferred over 24 000
inmates to home confinement since
passage of the cares act today there's
approximately 7 400 4 500 of those i'm
using estimates because these numbers
change every day approximately 4 500 of
those on or today are on cares act home
confinement under under specific cares
act
it's my understanding that the
present staff and i don't know how large
a group that is completely
[Music]
they have been offered vaccines and
fewer than one half have accepted the
invitation
senator we we have offered every staff
member in our agency the opportunity to
be vaccinated the rate right now the
last number i got yesterday was a little
bit over 51 percent
uh have accepted now the one caveat
there is that that does not include
staff that we're not aware of who
receive the vaccine on their own through
their own care provider we do know there
are people that have done that but we
have offered the vaccine approximately
51 percent that's about 18 000 staff of
the 37 000 have accepted it
and is there currently a mask mandate
for all staff at bop facilities yes
there is senator there has been for
quite some time and what type of testing
is uh offered to the staff
staff testing is available each location
keep in mind we as you're well aware we
have 122 locations we have a national
contract laboratory
where we can make it available so there
are several types and methods there but
each location worked with a local public
health service to establish
testing sites we do not test staff on
site
we don't have the resources to do that
could you tell me the percent of
prisoners who have been vaccinated
the percentage this morning we've we've
administered over 132 000 vaccine
vaccinations the percentage this morning
was a little over
40 percent about 50 000 or so inmates
again the numbers are changing but as i
stated in my opening remarks our
projections originally were august for
everybody to receive it by mid-may 100
of the inmates in our custody will have
been offered the vaccine and keeping in
mind that it's voluntary the acceptance
rate among inmates is about 66 percent
again that changes daily sometimes
and those who are released is there any
testing before they're released
inmates are quarantined mandatory in and
out quarantined before their release and
if they have prov if they look if we
have symptoms or anything of that nature
then we will provide the test upon
release otherwise they're mandatory
quarantined unless they're showing
symptoms when which pla which time
they're placed in isolation which is a
whole separate procedure
i'm going to
take leave as chairman to ask one other
question senator grassley if you don't
mind
there was a lot of controversy and votes
on the senate floor about sending the
checks
the stimulus checks to 1400 to inmates
in prison
this was a policy that was originated in
the cares act
that was
drawn up on a bipartisan basis and
signed into law by president trump and
there have been questions raised about
what happens to that money for inmates
can you tell us what happens
absolutely it goes to the inmate we've
processed over
right about twenty two thousand checks
for for about nineteen million dollars
we worked with the irs the department of
justice tax division and the executive
office of the united states attorneys to
make sure that those inmates who were
receiving those checks that we worked
through that and they received those
checks if for some reason like with
anything if something occurs where
somebody does all they need to do is
tell us we don't know who's entitled the
check but we have we have ensured that
22 000 times inmates in our system have
received those checks for a total of 19
million dollars out of 150 000 inmates
well sir i'm not sure who who's entitled
to them i don't have that
i'm just asking you yes out of our
current population of 125 000. isn't it
true that money placed in a federal
inmate account that exceeds
excuse me that exceeds 450 dollars
during a six-month period including
stimulus checks for example
is assessed by the bureau of prison to
pay prisoner debts
including restitution to crime victims
and fines well
senator part of our policy and part of
reentry is teaching responsibility so if
an inmate has child support or owes a
fine or restitution that is part of his
reentry plan to to be responsible and
pay those debts
to my knowledge the government we don't
assess that we do make sure that they
participate in the uh program to pay
restitution and things like that so
there are those checks and balances but
we're not taking money from an inmate
there's a record of this everything is
screened and and gone through the the
policy as appropriate but i want to
clarify this
if i'm a prisoner and i have
received a fourteen hundred dollar
stimulus check it's my understanding
that 950 of that could be assessed to
pay any restitution or fines which i
have been ordered by the court to pay is
that true
i believe so senator i i'm not entirely
sure about the policy i haven't reviewed
that policy but
lately but i'm almost certain that
if they have a financial responsibility
part of their reentry plan part of
getting them ready to return to society
95 percent of them will is to be
responsible and make their payments
and child support is the same type of
responsibility i'll support uh anything
where their their their obligations that
is part of being a responsible citizen
and paying their bills thank you very
much mr carvajal senator chrisley you
said in your statement
that implementing the first step act is
a priority
for you
and the current administration and i
hope it is
but i'm kind of would like to know
uh how we're supposed to know that is
there some measurable or goals that
you're trying to meet that we can say
six months from now or a year from now
you're doing what you said you were
going to do
that's a great question senator and i
know that i i wrote a lot of notes
through both of your opening statements
and i hope i have the opportunity to
actually answer these questions because
i'm not sure where you get all your
information but i'm glad you called me
here to be able to answer this because
we are on track to meet the first step
act
uh
last year even through coved which is a
whole another issue as you well know
we had over 50 000 inmates enrolled in
some type of program 21 000 maybe 25 000
actually completed a program those
programs are worth earning time credits
which is what the first step back is
about uh so i'm not sure who's giving
your information uh now could it have
been more absolutely
but i don't know why someone would think
that we would want something that is
part of our mission
re-entry into society is half of the
mission of the bureau of prisons the
first one is the obvious one keeping
people safe so yes we want the first
step back to be successful uh senator
and i appreciate you letting me clarify
that you'd do me a favor if you went
through my statement and
told me what's wrong don't do it now but
you can do that in writing
um
so it's uh i i'm disappointed in the
progress
that the justice department bureau of
prisons have made
we're all acutely aware of the impact
that the coven 19 has had on prisons
but at this point
over one year when president trump
declared covet as a national emergency
i don't think that that national
emergency can be used as scapegoat
being accountable and moving forward is
necessary
i mentioned in my opening state
statement what you might tell me again
would be wrong
that it seems like the justice
department
and the bureau of prisons has failed in
this effort
for it being the most significant
criminal justice law in a generation
if that's
true what i'm saying
then it's shameful i certainly hope that
this sentiment is false
and even if it isn't true at certain
points perceptions become a reality so
if it's
more unreasonable perception
how can you assure me and those affected
by the first step act that the
implementation
that
in this belief is incorrectly held
thank you senator first off you
mentioned
the risk and needs assessment
that was implemented in january of 20
right before covid
i don't know
why someone would think we don't have a
risk and needs assessment it's public
knowledge the irc has acknowledged it we
worked with outside stakeholders to
create this we did not create the
pattern tool that's the department of
justice's tool it was done by
independent researchers
it's been vetted it's under reassessment
now we have a needs assessment we've
always done it informally we didn't do
it very well and formalize it but our
our process has been formalized now
we've identified
again with the collaboration of outside
stakeholders including correctional
experts from other agencies we
established a needs assessment 13 needs
were identified when we go through the
risk process we identify those needs and
then we apply of one of over 80
evidence-based recidivism-reducing
programs or productive activities that
are worth time credits that is the
essence of the first step back so i'm
i'm a bit confused about where people
don't believe that we're doing the
senator i i believe we are doing it okay
now i want to go to home confinement
it's been a very vital tool to decrease
the prison population during covet
and it's successful in monitoring
inmates
uh of the 24 000 inmates who are
currently on home confinement
151 have
violated the terms of their release
and only three have been arrested for
new crime
this highlights how effective home
confinement can be
given this i'm concerned that the
justice department's memo concluding
that the bureau of prisons would have to
recall
some non-violent
inmates currently on home confinement
back into prison facilities
once the pandemic period ends
this policy would result in almost four
thousand inmates on home confinement
being forced to return
to a facility to complete their census
the first step acts goals are to reduce
recidivism while ensuring public safety
all
while making sure
to not burden the taxpayer this seems
that the policy that i referred to from
doj seems to counter the first step act
goals
so do you or do you not agree with that
and besides
the legal reasons
outlined in the justice report or manual
is there any policy reason that inmates
in home confinement under the first half
act or the cares act should be returned
to the bureau of prison facilities if
they're not
if they if they have not violated the
terms of their release or commit a new
crime
great question senator uh first off uh
the portion that i'll start with is
whether or not we're bringing them back
the reason the discussion and and i
would presume that the doj issued that
uh
back in november was the fact that the
statute the the cares act did not change
the statute
the statute as written allows for 10
percent
or 10 percent of their time or six
months up to 12 months in the community
karezak placement extended that
this program was not designed for people
to be out that long
that's the first part we would need to
change a statute or have the authority
to adjust it because we must follow the
law and that's what that's what we're
doing the second piece of this is the
president recently extended the national
emergency so there's no rush to bring
these back we're covered by the cares
act
so we're not advocating
uh
one way either way we're cert we're
planning we were asked can we
accommodate if we need to bring these
inmates back
because they're still in our custody yes
we can you are correct your numbers on
the 151 the three uh that were that were
new
uh
new crimes only one of those was violent
i don't know the the details uh but the
rest of those is we would we would
screen those i want to make something
clear senator that for anyone to believe
that we arbitrarily want to disrupt the
lives of these people after we've put
them out if they have successfully been
out there we're going to use good
judgment and common sense and work
within the law to make sure that we
place them appropriately we have plenty
of bed space in our minimum security
camps if they've proven they've been out
i simply ask that either that statute is
changed so that we can follow the law
because as written we wouldn't be within
the law
or that that we work with the doj as we
do now and the people understand that we
are doing things within the parameters
we're given
we're not doing them out of like or
dislike or anything we we want this to
be successful it's the entire mission of
the bureau of prisons to return people
to society so i don't know why people
believe that we are somehow against this
i will say that we do it responsibly
part part of the direction the attorney
general stated in there was that we
consider the victim that we consider
public safety and we take that very
seriously so when we look at this
criteria and we make these decisions we
make sure that we're not causing a
burden to the to the public either
public safety is part of our we are a
law enforcement agency so i want i
appreciate the opportunity to clear that
up because i don't want somebody to
believe that the bureau prison somehow
doesn't want to let people out that's
not accurate we want to let them out
within our authorities and within the
law
thank you mr chairman
senator grassy let me let you and i work
together on that last question because i
think it's an important one and i think
director carvajal said maybe a change in
the statute is necessary okay and
we've done things like that before
obviously
my question would imply i want to work
with you good well i'm looking forward
to it senator
feinstein
thanks very much mr chairman
um
i have spent a lot of my past in
prisons particularly state prisons
under the california indeterminate
sentencing law sentencing
and paroling women convicted of felonies
in california
and so i'm very familiar
with the atmosphere of these
institutions
i wanted to just ask you a recent study
from the new york times indicates that
at least 39 percent
of prisoners in federal facilities have
been effect infected with covet more
than four times the general rate of
infection in the country
the situation i believe seems to be
worse at the terminal island facility in
california where the virus i'm told has
infected over 70 percent of the
facility's population and killed 10
inmates
according to a january rep the
department of justice's ig staff at
terminal island
ig staff
terminal island struggled to enforce
social distancing
and may not have been quarantining
inmates before moving them to
alternative housing the ig also found
that roughly 60 percent
of facility staff said they did not have
enough personal protective equipment
in light of this director
what efforts have been made to improve
adherence to covid 19 protocols
specifically at terminal island
thank you senator termil island as you
are well aware was one of our earliest
big outbreaks
what you said is absolutely correct we
had a widespread transmission our
ability to social distance in a prison
we learned early on prisons aren't made
for that first of all they're made for
the complete opposite
throw on top of that terminal island has
open dorm and open bays
adds to the problem
it was at capacity or over i don't
remember the exact numbers at the time
so how are you handling that
open wards open bed situation that's
where i'm going senator good we we
reduced the population we've done that
throughout our because of a lesson
learned open bay open dorm not conducive
for for contain containment so we've
lowered the population and spread those
inmates out at the time it at terminal
island was was something where we tried
something new we actually acquired tents
in a couple of cases i believe we at
that location we actually partnered with
a coast guard
we set up temporary housing not orthodox
in a prison the last thing in the world
we want to do is put somebody in a tent
outside uh within the perimeter but we
did that because we saw the the uh the
effect that social distancing had so we
spread people out uh we have used
non-traditional areas to house people we
converted uh factories in some cases
rooms anywhere we could spread people
out we did that early on terminal island
was one of those cases the the oig did
go in there one of the things i'll point
out about that and we certainly
appreciate working with them we we work
hand-in-hand with them they review many
of our facilities one of the things i'll
point out though is it because that was
so early on
senator everybody was dealing with this
we learned a lot of lessons through
covet i wish i knew
then what i know now about it but we
didn't know it at the time coveted was
new to everybody we have a history of
dealing with pandemics very well in the
bureau of prisons okay covid was
different it's extremely contagious it
happened very quickly
testing resources weren't available at
the time they are now they weren't at
the time and things like that i think
that people need to keep into
consideration you can't just empty a
prison overnight it doesn't work that
way we have different challenges within
a correctional environment always
keeping safety and security first so i
appreciate the opportunity to clear that
up
well thank you
in
response to a question for the record i
submitted after you testified before
this committee last june
you indicated that the bureau had
reviewed 40 000 inmates for potential
home confinement at that time
less than one-third of the total number
of inmates in the bureau of prison's
custody
director as of today
approximately how many inmates has the
bureau reviewed for placement in home
confinement
senator i wish i could give you a solid
answer because the numbers have changed
i will tell you that we have reviewed
everyone who is eligible and has a covet
at least a coveted risk factor the cares
act actually the way it was written
allowed us to review 100 of the inmates
but when you apply those hard criteria
that the obvious ones that we aren't
going to bend on the violence the sex
offense that lowered the number to the
27 000. uh if i had to make a guess
because our numbers have shifted over
the last year percentage would be fine i
would say
50 to 75 percent
at least
have been reviewed at this point i'll
have to follow up with you on the exact
numbers
i'm sorry you have the placement
facility then placement numbers
i'm not sure i'm understanding your
question senator well
you indicated that the bureau had refu
reviewed 40 000 inmates for potential
home confinement
what portion of the 40 000 a percent
would do have been home confined
i apologize i wasn't tracking with you
we at this point we have placed over 24
000 in home confinement since the
passage of the cares out of the 40 000.
i don't know if it was that specific 40
000 center in general we have out of out
of our population we have placed over 24
000 in home confinement
well and let me ask one other question
it's my understanding
that um there's an effort to ensure
that every inmate in bop custody
receives the individualized review
required by the attorney general's
guidance
and my question is when will that be
completed and may we see it
the the guidance of i believe what
you're talking about is the direction to
take to indiv individually review every
case eligible for home confinement in
the totality of circumstances and
applying those criteria that's exactly
what we do we follow the direction in
that memo
well may we see the results
i i don't know how i would do that
senator but i'll certainly talk to my
staff what i mean by that is it's not
that i just don't know how we would
accomplish that but i will get back with
you i will follow up with you i just
need to talk to my staff about how we
would present that to you well i will
write you a former letter
asking for the specifics and you can
either adhere to it or not absolutely
but i believe we are entitled to know
this thank you absolutely mr chairman
thanks senator feinstein senator cornyn
mr carl hall
you and i may be two of the only three
people on the committee who know where
three rivers texas is
uh where you started out your service in
the bureau of prisons uh but i just want
to say thank you for
what you do day in and day out i i can't
imagine the the challenges that confront
the director of the bureau of prisons
and i want you to let us know
what we can do to help you accomplish
your goal i'm glad you really you made
the point that you want to be able to
release
inmates when they're no longer a threat
after they've served their their time i
think the perception is just the
opposite
and i'm glad you clarified that
but
in texas as you know
we
made a major effort at criminal justice
reform focused on people who would take
advantage of the opportunity to deal
with their addictions learn a skill
and be prepared for life outside of
prison and it was that state-based
experiment that was duplicated around
the country that formed the basis of my
interest in particular in the first step
act um sheldon whitehouse from rhode
island i think was was my partner on
that and i want to make sure he's
recognized for his contribution too
but
by its name
we didn't expect to stop with the first
step
and we're interested in your
your advice and counsel on what the next
step should be for example
i know the experience in texas the state
system was the legislature
continued to look at
follow-on services that might be
available because i can only imagine
once an incarcerated person is let out
of jail they go to their own old
neighborhood subject a lot of the same
influences they had in the first place
and it's hard
uh it's it's tough i mean you gotta
admire people who can who can continue
their rehabilitation
and
and
want to be constructive members of
society so we we want
i'll just ask you that question for the
record and ask for maybe you and your
staff to let us know what additional
services congress should authorize in
order to make sure that this
recidivism reduction program is
successful once people get on the street
um
sexual assault in prisons is something
that congress has has addressed
previously
and
what i am interested in is
do you know how many
prisoners in the federal
prison system currently have access to
services like telephone hotline services
if they've been a victim of
sexual assault
yes senator all of them
we uh we we make sure that that is uh
that we speak about that from it starts
with admission and orientation obviously
priya plays a big role 100 percent of
our facilities are priya compliant uh
they're reviewed often
we make sure that inmates have the
number they're posted electronic
bulletin boards regular bulletin boards
and we certainly encourage them to come
forward
whether it's the staff or the by the use
of the hotline to report things of that
nature
well i want to make sure that every
victim of sexual assault in our prisons
has access to uh
services
and that hotline number and so i'm going
to follow up with you and and see where
we are and i'm sure
wherever we are we we can always do
better
um
senator durbin asked about stimulus
checks for inmates
there were two votes um
on the floor of the senate one in 2021
and uh senator
cotton and senator cassidy and senator
cruz offered
amendments that would have prohibited
the issuance of stimulus checks to
prisoners
that failed by a vote of 49 to 50. there
was another one
by senator cruz and senator cotton
joined by senator cassidy that would
prohibit any individual who was
incarcerated in a federal or state
prison from getting stimulus checks that
also failed by a vote of 49 to 50.
but just going back on the history of
these stimulus checks under the cares
act
initially congress was
was silent
as to whether prison inmates would
receive those checks the irs took the
position that they were not eligible
and then there was a class action
lawsuit filed
which said that congress
had to
that the irs had to comply
because there was no pro explicit
prohibition
um
so
i
did i recite the history of of your
experience
correctly in other words originally
congress was silent then the irs took
the position they weren't entitled then
there was a class-action lawsuit that
said since congress was silent they had
to be provided
is that correct
senator i don't know about the specifics
uh i do know that there's a class action
lawsuit i do know that the bureau
prisons for a fact is not one of
defendants
and as with everything that we do we
follow the law the legislation and we do
with what's within our authorities and
that's what we've done we've ensured
whoever made the decision and how it was
made once it was
there we followed it so as i stated
early we made sure that inmates who
receive those checks receive those
checks working through the irs the doj
and other appropriate offices that's
what i do know sir
mr chairman i ask one follow-up question
you've been asked about prison
overcrowding particularly in the face of
the pandemic
and i would note that
at the beginning of the biden
administration there was an executive
order
issued by the administration prohibiting
the use of private prison facilities i
believe now there's there were roughly
14 000
federal inmates in those private
facilities
does that executive order make it
easier or harder
for you to deal with the overcrowding
issues that were raised earlier where
are you going to put these folks
thank you senator i know that uh
there's been much talk about that
we were working on we we
continuously assess our population it's
been trending downward long before
mid-year last year long before even the
election or the change administration we
determined we didn't need certain amount
of beds because of the
trending downwards so we had allowed two
or three contracts expire we're down to
eight there's eleven thousand in there
right now thirteen thousand
thirteen thousand beds we don't need two
thousand of them those are expiring so
this was well in play well well before
the executive order uh we have fifty
five 000 empty beds in our system right
now
uh so we have ample bed space so part of
my responsibilities as you know uh
senator is being a good steward of
taxpayer money and utilizing our funds
appropriately so if we don't need a
contract i am not a political appointee
i'm a i'm a careerist and i do my job
and i make sure that we appropriately
spend taxpayer money if we don't need
that bed space it has nothing to do with
quality we have partnered with the
privates for years because we did rely
on them when our account was at 220 000.
we simply don't need the beds right now
that may change in the future right now
the bureau of prisons doesn't need those
beds it has nothing to do with quality
or anything else we simply don't need
the beds so that's unrelated to the
crowding issues that were raised by the
chairman and others
i'm not sure what crowding is down 7
percent system wide
part of that was because we did release
inmates on the on the again through the
cares act or 24 000 uh or on home
confinement and that doesn't count
normal releases so we have ample bed
space at one point in time we were at
220 thousand we absolutely needed help
from the privates or or people may it
might have been an unsafe environment at
this point in time today our population
is 125 000
and we have 55 000 approximately 55 000
open beds so it's not an issue right now
the best way for me to explain it
senator cornyn i'd just like to clarify
i think that director carvajal made this
point too
it's just that it's the nature of the
prison system that social distancing is
a challenge
for them so i i wasn't talking about
crowding per se but in context of kova
19. as the directors mentioned the total
population has gone down dramatically
i thought when we were talking about
crowding and social distancing those
were related issues but i appreciate
your
your answer thank you thank you very
much
senator booker
thank you very much uh mr chairman uh
director uh thank you very much for
being here i really appreciate it i
first just want to express uh my my
sympathies i know that we lost
correctional officers uh to covet
i see these as line of duty deaths in
fact i did a wonderful bill with
chuck grassley to make sure that law
enforcement officers who die of covid uh
get the benefits for their families that
they should there's a presumption of it
being a uh
a line of duty death uh but i know that
your job in normal times
uh your the office is under your command
it's an incredibly difficult
challenging job that they put themselves
at risk in service of safety so i just
want to express my gratitude and my
sympathies for the loss for the officers
that were lost during this during this
crisis
the uh risk assessment tool called
pattern
uh that was designed under the first
step act
for good time credits it's been used for
home confinement and compassionate
release during this pandemic however i
i've got serious concerns about the tool
that we've expressed to your uh to your
office um because of the
the perception of bias that's built into
the analysis um and it shows uh a
a sort of a stunning bias uh in terms of
uh
the
the uh number of african-americans
versus number of whites who seem to
qualify under that um pattern tool and
so i'm i'm i'm wondering will the bop
continue to use the risk assessment tool
for purposes of home confinement and
compassionate release for covet 19.
okay thank you senator two two things uh
first off i mentioned this earlier and i
think it's important to point out we did
not develop pattern we assisted in
development through outside researchers
and and scientists outside stakeholder
input
and this tool
showed across race gender and ethnicity
it had the highest level of productivity
and that's why it was chosen i did not
choose it we're the end user it's the
department's tool
uh there has it's been reassessed now
there were some adjustments made in
january of 2020 senator to your point
there was a perceived
or actual uh bias against people of
color so they removed two pieces of that
it was the age of first arrest and age
of first of conviction and voluntary
surrender
that was done to remove that bias
or perceived bias and it also created
more transparency and fairness again i
did not select that tool we are the end
user
but it goes under
review every year there's independent
researchers right now the national
institute of justice actually does the
contracting for that it's being assessed
now so i don't have anything to do with
the assessment we are the end user of
that tool so we will continue to use it
as long as we're directed to use it so i
i know that you all are consulted and
the doj works with you as a as they
develop and perfect that tool yes so
your continued engagement on its
fairness our staff were involved in it
senator uh the same thing with the needs
assessment we worked on the needs
assessment with outside consultants
outside stakeholders some of which were
leadership of other correctional
agencies so that we get a good input of
subject matter experts and we developed
the needs tool we didn't develop it in a
vacuum we do get input from the outside
i was rather shocked at the irc's report
critiquing the tool when they had view
of it an input of it also
so again it still seems to be imperfect
and i'm hoping that you guys have been
very communicative with my office i'm
hoping you'll continue to take input
with us as we try to get something that
is ultimately fair and more fair enough
i understand senator everything can
always be improved and we certainly
understand that and i appreciate your
view this dialogue has been really
constructive and and can we get back to
the just the issue of uh of solitary
confinement in the age of uh of covid uh
for many months um
we we've been looking at the fort dixus
covet 19 numbers uh and they were uh uh
said to be low because of the bop's
action plan
um and the agency uh uh
was taking steps uh in that context uh
but we just believe that that is
actually not the case and that courts
were burying
uh um or buying the argument uh but
denying compassionate release which
people should have gotten and again uh
to give you an example uh mr there's a
man named mr marlonda trujillo uh who
was an individual incarcerated for dicks
whose motion for compassionate release
was denied his underlying health
conditions were pretty significant uh
severe coronary heart disease heart
failure chronic arterial fibrillation uh
severe uh mitral valve
regurgitation i'm trying to say these
things like i'm a doctor but i'm not
multi-vessel coronary art artery disease
chronic
dystolic heart failure
and more
mr trujillo later uh was later put into
quarantine because of his risk of
contracting covet-19 but fort dix's
quarantine process appears to have
spread rather than contain the virus and
tragically mr trujillo died um
and so i i just this is
this is to me a matter of not just
justice but it's a matter of uh
compassion and empathy to keep people
that are so frail in their condition
their risk to the to the population is
so low
and so i just want to continue to
to be engaged with you
on on these concerns we we know in new
jersey
the virus unfortunately is still
stubbornly persistent
and i'd like to just maybe end with just
the question
you know this what steps are are you
trying to take to continue to ensure
that cdc guidance uh uh is is being used
to prevent more unnecessary deaths um
and uh not putting people in in solitary
confinement uh but really trying to lean
into the idea of of that word compassion
and as in compassionate a release and i
i know that this is uh uh
we need to move on to my colleagues but
i'm hoping that you can give me a brief
answer now but maybe we can continue to
have dialogue between my office and and
yours
absolutely senator uh two things i want
to i want to clarify for you i
appreciate the opportunity number one i
i can't necessarily talk about certain
cases but i will tell you in a case such
as the one you described
uh you know the the compassionate part
of all that is is the emotion and i
certainly understand
all of those deaths weigh on me
if we did not
recommend that individual there was a
very good reason i'll give you an
example they may have had a detainer or
something of that nature which is hard
criteria so i have to follow the rules
senator so it it
i and peop sometimes people understand
we're not doing we're not not letting
someone out because we don't want to or
don't support it we're following the
rules as given to us so i appreciate the
ability to clear that up fort dix i
oversaw fort dix as a regional director
as you're well aware at one point there
was over 5 000 inmates here it was the
single largest facility in our agency
one facility
two two separate east and west it's down
about
50 percent capacity i did that based on
my working knowledge of that place
our goal is to get it down because of
the points you said we learned early on
that you can't social distance in an
area like that open barracks so that's
one of the things we did the other thing
i'll point out is from day one
we get
much criticism about how we responded to
covid but we have been in lockstep with
cdc guidance all along and when it
changes it's difficult for us in a
correctional environment sometimes to
apply that guidance but we do our best
to do it our medical director of the
agency speaks to cdc on a weekly basis
sometimes daily basis so i want to
stress that to you that everything we do
is in lockstep with cdc in fact we had
input on the
guidance that cdc put out for
correctional and detention centers a lot
of that came with our collaborative
efforts with them so i don't want anyone
to think that we're making this stuff up
as we go along we are consulting with
the experts out there and making
adjustments it's very hard to apply
sometimes in a correctional environment
because security and safety is always
going to
be first and foremost of everything so
thank you for allowing me to answer that
no sir and again the communication is
really critical and i appreciate that
you having those open lines
thank you senator booker senator lee
thank you mr chairman thank you director
carvalhal for your service and thanks
for being here today
you testified
a month or so ago in front of an
appropriations subcommittee and in your
testimony when talking about private
facilities um
you
described as i understand it those
facilities as as safe
indicating that bop does rely on them
and that they meet your safety standards
i was therefore a little bit surprised
when the executive order came out and
the executive order relied in part on a
conclusion that private contractors
quote unquote consistently on perform
based on your testimony it sounds like
that hasn't been your experience can you
tell me uh
is there an inconsistency between that
finding that they consistently
underperform
and and your experience with them
yes senator again uh i want to stress
the point uh
for the obvious reasons that i'm i'm not
a political appointee i understand i'm a
careerist
so i i have to you know some of this i
have to be careful how i say it because
i don't want to think that i'm playing
anything i'm going to tell you based on
my experience we have partnered with the
privates the determination to quit using
them was made well before even the
election much less the executive order
came out
but to your point
they are held to a statement of work and
a contract if they were underperforming
we wouldn't utilize them so that's the
best way for me to say that i'll follow
up with one piece we do have a contract
to your example
that we issued a issue of
violence and
a notice of violation recently because
they were not performing to standard
there's a process for that i won't get
into the facility or why but that's the
first time i know of that our agency has
done that with
one contractor i assume that yes yes but
but my point is is it it can happen like
anything else it's they're either
performing or they're not we hold them
to the standard that makes sense um
you talked a few minutes ago about um
other aspects of the order what about
the part dealing with the u.s marshals
service as i understand that u.s
marshals service relies heavily on
private facilities
particularly for pre-trial defendants
and at any given time you might have as
many as 62 000 individuals
who have got to be able to make their
court dates in federal court throughout
the country
only 14 of those
defendants are housed in u.s bureau
prisons facilities meaning that the
other six at the other 86 percent have
got to be housed
somewhere else
given the the uh
in light of that order what will happen
what will happen to that uh does bop
have the resources to deal with those 62
thousand
u.s marshals service detainees
well senator i'll certainly defer to
the united states marshal service to to
follow up with that i don't
i don't think it'd be appropriate for me
to speak about their operation
but as i stated earlier at this point in
time uh our
private facilities hold about 11 000
inmates we have approximately 55 000
beds available at this point
but yes we take in inmates from the
marshall service we collaborately work
with them all the time
and part of our mission which we've been
scrutinized early on is movement well
the judiciary did not stop so as you
stated the marshals
take those inmates and they eventually
come to us right so yeah clear those 55
000 spaces aren't necessarily where you
need them
exactly or the us marshall service
detainees correct gotcha
since since the biden administration has
begun
um illegal border crossings
have reached their highest level in
about 15 years
it amounts to
171 000 people crossing over the border
in march
and and that's just the ones that border
patrol is apprehended that's not too far
from the entire population of salt lake
city crossing the southern border in in
one single month salt lake city is just
under 200 000 people
if private facilities are no longer
available
for
use to detain criminal aliens what's
what's the likely effect that this
massive increase of potential
immigrant detainees
what's that what impact is that going to
have on vop
well senator we don't make the
determinant obviously uh the
department of homeland security and
immigration customs service ice
they
they oversee that process we do hold uh
non-us citizens it's about 17 percent of
our population today it's about 25 000
we work collaboratively with with ice
for hearings and they make the final
determination whether someone's going to
be deported or not and we work with them
we don't house inmates traditionally we
have under emergencies for ice but we do
work
with the marshall service so i would
defer any questions about how that
impacts to the department of homeland
security
mr chairman i've got just a couple more
questions may i finish those uh thank
you
um i want to talk about the first step
act something that senator durbin and i
spent
a great deal of time working on over the
years and are proud to have passed
um
that bill includes among other things uh
significant programming for inmates what
what specific programs and initiatives
have you been able to implement under
the first step act for
prisoner development rehabilitation
yes senator we have over 80
evidence-based recidivism reducing
programs or
productive activities as we call them
they range everything from ged and
literacy to secondary education
vocational training is something big
we're trying to expand uh career
technical education you know uh part of
the the whole reentry process is giving
someone the skills to apply when they
get out so all of the trades that's a
focus to try to teach these people a
skill so that when they get out they'll
be productive
we're working on expanding our mental
health treatment
for as i mentioned earlier life skills
some of our inmates
need to learn basic life skills one of
the things that we learned obviously
through co-ed
covid like the rest of the world is the
use of virtual well
prisons aren't built for that our
infrastructure so we're working on
upgrading our infrastructure so that we
can implement virtual uh programming to
inmates so that we don't deal with this
uh you know need to social distance they
can do it from the safety of their cell
so we're looking at implementing tablets
things of that nature
but all of those come with uh security
issues that we have to overcome
uh you know infrastructure issues that
we have to overcome things like that the
biggest focus right now senator is
hiring staff to deliver the program so
that we can expand the capacity so that
more inmates have the opportunity to
earn those time credits
finally um
during covet a lot of americans have
seen their religious liberties and
impaired in one way or another
fortunately for for our prison
population um there are specific
protections in in arlupa as as you know
says that the government can't
substantially burden a prisoner's free
exercise of religion without satisfying
strict scrutiny what steps have you been
taking to to ensure that despite covet
19 and other challenges you face that
incarcerated individuals are still able
to exercise their religious liberties
very important to the bureau prisons
also senator and that's one of the
things that along with our mental health
treatment and our medical treatment we
consider that vital critical our ability
to provide religious services although
they've been modified and somewhat
have always been available even through
coved
we've worked on getting volunteers back
in here lately towards the end now that
people are receiving vaccinations and
stuff but obviously early on it did
impact the ability we rely heavily on
volunteers we have over 11 000
volunteers the majority of them are
religious based that come in we we we
serve over 30 congregate faith groups
there is all types of opportunity we uh
that doesn't count the individuals who
who choose to practice whatever faith
they believe so that has always been
available during covet although it has
been modified at times we've had to make
adjustments like everything else but it
was never not available
thank you very much director carvalho
thank you mr chairman for your
indulgence thanks senator lee senator
klobuchar thank you very much mr
chairman thank you for holding this
important hearing and senator lee
center lee thank you for your work
on this bill i know i've been at
meetings with you and senator durbin
senator booker through
various administrations where you helped
to get the first step act passed and i
want to thank you for that and i guess
i'll start with that i know you've had a
few questions about this uh
director carvajal and
um
um but
you know you talked about what you're
doing to implement that bill
um and i've done a lot of work with drug
treatment programs we have a lot of
good treatment programs in my state and
according to the independent review
committee that was actually established
as part of the first step act
bop has not taken sufficient steps
including prior to the pandemic so i
understand the problems with the
pandemic everyone does but to provide
sufficient access to programming do you
agree with the assessment do you think
there's something wrong with the
assessment
yes i do senator i can't speak for
anything that happened before uh i
wasn't in the process of delivering but
from my time forward i i assumed this
position about a month before covid hit
so
i would have to defer or follow up prior
to that but i will tell you that even
through covid we had over 25 000 inmates
complete
a program for time credits the irc works
with us i'm familiar with the report and
the recommendations they made
but we worked with them to do this we've
expanded our our programs we had over 41
000 inmates participate in drug
treatment or education last year of some
type in the bureau of prisons so i'm not
sure what it is that we haven't provided
i would need some specifics okay well i
think it's in the report that they
talked about
that there that there wasn't sufficient
access they talked about capacity we've
expanded capacity as i stated over 41
000 inmates participated in a drug
treatment or education program last year
even through covet so what you're saying
is you acted on those assessments
yes i i from the time i've been in here
we are taking action to meet the first
step act
okay um let's go to the um
the focus today on the pandemic and um
what's happened there
um
the fight against the pandemic as we
know continues to put more incarcerated
people at risk
the bop announced the deaths of eight
more incarcerated people in march and
april of 2021
in addition to the vaccine of course
testing is one of the best ways to
control the spread of the virus but
according to a report by the pandemic
response accountability committee bop
only tested 30 percent of the inmate
population between february and august
of 2020. since august 2020 as the
percentage of people in blp facilities
who have been tested increased and do
you have that number
senator i know that we have we have uh
conducted over half a million tests in
the bureau prisons of over a hundred and
fifty thousand inmates at least that
that may include testing some twice
things like that i follow the guidance
of the cdc and the and my experts my
medical director uh
early on it's probably accurate testing
resources were not available senator we
would have been applying
well they're more available now but i
just want to look at i want to look at
the percentage and it's okay if you
don't have that if you could give it to
me later that would be great to go from
the 30 to where you are since august
2020.
last june i asked about uh testing of
asym asymptomatic inmates which blp said
it was doing in consultation with cdc
guidelines
do you know what percentage again you
can put it in writing later what
percentage of bop tests have been
administered to asymptomatic inmates
i don't know the number of percentage
senator but
our strategy with the testing is in
lockstep with cdc and correctional
systems now i know that that has uh
changed recently and we're we're working
on that now my medical director is
actually working on a plan going forward
of how we would apply testing
uh if the if the guidance changes but
we've been following the guidance
at one point asymptomatic testing in our
environment was not
recommended because it wasn't a good use
of resources yeah i remember i i know
this way back when my husband had
coveted and i didn't get a test but you
know things have changed over time
because that was over a year ago so
um you testified today when senator
durbin was asking questions um that
while all bop staff have been offered
the vaccine only 51 percent of staff
have been vaccinated is that right
yes ma'am it's about 51
okay why do you think that half of bop
have accepted the vaccine when offered
and that half have not
what steps are you taking to combat the
vaccine hesitancy
well senator we have done a campaign
effort obviously encouraging it
normally as a leader i don't do anything
before my staff other than when i want
to show them by example this is one of
those cases where i myself was
vaccinated to encourage others that it
was safe i've done videos we
collaborated with the national union
at the local level in the national level
to encourage our staff to be vaccinated
it's a personal choice we respect that
we don't mandate it uh but it is in line
with firefighters police critical
critical infrastructure i've seen
everything no i know but it's 95 of male
clinic doctors have been vaccinated
because they don't want to give it to
their patients and i keep thinking of
the inmates that are there that you know
obviously incarcerated but they can't
choose whether or not
the people that are close to them
have decided to have the vaccination so
i guess that's something for us to deal
with on another day but that to me
uh you have literally people who are
incarcerated and then you have people
that have chosen not to get the vaccine
and then i look at the male clinic
numbers or 95 percent and so the people
that go to mayo clinic a place i'm very
proud of in my state you know those
patients don't have that same risk as
the people that are incarcerated um so
my last question is
about
the last may i sent you a letter
expressing concern about how the bop is
assessing eligibility for home
confinement particularly after we
learned about andrea circle bear who
died in federal custody four weeks after
giving birth while on a ventilator and
after testing positive the for the
coronavirus we know that weeks later
paul manafort and michael cohen
were transferred to home confinement
i still don't have the data that i think
i need to release information on how
cases are prioritized and the
demographic data of the people who were
transferred
can we get that i mean what percentage
of transfers were denied because of an
inmate's pattern score the bops risk
assessment tool which senator booker
mentioned
numerous civil rights and legal
organizations have warned is likely to
perpetuate racial disparity and decision
making can we get those percentage
releases so we could look at them
yes senator i will speak with my staff
and follow up on that i'd like to to uh
since you mentioned the pattern score we
have recently expanded the criteria
working with the department uh we are
now
we've been now given the authority to
consider low pattern scores
going forward where before it was a
minimum pattern score was the criteria
working with the department of justice
we have increased that to consider low
pattern scores now so we are working to
get as many people appropriately out
again within the criteria we're given
senator all right thank you
senator cruz
thank you mr chairman mr carvajal
welcome thank you for your service thank
you for your testimony
what currently is happening to bureau
prison inmates
who are criminal aliens
when their terms of incarceration expire
are there are they being
transferred
immediately to dhs for deportation
senator we have immigration hearing
programs at 24 of our sites we work in
conjunction with ice to do hearings ice
makes the final determination of whether
or not they're going to be deported or
not so we have a process that works with
that about 17 percent of our population
are
non-us citizens but again ice working
with them they determine whether or not
they're going to be deported typically
if they make that determination there's
a time frame they come and pick them up
and then they're released to them
so what percent of criminal aliens are
being deported after they've served
their present time
senator i don't know that information
you would have to ask the department of
homeland security i don't track that
system because it did it doesn't it's
not within my authority so
the bureau of prisons doesn't keep
records as to whether
inmates are being released into the
american population or being released
into the custody of ice
yes we do senator i just don't have that
number in front of me we can follow up
with you on that okay i would ask you to
please provide provide those data
um
what does the bureau of prisons do
with inmates to
minimize the risk of covet transmission
like we do with everything else center
we educate them we enforce the rules we
provide face coverance ppe
we try to
spread our population out as appropriate
as we can
put things in place barriers uh
the same thing that i would say everyone
else is doing to minimize the risk you
also have reasonable social distancing
so that inmates are not crowded in too
closely with each other
that was a challenge because prisons are
made to contain people closely so that
has been one of our biggest struggles
but we are doing the best we can
at this point and with a reduced
population we've been able to do that
we're redistribu redistributing our
population we put covid target
population numbers on those open dorm
facilities for the reason you said so
that we can allow more space between
them and we've expanded the use of
non-traditional areas to spread them out
a couple of weeks ago
i led a delegation of 19 senators
who traveled to the southern border
traveled to the rio grande valley and we
saw firsthand the crisis that is
unfolding
on our southern border
we visited the donna tent facility
which
was constructed to meet this enormous
surge of illegal immigration that is
happening right now
the biden administration
had implemented a ban on media seeing
what was happening at the donna facility
it's an unprecedented ban prior
administrations did not ban the media
from going in the trump administration
allowed the media in
the obama administration allowed the
media and the bush administration
allowed the media in the clinton
administration allowed the media in the
biden administration blocked reporters
and cameras from seeing what happened
the donna tent facility is this enormous
tent city
it has a capacity of a thousand
it was built to hold a thousand people
under covid restrictions its capacity is
250.
the day we visited the donna facility
there were over four thousand two
hundred people
crammed into a facility designed to hold
250 people with coveted restrictions
we saw firsthand the biden cages
joe biden is building more and more
cages filled with children
and the cages are more and more full
than they've ever been
in these biden cages we saw little boys
and little girls
they weren't six feet apart they weren't
three feet apart they weren't even three
inches apart
they were lying side by side by side on
the floor they had no beds they had no
cots they had no mats on the floor
holding emergency reflective
blankets the rate of covid positivity in
the donna facility is over 10 percent
what we saw is inhumane it is a
humanitarian crisis it's a national
security crisis it's a public health
crisis
and it was preventable it's the direct
consequence of political decisions made
by joe biden and the biden
administration
in the federal bureau of prisons would
it be acceptable for federal prisoners
to be housed
in cages where they were side by side
lying next to each other packed in in
the midst of a pandemic
senator the simple answer that is no we
we are scrutinized often for how we
house our people during covet as i
stated it's a challenge but
we absolutely treat everyone
with dignity and respect we have
standards and we meet that regardless of
what day it is or what's going on and is
there any federal bureau prisons
facility that would be allowed to
continue
at one thousand seven hundred percent
capacity which is what the donna tent
facility is right now
again senator i've never experienced
that i know we've been overcrowded
before we're fortunate at this point
that we have ample bed space but i i
can't i don't want to answer that
because i don't know the answer uh i
haven't faced that
to be able to tell you that
well
all of this is continuing and it's
getting worse and it's getting worse
because of political decisions the by
biden administration continues making
thank you
senator padilla by remote i believe
yes
thank you
mr chair um
sarah padilla i'm sorry your
transmission hear me okay
didn't start off well want to try again
let's try it
you want to try okay does that matter
we'll see
i'll try to keep it brief
i know several of the issues i wanted to
raise today have already been asked
including uh
uh clarity and uh
a better picture on home confinement and
the numbers of violations
uh etc so appreciate senator grassley
raising that earlier in today's hearing
i'll keep my remarks in question to one
specific uh issue and that is this
recently california governor gavin
newsom announced plans to close a state
prison in susanville california that has
seen a steady decline in population
with covert 19
being one of the immediate causes of the
decline but in closing the prison
it presents the state a tremendous
opportunity
to take some of
the funds that are saved through that
closure
and invest elsewhere in state priorities
while maintaining public safety
these funds could soon be reallocated
for a number of projects and programs
for the state so my question for
director carbajal is this
the federal prison population has been
steadily declining for years
and the fallout from covet 19
as well has further reduced the prison
population
have you considered closing any
facilities and allowing an opportunity
for the federal government to more
strategically reallocate funds
and address staff shortages at the same
time
senator that's a great question uh the
the
simple answer is we're not there yet we
are working as we speak on our
realigning and re reworking our capacity
as i stated earlier
one of the biggest challenges of the
bureau prisons is our aging
infrastructure over one-third of our
facilities are over 50 years old and 45
percent of them are over 30 years old
which makes it rather challenging these
these uh these things deteriorate at a
faster rate because of their consistent
365
day use in harsh conditions sometimes so
as we re redistribute our population
again as i stated earlier part of my uh
responsibility to make sure that we put
taxpayer money to good use at some point
working through the department to to see
what our needs are there may be
recommendations on on just that but at
this point i i would say the answer is
no
but it certainly isn't anything that we
would rule out in the future
okay well i'd appreciate a commitment
for an ongoing conversation on that
front i think we can be you know more
strategic more effective more efficient
frankly uh in uh both maintaining public
safety but reforming uh
how we uh not just house but
help inmates
who do have an opportunity to reenter
society do so on a more
constructive
basis going forward so thank you for
your testimony today
thanks senator padilla senator sass
thank you chairman uh director thanks
for being here and thanks for your
forthright manner thus far in the
hearing i'd like to ask some questions
related to the jeffrey epstein case um
epstein obviously was a wealthy
financier who ran a global
sex trafficking ring that pla prayed on
scores and scores of young women and he
and his cronies committed some of the
most repugnant crimes imaginable against
these young women and yet he was allowed
to die in the bureau's custody despite
being a known um suicide risk uh he
deprived or the the failures of the
bureau in in that apparent suicide
deprived not only all these young women
of having their
day in court and justice to be done and
meted out in a public way the way we do
in this country but in addition he took
with him to his grave all of the
additional evidence he had against
many of his co-conspirators and so i'd
like to ask can you think of any case
that approaches the epstein case in
terms of a crisis of public trust for
the bop is there any case that rivals it
no senator i can't think of one
so we're agreed thank you for that
answer um we've had directors of the bop
in the past who gave long-winded
meandering answers so they didn't have
to acknowledge that we needed to have
more resources focused in this case
obviously it's the most basic duty of
the bop to keep prisoners alive so i
guess as a strategic management matter
does every prisoner merit equal
treatment or do some inmates such as
those at the center of a sex trafficking
ring where there's lots of evidence that
hasn't yet been gathered against other
conspirators
do some prisoners merit special
attention and special measures to make
sure that their life isn't at risk
well senator first off i'd like to say
that we
we certainly treat people fairly but um
all of our inmates the cases like you
just
described there we
we apply the appropriate amount of
security needs things like that so
they're all special cases without
getting into specifics which i don't
think would be appropriate about how we
do certain things for certain inmates
the simple answer is that's part of our
job to assess that and to apply the
appropriate amount of supervision and
security and if it requires more in some
cases then we should be doing that if it
doesn't we should that's what that's and
that's that's what we do so can you
thank you uh can you give us a top line
on what went wrong in this case i
recognize that we have two guards who
are about to go to trial in the case so
i understand that there's an ongoing
investigation but we're also over a year
into this uh investigation and past
directors of the bureau haven't given
this committee any adequate answers i
mean just bureaucratic nonsense we're
well over a year into the investigation
so what can you tell us about what went
wrong senator you're probably not going
to like my answer but it's a it's a
statement it's a fact that i can't
discuss it because it's still under
investigation i had my deputy director
call the office of inspector general
last week week or so ago to get the
status of the investigation we were told
that the investigation is on hold until
which time the trial that is set for
june as you mentioned
takes place i don't control the
investigation that is up to inspector
general horowitz you'd have to discuss
it with him
so it'd be inappropriate for me to talk
about anything regarding that other than
what i've said already
i understand that there will be things
that could be used in court about the
prosecution of the two guards that can't
be discussed here i don't understand why
you wouldn't be able to explain to us
what we know about the security footage
what particularly is missing and how did
that happen these guards aren't being
investigated for anything related to
their destruction of evidence as far as
i'm aware
so there i get that there's an
investigation that does touch on a
prosecution of two individuals but many
more systemic things went wrong than
just the things these two guards are
being charged with and so a year year
and a half into the investigation we
don't have anything to publicly say to
the taxpayers or these victims yet
senator here's what here's what i would
say to that is again i can't speak about
something that isn't under investigation
here's what here's what i will commit to
that after that investigation is over
and uh all of these things have been
appropriately done i will absolutely
follow up with you on anything
regarding what we could do better
different i don't think it'd be
appropriate for me to get into any of
that right now because there's even a
chance so it's under litigation i've
been advised not to speak about it but
not because i don't want to because it's
not appropriate right now
okay we will definitely keep you to your
word on the pledge for the after action
when this trial is over can you explain
what processes have processes have
changed with regard to high value
targets there are things you've surely
learned that we would want to be
implementing to make sure that other
high value targets obviously every human
life uh is is equal in dignity in the
eyes of god but for the purposes of
investigation of co-conspirators we care
more about keeping certain prisoners
alive because they're necessary to be
evidence and testimony in other cases
what processes have we changed to make
sure other high-value targets are not
able to commit suicide in a situation
like this well again senator without
getting into specifics which i don't i
don't think would be appropriate in this
forum i i will say that we
uh we treat people as appropriate for
their security needs
first of all
whether or not someone's valuable to to
a case or whatever is irrelevant to us
that's someone's job to do we treat
everyone
everyone's life of value we're going to
apply the appropriate security so
again it's something that i don't think
is appropriate to speak about now but i
certainly will follow up with you at
which point i can
have that discussion with you i've given
you credit for being forthright up to
this point but i don't i don't think the
answer you just gave aligns with where
you started i think you acknowledged at
the beginning that certain prisoners are
more important for the purposes of
public trust and for other public
investigations and other prosecutions
that are happening ms maxwell
mr epstein's chief of staff or
conspirator or whatever we want to call
her
she is of greater value to public trust
than the median inmate in a facility
today so are you telling me that there's
nothing additional that's being done to
make sure that she can't commit suicide
relative to just the median prisoner in
any of your facilities
we apply appropriate security uh you
asked me a question earlier what have
you learned again without getting a
specific senator
the answer is we learned lessons from
that and we have made adjustments it's
just not appropriate for for me to
discuss them but
not for the investigative reasons or
whatever we assess the security and the
needs of someone who comes in you use
the word high value
special security needs whatever we are
going to apply the appropriate security
that we think we need to do to protect
that individual protect the staff
protect everyone and we do that
individually assessing these cases
um i've got more i'd like to discuss
with you about this but the the chairman
gets the gavel back so i'll follow up
offline thank you sir yes sir thank you
senator sass senator ossoff i believe is
by remote are you with us senator
yes i am thank you mr chairman uh thank
you mr cavalha for your presence today
will you please provide to the committee
uh an accounting of the policies
practices and procedures that are
implemented by bop bop to ensure the
preservation and retention of closed
circuit camera
footage and other evidence relevant to
investigations
yes senator we have policies and
procedures uh to retain that uh some of
the issues that we've we've faced in the
past were
not necessarily retention they were the
things didn't work it was our it was our
aging infrastructure we have over 24 000
cameras in the bureau prisons and we in
the last 18 months we've upgraded 116 of
those systems it's a resource issue
we're trying to get with a modern era so
to speak it's a fiber optics upgrade so
that we can go to digital platforms some
of the issues we've encountered in the
past and certainly i have knowledge of
that as a warden in some of these
facilities that sometimes the cameras
weren't working when they should have
been
because things get old and dated so
we're committed to replacing those we're
working on that now we've always had
retention of systems in place
most of the time when we didn't have it
it was because the camera was broken or
there was a a mechanical issue
thank you mr carvajal i'd like to just
amend the request and this is a request
for the record i'd like you please to
provide to the committee
uh an accounting of those practices and
procedures and also a list of identified
incidents where such footage was lost
within the last two years can you do
that for us for the record please
we will follow up on that uh i don't
have that information in front of me uh
senator but we can just
forgive me i just like your commitment
that you'll provide that information to
the committee
i i will take that back to my staff and
see what we can get you senator
okay well we can certainly compel that
disclosure uh if it's not offered
voluntarily but i hope that we can get
that on a voluntary basis um can you
please also provide to my office and to
the committee
an accounting of how many individuals in
georgia are currently serving their
sentences on home confinements due to
the covet 19 pandemic
yes senator again i don't have specifics
for that for that state but i can
certainly thank you i'd be appreciative
if you could provide that information to
my office and
to the committee and i'd like to touch
on this question
of covid19 vaccines for
bop personnel
with a particular focus on usp atlanta
but also taking a national perspective
what steps are you currently taking to
encourage adoption of the vaccine
by personnel at usp atlanta and what do
you assess to be the public health
benefits and the health benefits within
federal facilities such as usp atlanta
and
for the population of incarcerated
persons of having greater vaccine
adoption by bop personnel working at
those facilities please
well senator we encourage the staff to
take it but we also
because it's not mandatory we respect
the right to make the choice and and i
have to do that uh
we believe that
the way the vaccine was distributed now
that it's available that
inmates were protected under the
umbrella of staff being vaccinated
that's how the that's how it was rolled
out that's why staff were
chosen first to do that but once again
we have to respect the rights of an
individual to make that choice with that
said we encourage it we educate staff we
we try to lead by example in case as i
mentioned earlier where i i have been
vaccinated i put out video messages we
collaborate with our union
they do the same to encourage staff but
at the end of the day it's it's an
individual choice
thank you for that mr carvalhon would
you be willing to work with with my team
and
to communicate with the leadership at
usp atlanta about how we can work
collaboratively to encourage
vaccine adoption by personnel at usp
atlanta in the interest of the health of
employees at the facility as well as
those who are incarcerated there
yes senator i will
thank you so much uh mr cabal thank you
again for your testimony and mr chairman
i yield back thanks senator [ __ ]
senator holy thank you mr chairman
director thanks for being here a few
months ago dogs doj's office of legal
counsel i took up the question what
happens to prisoners released into home
confinement i'd like to return to that
if we could the opinion there concluded
that since some inmates may have
substantial time to go before becoming
eligible for home confinement under
ordinary conditions the bureau would
have to recall these prisoners to
correctional facilities i think we're
talking about 4 000
inmates or more can you give us a sense
of what specific monitoring measures are
being used to ensure that inmates in
home confinement during the pandemic are
complying with all of the applicable
guidelines
yes senator as you stated currently
there's about 4 500 inmates on home
confinement specific to the cares act
what that simply means that under the
current statute that that's 4 500 people
that normally wouldn't be out at this
point in their incarceration they're
being monitored 96 or i'm sorry 94 of
them are monitored by contracts non-law
enforcement we rely on on contract
individuals uh to monitor these most of
them are done electronically or gps
the other four percent are i'm sorry the
other six percent are monitored by the
united states probation federal location
monitoring
and has the bureau been successfully
able to successfully able to track all 4
500 if you haven't lost
track of any inmates during this time
well well uh senator we've returned 150
to custody 21 of that 150 were
specifically for uh i'm sorry 26 were
for escape for them not being where they
were supposed to be uh we found them we
we brought them back to custody as as we
would would be expected
very good
what steps is the bureau taking to
prepare for the return of of all of
these inmates to their respective
correctional facilities well the the
attention we've gotten on that because
of the opinion you you uh stated in
november i believe that the department
of justice put that out
we were we have always it's part of our
mission to prepare for that the statute
currently is written as i mentioned
earlier uh home confinement was not not
intended for long-term placement uh
there's actually about 2 400 that it
would that have a
release date over a year there's a small
number over five years it's about 310
okay those specifically we would have to
address because we wouldn't be in
compliance with a statute so either the
statute needs to change or we need to
make exceptions the good thing about
that right now is that we have time
because the president uh
extended the national emergency so we're
still covered under the cares act our
concern the bop's concern over this is
simply that we're following the law
senator it's not an opinion of who
should be out or not we follow the
criteria we do that fairly we put them
out we're we're concerned with making
sure that we're actually applying the
law as written
what challenges if any do you anticipate
in in returning these prisoners to
custody at the correctional facilities
well there it is necessarily a challenge
senator because we have the ample bed
space we have over 11 000 beds available
at our minimum security camps where most
of those would go if they've been in the
community they certainly could
function at a minimum security camp i
think more so is that if someone's out
there and they're being successful
and they're following the rules
and they've shown that they can do that
then we certainly want to work towards
the whole point of this is if they're
going back to society at some point we
also respect the fact though that these
sentences were imposed by the criminal
justice system and a court of law and we
respect that that's why we get so much
scrutiny about how we do this well we
simply respect the criminal justice
system and we have a responsibility to
make sure that if a judge imposed the
sentence that that sentence is served
but we're working within our authorities
very good let me shift topics
mother jones magazine reported in 2018
that up to 72 percent of prison
technology services which includes
tablets and video visitations are
dominated by just two companies those
companies are gtl and securus
that's in the that's overall that's
nationwide the whole prison system do
you know what that breakdown is for the
federal prison system
no senator off my head i do not can you
can you look into that and get back to
me with what it is i'm wondering how
much communication costs charged by
these two companies to prisons and
prisoners have increased over the last
decade do you have a sense of that i
don't know the specific number for those
companies uh senator uh i'll give you an
example though the cares act called for
freak phone calls for inmates
they're free to the inmate but they're
not free to us we've spent well over 100
million dollars providing video services
and free phone calls
which wasn't included in the budget so
it is a lot of money but we also believe
that that's the right thing to do
because we've we've uh restricted
visitation somewhat so we try to balance
it out but that's the only number off my
head
specific companies i don't know well
here's what i'm here's what i'm driving
at i'm concerned that there's one or two
technology companies who are benefiting
disproportionately from this market in
particular there's also the practice of
these same companies introducing special
lockdown tablets into prisons charging
inmates
by the minute i believe to read material
that's in the public domain all of the
profit goes to the tech companies again
this is public domain material
that seems to me like a bit of a problem
why should these companies just a couple
of them
be profiting
from public domain material due to their
monopolies in this market so i'll follow
up with you about that for the record if
i could thank you for being here today
thank you mr chairman
senator hawley uh i want to clarify
something because there was a
uh an exchange dialogue between senator
grassley and mr carvajal earlier and i
participated in it on the question that
you raised
and it appears there are two or three
things that i would like to clarify for
the record uh it is my understanding
that the cares act gave bop
authority to place inmates in home
confinement
the authority to initially place the
inmate home confinement was limited to
the emergency period of the pandemic
but as
as well as it was crafted the karzak did
not suggest
that the placement would end when the
pandemic's emergency period ended
i believe it was silent on that and then
came an opinion that was handed down i
think you referred to it
on the closing days of the trump
administration january 15th
office of legal counsel and they
concluded that when the emergency uh
situation ended then home confinement
authority ended
i believe this current attorney general
sees it differently or may say it
differently
make that clear may see it differently
i'm going to ask writing a letter and
ask him to clarify where we are in this
situation i think mr carvajal said said
as much earlier that he's looking for
some statutory guidance or other
guidance of what to do now with this
dilemma
and i hope we can clarify it
is that mr carvajal did i mistake her at
the situation senator i appreciate that
uh the the the cares act didn't change
the fundamental statute for home
confinement so we've been placing kare's
act home confinement under that again we
stress we want to follow the law
there was no there's no legal
impediments to bringing them back but
you're absolutely correct it didn't
specify what to do with them that's
simply what we're saying is that we need
to be given guidance on what to do with
these individuals so that we can follow
the law okay i think that's where we
come in playing thank you by requesting
some opinion from the attorney general
which will be my first
uh
effort and if that does not clarify it
to the satisfaction then we'll have
statutory response after that okay
senator blumenthal
thanks senator durbin
welcome to the committee director
carvajal
i want to talk a little bit about
danbury
uh you and i have discussed it before
and i know that you're prepared to talk
a little bit about it today
uh you well know that the way we conquer
this pandemic is to put
vaccines into people's arms whether
they're in prison or anywhere else and
whether they work in prison
or anywhere else
in your written testimony you have
stated
quote at this point all bureau staff
have been offered
one of the covet 19 vaccines
and by april 19th all
inmates will be eligible
for a vaccine by mid-may
we anticipate that all inmates will have
been provided
the opportunity to be vaccinated
we know that being offered or eligible
for the vaccine is not
the same as actually being vaccinated
that's the goal
can you tell me what percentage of the
bureau of prisons
staff at fci danbury have been
vaccinated as of today
yes senator i don't have the numbers
specific to danbury
for vaccinations because it changes uh
daily and and as we offer the rounds
uh i know that our total staffing is
about 51 percent who've been 51 who have
accepted the vaccine uh i can follow up
with you on the specific numbers for for
danbury because again these these things
these numbers change daily and i have
122 facilities senators so i don't have
the exact numbers for every one of them
well i would appreciate your following
up and giving me
that answer do you think you can do it
in the next couple of days yes thank you
uh i have the same question what
percentage
of the inmates
at fci danbury have been actually
vaccinated
again senator i don't have the exact
number or i can't find it in my notes
the numbers i will say though are on our
public website they change daily we
updated daily at 3 p.m i understand they
changed daily so i'm not asking you to
give me that number as of this minute or
maybe
even as of this day but
my understanding is that it's less than
50
at this moment in fact more like in the
low 40s
the acceptance rate in general is about
51 for staff so it probably mirrors that
let me ask you uh and i understand
you're talking about the acceptance rate
i'm interested in the vaccination rate
what are you doing to make sure
that at fci danbury people are informed
that this vaccine is safe
and effective
it's safe and effective whatever
misinformation may be spreading
through
the prison and we know that there's a
lot of misinformation
that spreads in prison what are you
doing
and the bureau of prisons doing
to inform accurately and correctly that
this vaccine is safe and effective
well as i stated earlier senator we we
educate the staff and the inmates we
talk about it we lead by example i
myself am vaccinated i did a video
out to the staff encouraging him i did a
follow-up video just as general
information encouraging them looking
forward to
hopefully the vaccine playing a role in
us normalizing our operations every
location including danbury has a local
ceo and union leadership that walk and
talk and encourage that my staff just
provided me the numbers uh
sir 162 staff have been vaccinated to
date and 323 inmates and what percentage
is there
i don't know the percentage off my head
sir
uh well you'll get back to me with yes
we can
uh
what more can be done to increase the
acceptance rate
senator we're doing everything that we
can uh within our limits we have to
respect people's rights
i've asked these questions senator uh
you know can i make them
take the vaccine the answer is no it's
under an emergency use authorization by
the the you know the fda
we've looked at every avenue okay so
short of compelling someone to do which
i can't do at this point we encourage it
we walk and talk but ultimately like
with everything else center we have to
respect people's rights to either take
it or not and i respect people's rights
too and i
understand yes sir that
you have to respect them and commend you
for it
but if we come to you with some ideas
for what more can be done
you would implement them
yes sir we're always open to improving
our operations and if you have a good
idea that will work for us we're
certainly open to listen to it is uh the
bureau of
prisons currently offering vaccinations
currently
at
fci danbury we're offering vaccinations
as they come in we don't make the
determination of when we get them that
is done through the coved
therapeutics operation we do have a
staff member embedded in there we work
with them and as the vaccines roll out
they determine the amount they determine
where they go and how they'll be
distributed we simply put them in the
arms my understanding is that
vaccinations at fci danbury
were stopped as of late february
now i would have to follow up and find
out if they were senator it was simply
because the distribution assigned to
that area again i have 122 facilities
there that we don't make the
determination that's done by the
therapeutics operation
uh they determine
uh it's kind of a hub and spoke system
they determine the amount i'm gonna
with with apologies i'm gonna interrupt
you because my time is limited
do you know whether
fci danbury is currently offering
vaccination
my
my information is that
they cease doing so as of late february
and my question to you is when are they
going to resume
if they stopped offering them senators
because we haven't been provided the
vaccine to offer them i assure you that
when we get that vaccine through the
normal distribution it is offered we
our wastage is our goal is zero wastage
a shot goes in an arm if if the staff
member doesn't take it they get the
first then it goes into an inmate
uh so as it becomes available we
distribute it and we utilize it it's a
sixty percent you're saying that the
vaccine has not been available at fci
dan i did not say that sir
all right let me
give you a chance then to clarify
the vaccine
is currently not offered at danbury
but it would be if you had the vaccine
to provide the as the vaccine becomes
available as designated by the
therapeutic operation for danbury it is
absolutely offered when it comes out
distributed to them we offer it
let me move on uh and i'm
i appreciate your following up with
additional information on fci denver in
january senator murphy
representative hayes and i sent a letter
to water warden easter
she was then warden
we specifically asked her to describe
fci danbury's current medical staffing
and capacity to provide medical care and
treatment to incarcerated individuals
who become ill due to cover 19 or other
underlying
conditions we were told and i'm quoting
fci danbury medical staff are actively
recruiting in an attempt to fill current
vacant
positions
end quote
to fill current vacant positions
that answer was unresponsive can you
tell me director
how many open positions there are
at fci danbury
and how long those positions have been
open
yeah senator the good news that you
should like this is that they're at 102
staffing which is extremely rare in this
agency uh with that said it's because
they've overhired correctional officers
there is three medical vacancies three
medical
part of the problem there is that we
have trouble competing with the local
obviously there's probably higher paying
jobs in the area so that's one of our
challenges
their numbers for covet are low as we
speak they've gone down they had zero
positive inmates and two staff inmates
and to answer your previous question
because i'm not good at math and i
didn't attempt to do this but my staff
did thankfully 60 percent of the staff
and 43 percent of the inmates have been
vaccinated and i apologize that i
couldn't work that in my head that quick
thank you senator blumenthal i
appreciate that thank you mr director
senator cotton
mr carver hall you just revisited with
senator durbin exchange with senator
grassley so i want to revisit it as well
about cares act home confinement
so under the cares act the bop received
extraordinary authority to put into home
confinement prisoners who would
otherwise not be eligible for home
confinement under prior law is that
correct
and yes and your testimony is that
when the emergency period expires the
bureau no longer has authority to keep
those prisoners in home confinement is
that correct
what what i what i stated senators as
written the statute for home confinement
and our policies it is a re-entry
transitional program made for 10 percent
of their time or six months in home
confinement up to 12 months community
placement there are several inmates
currently on home confinement
under cares act who will fall outside
that guideline in order us to apply the
statute appropriately we we need the
guidance or it needs to be changed
that's what i was trying to
explain so and you have about you said
you have about 4 500 persons under home
confinement now who's currently on
karazak who would otherwise not be there
but are there because of the cares act
at this point in time in their uh
incarceration they would not be because
of that
doesn't mean they wouldn't be eligible
at some point yes and i understand too
that some of those who are
lawfully under home confinement because
of the cares act will time into
eligibility for home confinement under
the prior law uh ten percent of the
senate 60 months whichever is lesser
that's correct that is correct about
2400 of them are over uh a year so half
roughly 50 percent if you extend that
out to 18 months it drops the number to
about hundred uh and the reason i say
that is we could work with a plan we're
working with doj part of our
recommendation would be working with
something like that again i stated
earlier we want these people to be
successful they're coming back to our
community obviously or they we wouldn't
put them out so to bring them back for
two or three or four months
you know we would take that into
consideration but again we we work
within the law so all of those things
need to be we are working with doj on
recommendations on how to do that should
the need arise
but but surely for that segment of that
population that has
years left in their confinement it can't
be the bureau's position or the
department's position that they can now
stay on home confinement just because
they have the good fortune of being
released to it during the pandemic well
senator statutory phrase
during the covered emergency period once
that period ends i understand senator
that's why i'm asking the question
that's why we we we're trying to clarify
this there's roughly uh 310 with over
five years who met the criteria
obviously they're low risk or we
wouldn't have placed them out but in
order to
be compliant with statute we have to
address that that's simply what we're
saying i agree and i think the statute
is perfectly clear on that i want to
turn
to one of the most pernicious problems
that i believe you face and that our
state and local prisons and jails face
as well and that's the problem of
contraband cell phones the inspector
general has listed this as one of your
bureau's top challenges something that
i've heard about repeatedly
from
our corrections officers and sheriffs in
arkansas
and the reason for that is of course
that
the contraband cell phone enables every
other kind of contraband weapons and
drugs and anything else
these cell phones are sometimes used to
run massive drug trafficking rings or
order murders extort people intimidate
witnesses i'll give you just a couple of
examples
one the family of joseph michael wood an
inmate in a maximum security prison in
alabama inmates use contraband cell
phones to extort his family demanding
money to guarantee his safety after his
family had had enough and refused to
answer
mr wood was murdered
another example was the family of
correctional officer osvaldo albarrati
who was murdered in a hit directed by
inmates through contraband cell phones
his offense in their eyes
he'd been performing his job and
confiscating contraband cell phones
i've introduced in the last congress and
i'll introduce again soon and i hope to
have bipartisan support the cell phone
jamming reform act it would explicitly
make clear that state prisons can use
targeted jamming to block cell phone
signals in prison housing units
i've been disappointed
at the telecom company's resistance to
this legislation but i hope they're
going to come to their senses more
of these cases
arise could you tell us director curver
hall what steps the bureau is taking to
address this issue and in particular
pilot programs you had and what you've
learned from those pilot programs yes uh
thank you senator pre covit if you would
have asked me the question what our
number one problem is we always answer
drugs drones and cell phones they're all
connected as you as you alluded to so
it's a severe problem
we appreciate the support from congress
in our budget
we got approp appropriated approximately
12 million dollars to conduct some
pilots we have two ongoing now one of
them is at fci edge field it is a pilot
for managed access which uh is one of
the one of the types and then as you
mentioned jamming we have a pilot
ongoing at usp atlanta and then part of
our florence complex we're also going to
use some of that funding designated to
jam a complex i don't remember off my
head which complex but that's multiple
institutions so it's very much helpful
uh the reason we're running multiple
pilots on different uh this again
federal government certainly you're
aware that we have to to
be fair and assess these that's what the
point of the pilot is depends on who you
talk to of which technology is better or
not but we certainly appreciate the
support
and it is a severe problem yeah and
i'll be eager to hear all the results of
those pilots and to share them with
state officials
um i know the telecom industry has
advocated for so-called managed access
technology and i would leave it in the
hands of state officials to make their
decisions but i want to point out a
third case in which a south carolina
prison was using a managed access
program
and still
a contraband cell phone was used in a
blackmail scheme that ultimately
resulted
in a needless death so to me the easiest
way to solve this problem is just to jam
these cell phones so i appreciate the
work you're doing on this and that you
will share with the congress and share
with state counterparts i also want to
thank you and all of your officers i've
been at facility for city it's an
incredibly difficult job one of the
worst or one of the toughest jobs
in some of the worst conditions we have
with truly violent offenders and i want
to commend you and all the men and women
that work in the bureau for your service
to our country thank you thank you
director carvajal uh i'd like to ask a
question about the issue of solitary
confinement and that of course is
described in many different ways
i believe restricted housing is the term
that bop uses
i've heard administrative separation a
number of different
categories but it usually means that a
an inmate is confined to their self
for up to 22 hours a day and given
opportunity to
leave the cell for exercise or other
reasons for maybe one or two hours is is
that a general
definition that fits with bop guidelines
yes senator
so i'd like to ask you this first
i'm starting with a premise i want to
see if you agree with on based on a
lifetime of service and correctional
institutions
and your current position
the department of justice
issued a report in 2016 that noted that
the use of restricted housing quote can
cause serious long has long lasting harm
and should be quote used only as
necessary and never as a default
situation
do you
accept or disagree with that conclusion
yes senator it's a it's it's a bit more
uh difficult because as you said i spent
29 years in the system
it's our jail within the jail
i'm not
we've always looked for alternatives and
other ways to do it it should be a last
resort but there are people who under
circumstances because of behavior or
violence things like that there's going
to be a need for it but we can we can do
better and we've done that in the bureau
prisons we found alternative ways we
certainly try to do more out of cell
programming
for the reasons you stated but let me
give you a quick example of the irony
here
much of the scrutiny we received during
coved was how we were isolating inmates
the word in and of itself isolation it
requires us to place someone in a cell
by themselves for medical reasons
so there there's a simple irony that
we're being scrutinized for restrictive
housing yet you want us to medically
isolate somebody and then we have to
balance that so there is a difference we
have found alternatives in fact your
facility in thompson is serving that
purpose
they're called half of that mission as
you're well aware senator is a special
management unit the other half of that
i'm proud to say is a reintegration
housing unit there are 700 inmates on
that side in a reintegration housing
unit that would otherwise be in special
housing based on their
issues
whether it's management or protective
custody so we utilize that facility half
of that mission is to prevent and keep
people as much as possible out of
restrictive housing so we're
continuously looking at this our numbers
have gone down they were well over 10
000 as you well aware i know this is a
an issue that's been
close to you and you monitor
pre-pandemic we were already dropping
them down in my prior position as
assistant director i was supporting
director hawk sawyer's uh
uh vision to lower those numbers and
that's how we came up with the
restrictive or the reintegration housing
unit so we are looking at ways to lower
that number and alternatives but it is
something serious and we get inmates out
of their cell as much as possible and we
certainly have procedures to check on
them routinely and provide them the same
services
let me add for the record
so my position is clear
that i visited a maximum security
prison in
state prison
in illinois and went into an area where
there was virtual
solitary confinement
they were
just a few exceptions
and i
ida i spoke to the inmates and i'll
never forget one who looked to me like a
mild-mannered college professor
and i said to him what are you here for
he says originally or since i've been in
prison
and i says today he said well
he says i told him if they put someone
in the cell with me i'd kill him and i
did
he just said it that matter of fact and
i've since explored the case that's
exactly what happened there's no
doubt that that man should be in
solitary confinement until such time as
there is assurance he's not not a harm a
person that will harm another person
with him i understand that there are
people who fit into that category
but i'm trying to weigh
what the department of justice
said in 2016
with the cost of solitary confinement to
someone who is not in a desperate
situation like the one i described
now i hear you saying
when we have to deal with social
distancing i'm separating some people
for medical reasons it sounds like
you're saying and i don't want those
counted against me in terms of efforts
to reduce restricted housing is that a
fair summary of what you said yes
senator i just i i want to reiterate the
challenges that we undergo in our
environment you know certainly if we can
find alteriors alternative methods to
house somebody we're always going to do
that
having been a warden many years and
working through this they're always as
you describe they're always people who
are going to have to be there for
everyone's safety but most of those
folks
have committed some kind of misconduct
or something and we are finding
alternative methods to deal with that as
appropriate
and we do that when we can and we're
committed to doing that going forward
uh i want to thank you uh for being here
and um i'm sorry it took two years
we should be meeting on a more regular
basis the participation of the members
of the committee is an indication that
we all have an interest in what you're
doing it's very critically important to
the security of america
and to proving our humanity in the
process so i thank you for being here
today
i'm going to conclude the hearing by
saying first i have a number of
statements i want to include in the
record the testimony of the sentencing
project families against mandatory
minimums council prison locals justice
action network clara lebeau the
grandmother of andrea
hi bear
medical expert homer inventors doctor
homer ventures and a number of other
organizations without objection the
statements will be included the record
will close one week from today director
carvajal thanks for joining us today and
for your testimony a number of members
have asked for follow-up information i
trust you and your staff will comply i
look forward to working with attorney
general garland the justice department
and bureau of prisons and partners like
ranking member grassley to confront the
many challenges the bureau of prisons
faces and the meeting will stand
adjourned
thank you chairman
so
thank you sir
uh
tonight on q a a conversation with usa
today washington bureau front row seat
to democracy
president biden nominated eric lander to
be the next director of the white house
office of science and technology policy
during his confirmation hearing mr
lander addressed several lawmakers
concerns regarding allegations of sexism
and two meetings with convicted sex
offender and financier jeffrey epstein
this is just under two hours
good morning and welcome today the
senate committee on commerce science and
transportation will consider the
nomination of dr eric lander to be the
director of the office of science
and technology policy dr lander i
welcome you and your family and it's
good to see you again
the position that i that you have been
nominated for
is charged with advising the president
on a broad range of scientific and
technological policies to address
national problems
for the first time in our country's
history president biden has elevated
this position to a cabinet-level post
underscoring its significant
significance and administration's
commitment to follow the science
you are an accomplished geneticist
molecular biologist and mathematicians
all subjects i got a c minus in
who has spirited
who has spearheaded scientific efforts
to increase our understanding of the
human genome
you have answered the call to public
service previously serving as co-chair
of president obama's council of advisors
on science and technology
our nation is facing a critical moment
one with incredible challenges but also
with infinite possibilities we are
simultaneously facing a global pandemic
and experiencing the daily effects of a
changing climate
and yet we are on the cusp of
discoveries that could help us meet
these challenges and so many others
facing our nation today and science has
never been more important
although science is often considered the
great equalizer the truth is that gender
and minority representation in science
technology engineering and math or the
stem fields is anything but equal
while the united states is a leader in
scientific and technological innovation
we have fallen short of consistently
recruiting retaining and promoting women
and diverse individuals in the stem
fields
my home state of illinois is proud to
host two thriving national labs fermilab
and argonne national laboratory
these crown jewels of scientific
innovation would not be possible without
the contributions of women and diverse
scientists and engineers
to continue serving as a leader in
scientific research the united states
must tap as wide a talent pool as
possible
after all more women in science
greater diversity in science ultimately
leads to better science and greater
breakthrough that benefit us all
one need looked no further than the
recipients of the nobel prize in
chemistry last year from their for their
groundbreaking work on crispr dr
jennifer doudna and dr emmanuel
charpante to see why female
representation is so important in the
stem fields
addressing gender racial and ethnic
disparities in stem is a national
priority as a nation and as leaders in
our government we need to do more to
ensure that gender equality exists and
the diverse candidates have meaningful
representation across scientific and
engineering fields
increasing the number of women and
diverse individuals in science requires
intentional recruitment and promotion
however that alone will not be enough we
also need inspiration
that means recognizing the
accomplishments and successes of women
and minorities in science technology
engineering and math
we need to inspire the next generation
of great minds to encourage scientific
study in all children and to provide all
children with the opportunity to succeed
on this note dr lander i must admit that
i'm troubled by issues that have been
raised surrounding your nomination
you have been criticized for downplaying
the contributions of the female nobel
laureates i just mentioned for toasting
a well-known racist misogynistic
anti-semite and for attending lunch
meetings with the late disgrace jeffrey
epstein
you have provided responses to this
committee to these allegations and i
plan to ask you about them today
the bottom line is that if if confirmed
you will have the authority to promote
the representation of women and
minorities in stem fields so i strongly
encourage you to use this hearing as an
opportunity to explain how you've
learned from your past mistakes
nobody enjoys reflecting on previous
errors that may be embarrassing shameful
or worst of all may have harmed
individuals or a profession that you
love
but ultimately
our most productive growth as a leader
occasionally stems from honest
reflection and following through on
difficult lessons learned i hope to
learn today how your successes and
failures have made you a better leader a
better scientist and prepared you to
direct our nation's scientific policy in
an inclusive manner that empowers women
and minorities i now recognize my good
friend from mississippi ranking member
wicker to give his opening remarks thank
you very much senator duckworth this is
an important hearing on the nomination
of dr eric lander to be director of the
office of science and technology
policy i commend senator cantwell for
allowing the committee the necessary
time to prepare and give a full and
thorough review of dr lander's record
and qualifications there's no doubt he
has led a long and notable career as a
bright and dedicated research scientist
however as senator duckworth has said
our extensive evaluation of dr lander's
record has brought to light a number of
concerns that deserve further
examination by this committee as senator
dutworth further said i hope his
testimony today will provide clarity on
these topics the director of ostp has
been a critically important position
since it was first created a person
occupying this role directly advises the
president on the scientific engineering
and technological aspects of a wide
range of federal government activity in
addition it falls to the director of the
ostp to
coordinate science and technology policy
across all federal agencies notably
under the industries of the future act
which i had the opportunity to author
and see enacted last congress the
director of the ostp is required to
submit a report
on the federal government research and
development investments infrastructure
and workforce development
the report must include a plan to
advance u.s leadership in industries of
the future such as artificial
intelligence and quantum science as well
as a blueprint for boosting annual
spending in this area to 10 billion
dollars by 2025. implementing this new
law is one of the many
responsibilities of the director of ostp
this position has been made all the more
significant by the president's decision
to elevate it to the cabinet level
hence the need for comprehensive review
by this committee i want to thank dr
lander
for his commitment to public service and
for appearing before us today
i want to welcome
our two colleagues from the commonwealth
of massachusetts and i expect this
hearing will be informative and useful
to the committee thank you madam chair
thank you i recognize senator warren
thank you chair duckwork and
ranking member wicker i have the
privilege of introducing dr eric lander
who has been nominated to serve as the
director of the president's office of
science and technology now eric has an
impressive record as a scientist and
leader he received a degree in
mathematics from princeton and a phd
from oxford where he was a rhodes
scholar he received a macarthur genius
award in 1987
and was soon tapped to lead the human
genome project in 2001 he and his team
published the first draft of the human
genome in 2003 eric co-founded the broad
institute where he has served as the
president and founding director
in addition he is a professor at mit
and as you noted chair duckworth uh for
eight years during the obama
administration eric also served as the
external co-chair of the president's
council of advisors on science and
technology now i have known eric for a
decade we've had many conversations
about a range of topics from hearing
aids to cancer vaccines
one recurring topic is women in science
eric recognizes that the scientific
community is strongest when it is
diverse and inclusive
eric doesn't just mouth the words under
eric's leadership the broad has
prioritized efforts to support and
advance the careers of women scientists
and scientists of color let me give you
a specific example on this
eric is a scientist to his bones and he
believes in data so to assess and
improve diversity and inclusion at the
broad eric set in motion a study to
collect data about the institute the
results showed that in a field where
women are underrepresented the broad is
modeling a better path
currently women make up the majority of
the institute's overall employees the
majority of the scientific teams and the
majority of the senior leadership team
in order to recognize his support for
women in science in 2020 eric's former
mentees and trainees
raised an endowment to create an award
to honor his mentorship of early career
women scientists
eric's support for women's careers has
been recognized in the world outside the
broad as well
this september for the fourth year in a
row
working mother magazine named the broad
is one of the hundred best companies in
america for progressive programs related
to advancing women mentoring flexibility
child care and parental leave
eric's commitment was on full display
during this past year the pandemic's
impact on working mothers has been
devastating cutting into the career
advancement of many women and forcing
many more to leave the workforce
altogether
eric was not a passive observer instead
eric led the broad in setting up its own
child care center and to ensure the
safety of the children and reassure the
parents the broad conducted on-site
coveted 19 testing every few days
thanks to eric's work women scientists
at the broad did not have to take a step
back during the pandemic
under eric's leadership the broad has
also operated a flagship diversity and
inclusion program for college students
nearly all of the program's graduates
have enrolled in graduate or medical
programs some have even won prestigious
awards including three rhodes scholars
the broad has also launched or
collaborated on major research projects
on racial health disparities including
serving as the largest
genome sequencing laboratory for the
nih's all of us research program and one
final note
the broad is internationally famous for
its cutting edge work on genomics
during the coronavirus pandemic eric led
the broad to take on a very different
role
the broad ramped up and ran coveted
tests night and day
building from scratch a covered testing
lab that grew into the largest
non-commercial lab in america described
as quote the centerpiece of new
england's testing infrastructure and
quote
a vision of just how much better our
national pandemic response might have
been
as the need grew the broad took on more
and more work running literally
millions of tests for cities and towns
k-12 schools and over a hundred colleges
and universities in seven states now
there's much more that i could say about
eric i know i'm out of time here but i
want to end with one last bit of
information for those of you who don't
already know him
eric is fun
he is a passionate scientist whose
enthusiasm for learning is infectious he
listens he puts people and ideas
together and best of all he makes things
happen
i know that under eric's leadership the
office of science and technology will
push forward cutting edge policies that
benefit everyone and reinvigorate our
country's role as a scientific leader so
welcome eric and congratulations on your
nomination
thank you senator markey uh
thank you um senator duckworth senator
wicker thank you for uh hosting of us
today and uh and i'm pleased
along with senator warren
to be here to introduce dr eric lander
as the nominee to be the director
of the white house office of science and
technology policy
and i want to extend a warm welcome
to uh eric's family to laurie his wife
laurie who was here today
uh and his children jessica and daniel
and david and
i can tell you they are a team it's a
very special family that the landers
have uh created and i just uh i'm so
proud of all of you and glad to be with
you here today
um senator warren
is
right um dr lander is a visionary
scientist and thinker
and he's going to serve with distinction
as director of the office of science and
technology policy
i often say that massachusetts is not
only the bay state it's the brain state
and dr lander represents the kind of new
american pioneer
one committed to exploring horizons
defined not by the boundaries of land
and shore
but of genes and genius
a pioneer who doesn't see limits in
biology but the expanse of possibility
he exemplifies what it means to
represent a place where scientific
progress is a part of our dna
dr lander started his career as a
mathematician
he has taught economics and has been one
of the world's foremost biomedical
scientists for years
when i was a young boy who refused to do
his homework my mother would threaten
that she would donate my brain to
harvard as a completely unused human
organ
somehow
somehow my mother anticipated dr lander
and his work on the human genome project
that explains so much about you senator
i i
mothers know you best uh but and thank
god there's a dr lander that can help
mothers uh and uh and so i'm so um
i'm so
proud
that my mother can see me here today
introducing dr lander because i know
that she would think that somehow or
other i had defied all expectations that
she had for me as a child and dr
lander's work
on the human genome project and founding
of the broad institute at mit and
harvard which reflects his deep
understanding of how science and policy
can inform one another
at the broad institute he pursued
collaborative science bringing together
biologists clinicians chemists engineers
and computational scientists the
transformative model for scientific
research that the broad institute
represents is a new way to take on the
challenges that we face today bringing
scientific discoveries and advances
forward more quickly than ever before
his contribution to science has also
demonstrated how impactful research can
be the human genome project was a
13-year long project that involved
hundreds of scientists across the entire
world this project is an incredible
example of a publicly funded project
that keeps knowledge in the public
domain and a feat
that provided a model for the kind of
large-scale cooperative effort that the
world's biggest problems require
the human genome project has also had an
enormous economic impact with one
analysis from ten years ago estimating
that the three billion dollar project
has produced more than three hundred and
thirty thousand
jobs and nearly 800 billion dollars in
economic benefit and that was 10 years
ago
sequencing
nearly the entire human genome has
already led to countless advances a
trend that is certain to continue into
the future the project discovered genes
that are fundamental to thousands of
diseases including heart disease and
alzheimer's and cancer and paved the way
for novel treatments
last night we heard president biden
commit to curing alzheimer's disease a
disease that my mother died from
i know we will reach that goal and i
know dr lander will have played a part
next
in addition to his groundbreaking
research he has taught mit's
introductory biology course for more
than 25 years
and is one of mit's most beloved
teachers he has inspired students to
grapple with complex issues helping them
become informed and active members of
their communities
he has an ability to explain the science
of why
much better than senators can explain
the political science of why not
and that ability to teach and translate
is more important than ever before
i know dr lander has the skill to
rebuild the celebration of science that
is a hallmark of american excellence
when his country needed him during the
coronavirus pandemic he moved to build
from scratch
to operation the largest non-commercial
covet testing laboratory in the country
senator warren already spoke to that
incredible success
he has been a strong supporter of of
people of color
in science in improving racial equity in
science outcomes he has used science as
a tool for justice playing a key role in
the origins of the innocence project as
his commitment to justice in forensic
forensic science has spanned more than
three decades
the crisis we face today
of man and mind and the intersection of
those two forces are daunting we are
confronted by a surging china
in its race to dominate the scientific
and technological landscape but eric's
breath of knowledge unparalleled
experience and pioneering spirit make
him uniquely suitable to lead with dr
lander at the helm of the office of
science and technology policy all
americans will be his students
sharing his passion for science
discovery and achievement we thank you
dr lander for trading your microscope
for a microphone
and we appreciate your service for our
country
thank you
thank you senator mark dr lander
thank you thank you member
thank you senators warren and marky for
your very very kind introductions it is
a tremendous honor to come before this
committee as president biden's nominee
for the director of the office of
science and technology policy
america has led the world in science and
technology for 75 years that leadership
has had profound benefits for our health
our economy our national security
driving medical breakthroughs from
cancer to covid new industries with
millions of jobs from computers to
biotechnology
but today
america's future depends on science and
technology like never before
we have amazing opportunities ahead
but also unprecedented challenges
and the choices we make now
will determine our path
for generations to
come in a recent letter president biden
recognized we need to rethink our
strategy for the next 75 years he asked
ostp to take the lead because ostp is
the place where all of science and
technology comes together across
government industry academia medicine
and society
president biden posed big questions
what lessons can we learn in the
broadest way from this pandemic
how do we ensure america is the world
leader in the technologies of the future
especially in our competition with china
how can science drive market-driven
solutions for climate change
and very importantly how do we ensure
that the fruits of science and
technology
are shared across all america and all
americans
if confirmed i'd throw my full energies
into this let me explain why
i grew up as a kid in brooklyn new york
i was raised by my mom because my dad
suffered from a long illness and died
when i was 11 and in my neighborhood
there were no scientists
if new york city hadn't had a few public
stem high schools there's no way i'd
have ever become a scientist
i knew i was very lucky to have that
chance and i've never forgotten it
most people never get a chance the
opportunity is so unevenly distributed
across gender and race and geography
science has been unwelcoming to women
and people of color it's been
concentrated in a few regions of the
country and most americans lack access
to great stem schools and many even to
broadband
and lack of inclusion is not just deeply
unfair it's a risk to america's success
to lead the world we're going to need
everybody
if confirmed to osdp i will
as i have done in my career at the broad
make full inclusion and equitable
outcomes a high priority
including ensuring that ostp's staff
will look like america including by
identifying extraordinary women and
people of color as candidates in every
search
that pcas the advisory group will be the
most diverse in history that ostp's work
will be rooted in equity
and i'd work to put in place a plan to
increase the numbers of women and
underrepresented people in stem careers
by 50 percent
we can do that
i'm also excited to bring other
experiences and values
i've seen how science can be a force for
justice
as a young scientist in 1989 i testified
in one of the first criminal cases using
dna fingerprinting
for such consequential evidence the
quality was shoddy
and i said so
that position wasn't popular within
everyone but the case forced higher
standards for dna fingerprinting and it
led directly to the founding of the
innocence project which has used dna to
reveal that hundreds of innocent people
were behind bars
with black americans making up a
disproportionate share and having served
much longer sentences
a year later i got to be part of an
amazing collaboration the human genome
project
when we set out in 1990 mapping a
person's complete genetic code seemed
absurd it would have taken 200 years
but scientists rallied together and
drove innovation
we got it done in just 13 years
today it takes just hours
and it's unlocked secrets from cancer to
alzheimer's driving unimaginable
progress and we're going to need this
kind of collaboration to tackle much of
what's ahead
after the genome project
i worked with colleagues to found a new
kind of research community the broad
institute it's deeply collaborative it
lets scientists particularly young
scientists
dream big and take on challenges at
whatever scale is needed blending the
best of individual creativity and
large-scale platforms i'm particularly
proud it's one of the few such
institutions in which women comprise the
majority of the overall staff the
scientific staff and the senior
leadership team
there's a lot more to be done but we can
reimagine how we do science
finally
i've learned
that good science
requires a healthy dose of humility
scientists favorite ideas are often
wrong
mine included
we constantly need to be open to
different perspectives from scientists
non-scientists
policy makers
i know that this committee has led on so
many critical issues in science and
technology
your work has been so collaborative and
so bipartisan
if confirmed i promise to work closely
and open-mindedly with each of you
thank you for the invitation to come
before you and i look forward to your
questions
thank you dr lander um i will start with
the first round of questions
as a member of the senate i have a
strong commitment to ensuring that our
country is a leader in innovation and
technology
this simply cannot be done without women
and without diversity in our stem
workforce
dr lander you have been the leader of
the broad institute for 17 years and
just explained to this committee that
you have sought to support women in
science
however statistics compiled by the broad
institute suggest that it struggles to
ensure robust representation by women in
stem roles for example
at broad in 2018 women made up only
about 25 of employees in computational
science and software engineering roles
while this may track with national
figures maintaining the status quo is
not what we need to be competitive
we must do better
dr lander my question to you is this did
you do enough at the broad institute to
address gender gaps in stem roles and if
confirmed as director what concrete
steps will you take to rectify gender
and diversity gaps in the stem fields
well senator i really appreciate the
question because it's a topic i care
tremendously about when we did the
survey to look at representation across
the road we found that we had
equal representation in all areas other
than the computational field
and
as you note representation in the
computational fields is terrible with
regard to gender in tech it's 15
we were very concerned that the one area
in the broad where we were not at parity
was the computational field and that let
that led us to an instant institute wide
process involving our group women at
broad to look at ways to increase that
representation to go out to the the
conferences for women in computational
sciences and invite
more people to come and apply to go out
and and present at more of these
conferences and we've already made a
significant difference particularly
increasing women the more senior roles
in computational science um it isn't to
the 50 that it is across the whole rest
of the road but it is tracking up and
we're very committed to getting it up
there
if confirmed as director what concrete
steps will you take to rectify gender
and diversity gaps in the stem fields
for our nation well thank you for that
question because i am really excited
about that and and as i say i've worked
on it
the first thing i would do i have a lot
of ideas myself but the first thing
the place i know to start is to invite
to the table all the people who are most
effective and therefore
affected and therefore know the most
so if confirmed the first thing i would
do is ostp would convene the amazing
organizations that advocate for women
and people of color and stem fields to
gather the best ideas and recruit to
recruit support and retain women and and
underrepresented people i think ostp
also has this ability to
look at diversity across federal
agencies and look at what has worked
there and from all of this i think osdp
can develop best practices and work with
companies and institutions to adopt them
i bring my own ideas to it but i don't
want to privilege my ideas over others
but some of the things i think matter a
lot
ensuring mentorship and opportunities
early starting in middle school where we
lose
most girl many girls and people of color
i'm a huge supporter and fan of groups
like girls who code and resilient coders
i think
science is not about knowing the answer
in the back of the book science is about
asking questions that aren't in the book
at all
and experiences like this
well if a young person builds something
creates something invents something
discovers something they're hooked
that's what we've got to do and we've
got to do it early and often and
consistently we also have to lift up
role models lift them up high so that
people can see themselves as scientists
we have to work with academia and
industry
to address power dynamics in academic
labs and in corporate labs
and we have to commit
and get people to commit to diverse
slates in every search
then finally
like we tried to do at the broad we have
to set goals we have to measure and we
have to hold ourselves accountable and
when we fall short we have to shine a
spotlight on it
those are some of the things i would
offer of based on my experience but as i
say i would very much want to first
bring everyone to the table because
there are people who will know more and
there are people who are no different
we've got to start with that but if
confirmed this would be one of the first
things i would do in the role at ostp
thank you i now recognize ranking member
wicker for his question
thank you very much um and um
very fascinating testimony so far you
know uh
dr landro i wish i could spend my first
round
asking you to elaborate on the human
genome project and
prospects for alzheimer's and
also a few more examples of
why it's important for scientists to
have a dose of humility
i unfortunately i've got to ask
questions about some requests that we've
made and um and of course uh senator
dutworth
uh alluded to these also
we we've asked for 10 years of donors to
the broad institute
we don't have a complete list yet are
you going to be able to get those
tourists
senator i believe we sent you eight
years which is what was available i can
i can ask to see if they can go back two
more
okay i wish you would um
it's important to us that we we we asked
for 10 for a reason so uh so you're
going to try to do that
i will try to do that thank you thank
you very much and then um
and then senator duckworth mentioned uh
jeffrey
uh epstein um
we asked for information regarding the
second time
you met with him
in 2012 can you commit
to
fulfilling this outstanding request for
information uh
yes sir i i can
may i say something about
epstein certainly
jeffrey epstein was an abhorrent
individual
and my heart goes out to his victims
i chose to have no association
whatsoever
with him
we never requested funds we never
received funds we from him from his
foundation the sum total of my
interactions was that i met him briefly
at two events within the span of three
weeks
in the spring of 2012. okay well it's i
think it's important that you've been
given i will and i'm saying and i did
not know about his sordid history before
that point as soon as i learned about it
i had nothing to do with him thereafter
if you could simply answer answer
ourselves yes sir specific question it
would i think it would help your case
and i think uh people on both sides of
the diocese
would be willing absolutely
um and then uh with regard to um
your future plans with the broad
institute
uh those of us that are in public
service
uh have uh that have a date in which our
public service will end it's expected
that you would go back to the broad
institute and there are questions
that need to be answered about
whether you
are going to be able to
avoid prioritizing
your work
with the broad institute
that might favor people back
there at the institute at the expense of
others so i want to give you an
opportunity to address that concern
which undoubtedly
does not come as a surprise to you
senator
if confirmed
i will do that job
in a completely even-handed way
i i have said
i particularly care about the fact that
we concentrate far too much funding in a
few places in this country
one of my priorities is to make sure
that in fact we bring in all of america
into science and so i can assure you i
will not favor in any way institutions
i've been associated with and to the
contrary
really think it's important that we
broaden that scope
okay well do you
do you think you'll go back to the road
institute when you leave this position
i have said and i think i probably will
well just be aware that's a concern but
you did uh segway
to
a matter that that i'll ask you to drill
down on in the neck in the last 45
seconds that i have
how what steps can we take
to make sure the research isn't just
concentrated in
two
favored states that um
states like perhaps
illinois and mississippi
might be able to
contribute uh to this great quest we
have for knowledge
well senator i
as i say i care a lot about this and i
think creating programs that
support and expand the national labs
which are
distributed across the country creating
regional technology hubs
supporting focuses
of particular excellence in different
states
i i think there are a large number of
programs that can help
create critical masses that become
magnets we've seen it happen um with the
manufacturing institutes that were
created a pcast report when when i was
the co-chair of pcas called for these
manufacturing usa institutes and there
are these institutes in in a number of
states there's one in illinois for
example
um
but we we need to
we need to be
thinking about mechanisms to create
critical mass
all over the country because we can't
succeed without it so i of course i am
very sensitive to the fact that i come
from a state and a city
and institutions
that have received lots of funding that
can't be the way we we run funding in
the country is that the things are just
concentrated it will not succeed
thank you sir and thank you madam chair
thank you
uh remotely uh senator hickenlooper
great thank you very much madam chair um
and dr leonard thank you so much for
being willing to
to step into public service uh and
what a remarkable
career what a remarkable life you've had
let me ask my first question as a former
geologist i've seen firsthand how
intricate earth science can be
climate action
is and should remain a priority of this
administration one of
ostp's duties is to oversee the u.s
global change research program to try
and coalesce
uh climate research across all 13
federal agencies that are working on it
to produce the quadrennial the national
climate assessment
can you describe how ostp will preserve
scientific integrity when producing the
next national climate assessment
well
thank you senator um the the the
um
all of all of the work at ostp has to be
rooted in scientific integrity
um
with regard to to uh the the climate
assessment
the first thing is good process
it's
that that that
national climate assessment involves a
process that brings together
lots of voices
to wrestle in a structured way
so that lots of evidence is presented
and transparently and then the other
really fundamental part is to embrace
dissent and disagreements
i think science is strong because
science debates
because science
embraces dissent
and so
if at the end of a process we don't all
agree on the answers we have to
represent that range of dissent that is
what scientific integrity is about is to
speak the truth
and we have to keep that separate from
any external interference from any
direction that is not about the evidence
itself and if committed i will promise
to
support and enforce
that kind of integrity not just for the
national climate assessment but for
everything that ostp does
that's great i appreciate that uh second
question
kobe 19 the pandemic has highlighted so
many things including the importance of
science to provide solutions to these
modern problems and the u.s research
enterprises span numerous federal
agencies national labs as you've already
we've already been discussing
we also have to recognize the
contributions from many
of the leading universities and graduate
researchers including of course the
university of colorado and colorado
state university colorado school of
mines i have to list them
two things can you comment on how you
believe covent 19
the copen 19 pandemic
impacted federal researchers and how you
would lead ostp to reinvigorate
the research workforce and then you can
tag on to that and how do we
work to prevent future pandemics
well
what great questions thank you very much
senator uh the covet 19 pandemic has had
a devastating effect
in many parts you know in all parts of
the country it has certainly had a huge
impact in the research enterprise the
biggest impact has been on women
scientists
as the economy shut down the burdens of
child care fell disproportionately on
women scientists that it's part of an
overall pattern of more than two million
women leaving the workforce since the
pandemic
it it had impacts on labs whose funding
may have run out in the middle of this
period and won't have been able to reach
the goals they had promised to reach and
has impacts on graduate students and
post-docs who have a limited time and
they've lost critical time in their
projects
so it's going to require from the
federal government that we have a
flexibility with regard to supporting
the research enterprise through an
enormous disruption to support people
and laboratories
what we really have to do is make sure
we never have this again
there will always be emerging infectious
diseases
we have to be sure that they never turn
into pandemics like this
i think we have to set very bold goals
it was
great that we could produce a vaccine in
a year and then get it distributed
we have to do much better i think the
sort of goals we need and i think what's
possible with science today
is to say within 100 days
from the detection of a potential
pandemic
we should be able to have enough doses
of an approved vaccine clinically tested
for the whole country
within 100 days when you say something
like that you gulp
but then you take it apart and you say
yeah we can do those pieces it'll
require thinking differently about every
one of them
what interests me what excites me about
this potential role i've confirmed is to
try to help us come together and set
really bold goals and respond to them
because i've seen america do it again
and again and i think we can do it with
regard to pandemics this should be
the last time the last time that we have
a pandemic like this not the last time
we're going to need to respond but the
last time something devastates our
country and the whole world in this way
if we play
if we play our role we owe that to
future generations it is a generational
responsibility
i appreciate very much your willingness
to to take on those big challenges and
to
to make real bold commitments 100 days
that's
that's amazing if that can be done and i
believe that you could do it um anyway
i'll yield a matter of time i have many
more questions but i'll
yield my time back to the chair or my
lack of time back to the chair again dr
lander thank you so much for being
willing to do this i look forward to
working with you thank you
senator thune
thank you madam chair and thank you dr
lander for being here today the office
of science and technology policy always
plays a significant role in coordinating
federal r d
initiatives and the rise
in scientific prowess of china and other
nations has made that role only more
crucial today it's imperative that the
united states maintain its global
leadership in the development
commercialization and standardization of
innovative technologies
during my time as chairman of this
committee we successfully enacted the
american innovation competitiveness act
to better coordinate r d efforts at the
department of commerce and the nsf as
well as the national quantum initiative
act
initiative act to strengthen and unify
the focus of the federal government on
developing
quantum technologies both of these bills
are bipartisan and due broad support
from industry
and the scientific community the us
continues to lead the world in the
development and commercialization of
innovative technologies and we cannot
cede
that competitive advantage to china and
it is crucial that the u.s act boldly to
solidify american leadership
in science and in technology dr lander
at a hearing uh two weeks ago dr kelvin
drilgermeier made an insightful comment
on the need for private sector
to be involved in strategic decision
making when it comes to research
partnerships rather than simply being
brought in after the program has been
established
how do you believe the federal
government can better incorporate the
private sector as a partner in r d
initiatives well thank you senator
um
the biggest challenges facing the
country today
many of them involve these technologies
of the future
and i think
a gap has become apparent
between
what we can do amazingly well in
foundational research
and
what we can do amazingly well with
vibrant industry and there's a gap of
things that fall between where
government needs to work both with basic
research and with industry to help fill
that gap for things that aren't yet a
business plan but could launch a hundred
businesses or a thousand businesses so
i think partnerships in many of these
technologies quantum computing
artificial intelligence synthetic
biology different kinds of
telecommunications are going to be
really crucial we have to do this in an
american way we watch china doing this
in the way of a civil military fusion
and that's just not our way of doing it
but we need an american solution to it
that
brings together these great sectors we
have to fill that middle and sometimes
that's going to be creating the
infrastructure that many startup
businesses need but can't afford to
to produce themselves we see that with
manufacturing for example sometimes it's
going to be de-risking technologies
because no sensible investor would
invest in those technologies because of
the risk but as a country we can say
we're going to need this technology
let's de-risk it together
i i think that is perhaps the most
interesting question about our
scientific and the science and
technology strategy going forward is 75
years ago that really wasn't the case
today we face international competition
and we face big technologies that
require us to act together as a country
and yet still do it in a way that is
based on free enterprise so i have
confirmed i am very eager to help and to
work with you and your colleagues to
figure out how we do this best and i see
many ideas already being floated for
this
last year several federal agencies were
breached in a supply chain attack by
malicious hackers
an attack at this scale has an enormous
effect on our economy and national
security is confirmed how would
ostp respond to this economic espionage
and work with industry to combat
ongoing cyber attacks
well
senator
the the nature of cyber attacks that
steal intellectual property from the
united states for example are are very
concerning
um we have to approach these things in
multiple ways security
of course
and then also technology
sometimes we are patching holes in cyber
i think it's important to be able to
step back and ask how can we make
fundamental changes to the
integrity of our cyber defense
that would ensure fewer holes i think
there's a lot of active discussion right
now about ways to rethink aspects of our
cyber defense and have confirmed
ostp has important roles in this and i
would be a very active participant in
trying to see how we defend ourselves
technologically
and then of course we have to defend
ourselves with regard to research
security
so my time has expired madam chair thank
you thank you dr lander
thank you
senator blumenthal
thanks madam chair uh welcome to
committee
dr lander you have a extraordinary
and very impressive background in
both academia and elsewhere
and
i want to ask you at the outset
a question that will not determine my
vote on your nomination
uh since i am in the middle of reading
walter isaacson's book the code breakers
uh i'd like
your opinion of the book what you think
of it
and uh
um
i do have a reason for asking about it
though
okay um
i'm uh
senator it's an excellent question and
i'm gonna have to say i haven't read the
book yet
having
didn't that's fair enough yeah
let me uh just say one of the
there are a couple of themes of the book
uh
one is a recurrent theme in walter
isaacson's works
which is that
great inventions and innovation are the
result of cooperation and
collaboration among teams of
scientists and also
uh academia
private industry and government and i
think your
appointment would
further that kind of collaboration and
partnership but another
kind of subplot of the book since it's
about a woman scientist is that
women are sometimes discriminated
against or harassed
in the world of
science as they are in many other
professions as well i've introduced a
measure called combating sexual
harassment
in science act i've done it with
senator smith of minnesota it was
originally championed by
then senator
amla harris
i'd like your commitment to support at
least the goals of
the legislation to end harassment
and perhaps for the legislation itself
which i hope will be incorporated in
the endless frontier act
you you have my enthusiastic support and
commitment toward those goals they are
extremely important i think there are
many many approaches we have to take to
end that
i've also introduced a measure called
supporting early career researchers act
to give
americans stem
researchers
who are just beginning in their field
especially
women and traditionally underrepresented
minorities
more opportunities in the world of
science in particular
particularly important as you've noted
because of the impact of kovid
it would direct nsf to establish a new
post-doctoral fellowship
program to support the next generation
of
stem talent one of my colleagues senator
klobuchar as
been particularly instrumental in
joining this effort
i think we lose valuable talent
because of the
potential
obstacles
for end inequalities for certain
minorities
so again i would ask for your support as
director of ostp
for this kind of effort in particular
that legislation
senator you i commit to that
uh
i've i've been very interested uh i i'm
a former prosecutor i still think of
myself as a litigator uh particularly
interested in your work on forensic
science the innocent project do you
think that
the legal profession in our justice
system has made sufficient use
of science
in the kind of
forensic evidence that's admitted and
particularly in the more serious cases
that
are involved in the innocence project
senator the
science is is a force for truth for
getting the right answer
and our justice system needs that as a
foundation for anything else is to know
the right answers
i think we have not always availed
ourselves of the best science to get
those answers or
more troublingly not always done it in
the rigorous ways to be able to trust
those answers
that all of these scientific methods
when they come to court need empirical
evidence so this is an extremely
important topic to make sure that
science can be
a
really strong
supporter of the search for justice
it's mattered to me for 30 years and if
confirmed i will devote attention to
making sure we
fully realize the promise of this for
justice
thank you my time has expired but there
is a
wealth of
conversation that i'd like to have with
you and uh
i would hope that
we could spend some time talking about
that last topic as well as some of the
others
if confirmed i would love to do that
great thank you very much
very patient senator blunt uh thank you
chairman uh dr landers it's good to see
you here um
the um
president is seeking a lot of new
authorities for research entities in the
government from the national science
foundation to the department of energy
what
the one he mentioned last night was a
new concept
in health arpa
h talk about how that would be different
than what nih has been doing
and also
talk about
your view of whether the best place for
that is at the national institute of
health well
senator first let me say thank you to
you
for your tremendous and consistent
support of biomedical research
biomedical research is an extraordinary
gem of the united states and it is
because the congress has
uh supported it for so long and so
strongly so so thank you
um the idea of an arpa-h
is a risen again because of one of these
gaps that i was referring to before in
the discussion with senator thune
um
we have unbelievable foundational
research in this country that through
nih grants can discover all sorts of
things we have a vibrant biotech
industry that is able to take a business
plan and run with it
there are a lot of things that have big
gaps in between
they are
you might call them platforms i'll give
one example if i may
very often drugs have side effects
because they don't just act in the place
you want them to act but they act in
other places in the body
what if you could build a post office a
zip code that would deliver this drug to
the right cell type
well you could dramatically reduce many
side effects and probably be able to
increase the dose if you know it's going
to the right place
no
nih basic research grant could do such a
thing not your traditional r01s
and no sensible startup biotech would
take that on
these are the kinds of darpa-like
projects that
led to the internet and the gps and we
now see they could lead to things that
would launch a thousand opportunities
to me this idea of darpa within
biomedicine is is exactly that it's to
build those platforms
to be able to overcome market failures
to take on bold challenges and where
should it sit
my answer is within the nih
if you were to try to set up a separate
thing i think there would be duplication
and competition
let me see if i can get another question
in here please uh with what nih did
during the pandemic with
particularly the what we call the shark
tank on developing
uh tests and becoming a active partner
with 34 different businesses
would that make them more prepared to do
this than they would have been say two
years ago absolutely i think this pro
program the rad x program the rapid
acceleration of diagnostics initiative
is a perfect example that says nih can
pivot and take on
bold things like this that that lift up
as you said 34 or maybe many more such
opportunities there isn't a
natural way to do it it's it's been ad
hoc and it was amazing that it was spun
up so quickly as an ad hoc approach
imagine the possibility if we had a
structured way to be able to seize those
opportunities each year i think that's
that it very much supports the idea to
get in one more question this whole
what's happening in synthetic biology
and
agriculture and developing advanced
materials if you're confirmed what would
you do to ensure that the united states
continues to advance
our innovation and maintain a global
advantage in that
quickly growing area
well senator synthetic biology has
enormous potential to do things like
reprogram cells to fight cancer or
reprogram crops to be able to have
higher yield
and it requires a kind of tool kit the
same way in the early days of
semiconductors people had the bits and
pieces that they would assemble into
integrated circuits
biology is at that early stage where it
needs to build those tool kits and get
them in the hands of thousands of
innovators and i think that the federal
government has a really important role
in being able to support the creation
and dissemination and the sharing of
best practices better to use those
thank you thank you chairman
thank you senator markey
thank you madam chair um i would like to
follow up on
the direction that senator blunt was
going um
looking over at
nih and
looking at what the president said last
night about alzheimer's
diabetes cancer
and perhaps you know
to give you an opportunity to integrate
that what you've done in your career
thus far what your hopes would be
you know the promise for families
because research is medicines field of
dreams from which we harvest the
findings to give hope
that there will be a cure
so
can you speak a little bit about what
your goals would be
just take those three diseases and
you know and synchronize it perhaps with
what the biden administration's
dreams might be of the next four years
well
um
cancer diabetes alzheimer's
the problem in all three diseases had
been
we didn't know what was wrong under the
hood
we could give you an account of symptoms
but we couldn't give you an account of
what was actually wrong i think the
federal government's investments
starting with the human genome project
and many other investments are now
telling us how these diseases actually
work
which cells are going wrong
which ones to target
i think that has been a tremendous
success now the question is can we
target those cells alzheimer's used to
think it was the problem in a nerve
cells but it's actually some other kind
of cell entirely it's likely the place
to look
how do we manage to
now build the next generation of tools
to target things to the right places do
it safely
do clinical evaluations more quickly
than five or eight years for alzheimer's
so that we can test many ideas these are
the sort of things that only
federal research can support
and then unleash innovators
and
do you think
there's enough funding or are we going
to have to increase funding if we take
this new model for
of having adopter for healthcare
research focusing upon those three
diseases
will it require a reallocation of
funding or do you think
an increase in funding would be called
um well senator i think the
opportunities are so extraordinary
that
we are not fulfilling all the
opportunities in part for lack of
funding
i think
we also always have to be thinking about
using funding most wisely
but if you're if you're asking are there
remarkable opportunities ahead that we
are not seizing today the answer is yes
um
when uh
when you look at the
covent crisis where we are today
uh from your experience
of what
um what do you think is going to be
needed from an american perspective as
the leader
in helping the rest of the world deal
with that issue as well so that we
anticipate
perhaps a recurring
uh phenomenon in the years ahead what
what recommendation would you be giving
to our country
well
we never want to see something like this
happen again and so we have to take
apart all the pieces of it
and
we will need to have capacities in place
hot capacities that can be turned on a
dime because these things well we've
learned what it means to have an
exponential increase in something
those are capacities for diagnostics
the ability
in a week
to reprogram existing diagnostics being
used in public health to take on a new
pathogen
to do it so cheaply that we don't
agonize about how to pay for it
the ability to produce vaccines against
any of the classes of viruses that
infect humans
make five of them
the ability to make therapeutics
very rapidly we did not succeed in
making therapeutics new therapeutics in
this pandemic rapidly enough to respond
and yet there are approaches to do it i
think we need a top to bottom look at
the components the good news is
there are scientific approaches for all
of those things and we need to pull
together and we need to pull together
across agencies and we need to pull
together even across some countries i
think the united kingdom is an obvious
partner in something like this
because we all
have to prevent this from happening
again
thank you again thank you for your
service thank you
review of webex my good friend from
tennessee senator blackburn
uh thank you madam chairman and uh dr
lander i want to thank you for your
phone call and the time that we had
to visit i so enjoyed that i want to
join
ranking member
wicker
in his request that the broad institute
please
provide to us that tenure of donor
records
the um epstein connection is of
tremendous concern to us and we would
like to
to have that information
um a question that i have for you in
your opening statement
you had said uh you know the ostp's work
will be rooted in equity
tackling issues from stem inclusion to
algorithmic bias
you also state this administration
poses big questions like how can science
create market driven solutions for
climate change
so first question to you is i want you
to provide some clarification around
your utilization of algorithmic bias
and then secondly we'll talk about
market driven solutions
so thank you senator those are these are
really important questions and i'm very
glad to respond to them
when
when a computer scientist
uses the word algorithmic bias
they mean that an algorithm is not
producing the correct answer because of
typically the data that was used to
train it
not applying to the circumstance in
which it is being used
um there are many ways that that can
occur
but it means the results are not
reliable
they don't reflect whether the person
you're looking at really should get a
loan
what they reflect is
a data set that doesn't actually
describe
the person who's come before requesting
a loan for example
um i think it's it's a very important
question right now in artificial
intelligence how to be able to verify
that programs produce the correct result
in circumstances other than the ways in
which they were first constructed
i agree with you on the concern with
algorithmic bias i
think that your application to
artificial intelligence is so
appropriately placed it is of concern
when you look at building these
algorithms out if you are pointing one
direction that algorithm instead of
opening up
new potential options to you it narrows
those options that are presented to you
and i will look forward to continuing a
conversation about how we change that
and how we work with uh tech
big tech companies to change that it is
not helpful whether it is in research or
whether it is in public discourse um
i would love for you to
talk just a minute president biden has
been very aggressive in executive orders
and
i sometimes wonder
how this aligns with market-driven
solutions
and
when you talk about
climate when you talk about energy
because what he is putting forward in
executive orders does not seem to line
up with market-driven solutions you can
look at a variety
of different things and look at how the
chinese have so adversely impacted
the market when it comes to solar panels
or to polysilica
being made in the united states
so
and then you look at president biden's
executive orders and what he did around
the keystone pipeline which by the way
natural gas a good way to move oil and
gas
is through a pipeline and
i i look at some of these executive
orders and i wonder
what the
desired outcome is
because it does not seem to be a market
driven solution so i'd like for you to
bridge that gap
between what has been happening by
executive order when it comes to fuels
when it comes to energy
and what is um going to become
market-driven solutions that are
affordable for the vast majority of the
american people
well thank you senator i i think all of
us are very concerned about addressing
uh the issues around climate change
and technological innovation is a
critical part of that
that technological innovation
ultimately has to include innovations
that just make
clean
net zero carbon energy
cheaper than any alternative in the long
run that will lead to market-driven
solutions and i think science uniquely
can contribute in those ways
thank you so much thank you mr chairman
thank you senator lujan
remotely
thank you so much chair duckworth uh dr
lander new mexico is home to world-class
science and research facilities
including los alamos national lab sandia
national lab the air force research lab
spaceport america small businesses
universities and community colleges and
more
from the manhattan project to the human
genome project to the fuel that
propelled the mars 2020 perseverance
rover new mexican scientists are playing
a leading role in solving our toughest
problems
i'm excited that biden harris
administration has elevated your
position to the cabinet level this
demonstrates a strong commitment to
science and innovation
from climate to emerging health issues i
want to offer my support in making sure
that ostp has the resources and capacity
necessary to carry out its mission and
offer necessary scientific counsel to
the president my question if nominated
how do you plan to use your role to
ensure that science and research and
development are not just in the room but
are central to solving our most
challenging problems
scientific research
senator i
very much enjoyed our conversation
particularly about the national labs and
i
i have to say um
as i told you my first experience with
the national labs was in your home state
with with los alamos national laboratory
so i am
deeply excited about what
science can do to solve so many problems
and
seeing
so many different laboratories and
approaches to science flourishing right
now
and and so many new technologies and
opportunities gives me such hope if we
can draw people into it so i think
lifting up the possibilities i mean this
is a i grew up in the 1960s which i
thought then was a time of amazing
inspiration and
opportunity about what the world could
accomplish
i think this is a moment like that again
we see possibilities that
i think should lift the excitement of
any young person to say that being in
science will be
the most exciting thing that one can do
in the coming decades and we just have
to make sure everyone understands all
those opportunities and that there is a
place for everyone in those
opportunities
thank you dr lander
as you know congress is currently
considering proposals to strengthen
america's leadership in science and
technological innovation
as a nation we are not keeping pace with
other countries
increases in their r d spending we must
invest more in science including at the
department of energy nsf nist and nasa
the lab directors of the 17 department
of energy national labs recently wrote a
joint letter offering technical
assistance to the endless frontiers act
which proposes an expansion of the nsf
to address 10 technology focus areas
this letter recommends that congress
embrace a broad approach to our
technology leadership economic
competitiveness by strengthening the
entire u.s innovation ecosystem this
means increasing investments at nsf as
well as other agencies that play a key
role in important technology areas such
as the department of energy
yes or no do you believe that we have an
innovation ecosystem and that the
department of energy is a vital part of
it
uh senator the department of energy and
its amazing networks of laboratories is
a vital part of america's ecosystem of
innovation
do you believe that
do you believe that the department of
energy and nsf do complementary work
i do believe that they do complementary
work
do you agree with the lab directors that
we must make substantial investments
in and strengthen the entire u.s
innovation ecosystem including at the
department of energy
i i think if we are going to compete in
the years ahead we need to strengthen
all aspects of our innovation ecosystem
this is a very
consequential moment for the united
states
to make sure that that we have
strong innovation throughout the country
throughout the the government's support
for it throughout industry so it is
critical that we strengthen all of it
because it's the only way america will
remain the leader in science and
technology
chair duckworth this letter from our
nation's lab directors recommends that
congress embrace a broad approach to our
technology leadership and economic
competitiveness by strengthening the
entire u.s innovation ecosystem and i
ask unanimous consent to be entered into
the record
without objection
i want to thank dr lander for his time
today for my conversation with him and
with that uh chair duckworth
thank you and i recognize the senator
from minnesota senator bashar who will
take over as a chair
thank you very much madam chair and
thank you
dr lander for being here and
we talked on the phone
about some of your interests in
a science and technology and
i want to start with
really what i consider the biggest
scientific challenge in front of us
which is climate change and i know
you've been asked a few things about
this and the president certainly focused
on it last night in the state of the
union
as you know earlier he
this year
the president asked you how science and
technology can create solutions to
address climate change and soon after he
issued the executive order establishing
the national climate task force
can you speak to the importance of
interagency coordination in addressing
climate change and what steps you can
take to address the issue well thank you
thank you so much senator um
climate changes is
an incredibly important challenge for
for our time
and we have to move quickly on it
um
i'm impressed looking back the last
decade that we've seen real progress
that
green technologies
zero carbon technologies used to be
hugely more expensive than fossil fuel
technologies that gap's closing
we'll get market driven solutions when
the gap closes all the way
but the gap is no longer so huge
we see it with with solar we see it with
smart grids we see it with wind and i
think what we need to do now is focus
hard from the point of view of science
and technology on what we can do to
promote the innovation
to make each of these things
more and more efficient
so that
we reach a point where there's not
really a question
because
because it is just cheaper to do it that
way i think that's the ultimate goal for
science and technology and i think as an
amongst the agencies we have to be
coming together and looking on a
continuing basis
what
those differences and costs are and how
we can close them very good um the
um i know senator thune talked to you
about cyber security workforce something
that's a major priority and he and i
worked together on a public-private
exchange
do you believe we need to train our
cyber security workforce better to deal
with the hacks and what we've seen out
there oh
the cyber security problem is a very
serious and very worrying problem for
the whole country
i i believe we do not have enough people
trained in it
to be able to both defend
and then think about how to construct
systems that are just less less hackable
so i think this is an area of tremendous
opportunity there are some manufacturing
institutes that are actually started
that focus on cyber security
manufacturing there are programs i know
of at annapolis but we really have to do
a tremendous amount because
the risk of cyber security threats is
just too big
um and along the lines of cyber there's
still issues of course with broadband
really come into
magnification during the pandemic
and we've got you know in my state about
16 percent of households even though our
state's above the national average that
don't have access
um send representative clyburn and i
lead the two major bills together the
same bill on broadband and of course the
president
um included
these provisions in his infrastructure
package in your testimony you highlight
the importance of access to broadband
can you talk about that in terms of i
know you do such high level science but
if you're going to get stuff out to
people so they can actually use it
you don't want a whole bunch of people
like 20 of the population not having
access
well senator this is such an important
issue i mean it
how can you be a part of 21st century
american economy education work
healthcare commerce without access to
broadband and yet
tens of millions of americans lack
access to broadband and it's
disproportionately rural americans and
people on tribal reservations and people
of color and older and lower income
americans and americans with
disabilities
and for me it's actually a personal
issue because my daughter teaches high
school in lowell massachusetts
and
three quarters of her kids
are on free or reduced lunch
and during this pandemic when she has
been teaching online
we're acutely aware she is acutely aware
every day of how hard it is for many of
her students to be able to even
participate in class
we have to solve this um yeah very good
and i think it's just important to put
the connection with the high level
science and
um my daughter's class matters even more
than the high level science for this
my last uh question is uh you and i
talked about minnesota and we're really
proud of the work that
we've done in research in our state of
places from the university of minnesota
to mayo clinic and mayo clinic i visited
their personal
medicine area
where they have personalized medicine
using the science we have now to help
people
and could you talk a little bit about
that the work of course that francis
collins has done and where you see the
future headed because i is one of the
co-chairs of the rare disease caucus
along with center with senator hatch and
now senator wicker you know we've done a
lot of work in that area and um there's
still so many things that we need to
know to give people the best treatment
where do you see this going well
the the amazing progress in being able
to find the genes that underlie diseases
is is not just giving us diagnostics
it's now pointing to therapeutics so
more and more rare genetic diseases that
we never imagined would be treatable
now through different kinds of gene
therapies we're seeing can be treatable
and it's just amazing the hardest
problem may be just delivering the
therapy to the right cells but the idea
that this is becoming
i've gone from an utter mystery to a
problem of careful engineering and that
we can provide
in some cases real therapies and cures
and in many other cases you can at least
see paths to them
to me it's it's it's just a mind-blowing
thing over the past 10 or 20 years
and if you try to project forward 10 or
20 years you just think wow what's going
to happen exactly all right well we hope
in your new job you'll visit
mayo if you are confirmed and i'll come
to our state so uh with that i i can
only share this for a short period of
time i just happened to i was at another
hearing on patents uh in judiciary but i
will toss it over to
senator rosen and then maybe be able to
come back in to call on center sullivan
i have a number of calls i didn't know i
was going to share it so but don't worry
i guess you won't be abandoned mr dr dr
lander
with that i will turn it over to senator
rosen who is with us
remotely thank you senator klobuchar and
thank you dr lander for your uh research
your service and your willingness to
serve in the future you know so many of
my colleagues i've been listening have
asked great questions we were able to
have a great conversation so i want to
build a little bit on my colleagues
questions
talk about stem education because it's
really important that's one of my top
priorities in congress is a stem
education and really building our stem
workforce you know my building blocks of
stem act with the senator capital was
signed into law last year and expanded
nationals uh
the national science foundation programs
to help increase participation for girls
in computer science i'm glad it was
really funded in the last omnibus but
there's just so much more work that we
have to do particularly in breaking down
barriers that stand in the way of
students of all ages of all genders from
all backgrounds whether they're urban or
rural uh just across the board and so um
what what role do you really see that
you have in helping to promote stem
education workforce training and really
what i want to ask you is that how can
you partner with all of us 21st century
economy
needs a 21st century workforce to find
these wonderful breakthroughs like like
we have been doing and how can you use
your platform to help us promote these
kinds of exciting
things and the work that you can do when
you pursue
any career in the stem field
well senator rosen
thank you and it was it was really great
to talk to you the other day
i am as as was mentioned in veteran
teacher for
25 years i've taught the introductory
biology course at mit
and i've seen what happens when you can
light the fire of imagination
in someone's eyes
i think we need
to to lift up the possibilities and
invite people in
to stem in a way that we have not done
before we need to create curricula that
work for teachers in many different
settings
so that
everyone wherever they are
can get as excited about these
possibilities
there are many different approaches i
don't think there is any single answer
to stem but i do think
that one thing again and again that
works
is not book learning but learning
directly by doing this kind of active
learning
um
discovering something yourself building
something yourself inventing something
yourself
is
people get hooked on it
and they don't even know that that
they're doing stem
what they're doing is we're tapping into
the natural creativity
and i'm very excited if confirmed to
work to help
pull together and convene to create more
of the resources that will let teachers
around the country be able to do this
in ways that suit their individual
states and their cities and their
classes and the diversity of americans
because there are many ways in but we
have to make sure all of those paths in
are smoothed paths
no i couldn't agree more we have so many
robotics programs i've been to third
grade classrooms where they showed me
how they built robots and they created
websites we've seen cooking classes
where they tell the kids this is
chemistry and i see especially in
elementary school that spark of
imagination if we can just do that i
think you're exactly right and so that
leads me to my next question because we
know that there were concerns about the
issues of
politics
influencing science and so
we want to be sure that that the new
administration that we let data and
evidence uh
direct our policy in areas of science
especially now we have the pandemic and
so many other things rare diseases
cancer all of the things we talk about
so if confirmed kind of building on this
how how can you help restore that trust
and
scientific integrity with the public
i think senator
restoring that trust is one of the most
important things
that we all have to do and i i think
most important thing is to listen
i think sometimes scientists talk first
i think you need to listen
people have valid concerns and
i think listening to people about their
concerns um
letting them express them inviting them
in
is so important to rebuilding trust i
don't think it's a question of just
quote educating people i think it's
sometimes about educating scientists
about what concerns people
so trust building requires
listening and listening very deeply and
if confirmed i would want to make sure
that osdp took that approach and and
tried to promulgate that approach
throughout federal science programs
thank you i appreciate your time and i
yield back
thank you very much senator rosen next
up senator sullivan
thank you madam chair
and um dr lander
good to see you i really enjoyed our
zoom meeting you know
i take the advice and consent role here
in the senate really importantly i try
to meet with everybody assistant
secretaries under secretaries deputy
secretaries
you name it and uh some of these are
very informative some aren't but i i
really enjoyed our discussion i learned
a lot
so i i thank you for your time i'm going
to be a strong supporter of yours in the
confirmation process
let me um
let me uh
kind of touch on a topic that you and i
talked about you know we're getting
through this pandemic
you know there's been a lot of finger
pointing and blame
and everything like that um
and uh but there's some silver linings
as we talked about
and
you know you never want to
highlight the misery of what's going on
in other places but it looks like right
now if you look at overall
of course we've had way too many deaths
which is horrible
but with regard to the vaccine and the
ability for american states to get it
out my state has been leading the charge
remarkably vaccination rates
in alaska for the whole country
but how quickly were able to do that the
vaccine knock on wood and we hope this
stays the case appears to be working
relative to like the chinese vaccine
that doesn't seem to be working that
well and other countries are having a
real hard time and now we're
we're kind of leading the world i would
say
and
i think there's so much to learn in a
positive way
from operation warp speed and how that
came together for
so i'm going to be working on
legislation and i know you and i talked
about it i would say you know i wish
president biden would be a little more
magnanimous
you know his uh
his discussion vaccines always seem to
seem to start with his inauguration
of course that wasn't the case he kind
of did it again last night he never
recognizes the trump administration's
work i think we need to come together
and recognize that but could you just
tell me quickly because i had a couple
other questions
what are some of the lessons that we
learned i mean it's been a year really
since the pandemic hit us hard and we
already have a vaccine that is getting
to most of the country and most
scientists
would not have agreed
that that could happen at all and yet we
did it american ingenuity we did it it's
a great lesson
that we should all try to be celebrating
and learning from
well
senator first um
let me say i also tremendously enjoyed
our our conversation and i i will say
through the record i did commit to you
to come to the great state of alaska
yeah so i was going to get to that
you're oh okay well you'd come in the
winter which a lot of nominees don't
so
we're going to get you up there at least
i i'm i'm proactively i'm going to take
fairbanks where it's 40 below zero and
you're going to see well you got that
great research center up here we talked
about my next question oh i'm sorry i'm
just you know i'll stick to the question
in front of us here um with regard to
vaccines
it's amazing how fast it worked
and it's also amazing that
it was 10 years in the making it was
investments by
this american government in things like
mrna vaccines understanding
coronaviruses
and so as we look going forward i think
we have to look that we've made
investments over a long period of time
and then
when it came time we had things on the
shelf we had to bring down we got to
keep doing well look i want to i'm i'm
going to be proposing legislation i
think it will be very bipartisan it will
be not it will be non-finger-pointing
right it's going to be hey
we pulled this off democrats republicans
trump administration by administration
what have we learned and how can we
apply that to other places yes
so i want to work with you on that
legislation you and i had a good chat
about that let's let's talk to let's
talk about alaska here real quick
here's my big issue
we're a great state everybody loves
their own state i think my state's the
most unique certainly and you'll see it
when you're up there but it whether it's
climate arctic oceans fisheries there's
so many huge scientific things
that we can learn from what's happening
alaska here's a bit of a frustration
federal agencies often want to study
these but they do it in places that
aren't in alaska
so i i need your commitment to come up
see the state but also help me get the
scientists who are studying these alaska
issues to actually be in alaska this has
been a problem i'll just give you one
example noah i love noah there was like
this giant migration
of scientists were studying alaska
issues who left alaska
you wouldn't have
scientists studying the grand canyon do
it from illinois right
so i'm just saying
we need to fix that
can you comment on that at all i mean
it's best to be a scientist studying
something in the place where it's taking
place right
senator i i
there are some things you can learn from
a distance and some things you could
learn from a computer simulation but you
can't learn about natural places without
being there and so i i think that's a
broad statement that i strongly support
we need people there to observe and be
part of
the the ecosystem and all of the
exciting opportunities and challenges
great let me and i and i know i'm a
little bit over my time and i know i
think senator loomis is up next but just
one final question i
i agree with what senator rosen just
said you got to take politics out of
science but this works kind of
always right now i would say there is a
definitive
um area where
energy
traditional energy oil and gas in
particular mining seems to be out of
favor right this current administration
is restricting the production of
american energy crazy in my view um
killing jobs for sure
and even during the obama administration
you had scientists come out and say the
national petroleum reserve of alaska
doesn't really have any oil in it that
was the scientist it was totally
political because they were wrong it's a
huge area some of the biggest finds
recently in the world have been in what
we call the npra
so that was politicized science to try
to get people not to explore for energy
in america based on faulty science fake
science in my view
so
can you just tell talk to me briefly
about making sure you stay keep it
straight down the middle a lot of focus
on climate change okay we need to focus
on that but also on energy
having
being the world's
natural gas
largest supplier has
benefited our country and the
environment and the reduction of
greenhouse gas emissions
enormously that's science
some people don't want to say that but
that's science can you just talk about
being even healed and keeping politics
on both sides out of
science senator
you say it well we have to be even
killed
politics does not have a place in
science when we have a problem we need
to look to all the solutions we might
have for that problem and if confirmed i
can commit that i will bring that
approach and i will encourage that
approach good i look forward to strongly
supporting your confirmation and i
believe um
i senator loomis i think is up next so i
think i'm the de facto chair right now
let me see if i can get it to uh
can you hear me yes we can hear you oh
thank you so much uh i appreciate it uh
mr chairman and i want to follow up on
one of the things that you were
addressing just now
and expand it to rare earth and critical
minerals you know our supply chain is
one of the most important to be secured
from chinese influence
and fortunately there are places in the
united states with large critical
mineral deposits my state is one of them
i suspect senator sullivan state is as
well
i believe the national science
foundation should be working with the
department of energy and other agencies
to advance mining research and the
development of related technology to
make sure the best use of american rare
earth resources
is occurring in his advance now so could
you talk about your perspective on this
how will you use your position at ostp
to make this a reality
well senator thank you um
the rare earth minerals is is
such an important issue because they're
used in so many critical technologies
today
from
lithium-ion batteries to semiconductors
and because they are
a real supply chain problem because in
many cases perhaps half of cases the
major supply is china and if we would
ever lose that supply
we would be in a bad way
so there is an
urgent question facing the united states
of how do we guarantee our supply chain
for
scores of rare earth minerals gallium a
hundred percent of the supply comes from
china and it's not that we don't have
supplies of some of these minerals here
it's that we don't have the mining and
and refining capacity for those
so i would like to see systematic plans
and if confirmed i would i would like to
push for systematic plans to make sure
that we know how to secure supply chains
in
ways that are economically robust and
safe for the environment and i think
american
manufacturers have been working out ways
to to do this with new kinds of mining
and new kinds of secondary extraction so
you you have my commitment senator that
this is a very important topic from the
point of view economy and national
security and i would be very glad to
work with you to make sure that we have
the supply chain we need for these rare
earth minerals
well thank you we'll push you to push
others to prepare those plans so
they're available to all of us and and
we can
um
have the things we need that critically
need
um in case china pulls the rug out from
under us which they could at any time
they chose to um i also have a question
about the disparity in nsf funding
allocations uh small universities are at
a disadvantage when competing for nsf
grants against major institutions like
yours
the proof is the fact that
just seven states received half of
the available nsf funding and the bottom
10 states shared just 3 percent this
continues to be an issue that
i've been following for decades
because i used to be involved in these
issues at my university of wyoming
so will you commit to using your
position as director of ostp to work
towards more equitable distribution of
nfs funding
well senator um
i strongly believe that this country
will only fulfill its potential
if we involve everyone and that that
means research going on vibrantly
in all the states of this country
and there are many ways to help promote
that
um and i am extremely interested in this
topic and i would
commit if confirmed to work closely with
you to make sure that we engage
your state and
many many other states who are not as as
heavily engaged in this as they need to
be and should be and must be so i will
indeed work with you on this topic
well thank you very much
now one one last comment um you and i
had a good discussion about some of the
controversies that were brought up
during your nomination earlier and when
we spoke and and i looked into the
allegations of sexism and um it isn't
clear to me what your motives were
but it is clear that you wanted to make
sure your labs got the patents and the
credit for crispr technology and that in
the process
you may have marginalized or trivialized
the contribution of two scientists whose
work was essential in making crispr
breakthrough possible so that does
remain a concern for me uh however i
appreciate your candor during our
conversations uh and uh thank you for
taking my questions today mr chairman i
yield back and
if i may respond because it's a very
important question senator important
question it's a very important question
so a very important value to me
throughout my whole career
has been championing scientists to make
sure they get credit for their work
so in 2016 i wrote a long review article
championing the work about a dozen
scientists
mostly unsung heroes who had contributed
to crispr over the course of 20 years
they included young scientists immigrant
scientists young asian american
scientists and two remarkable women
scientists
doctors doudna and charpentier
and i was excited to tell the whole
story especially because there's a long
history of people not receiving proper
recognition
and my goal was to show how all of these
contributions from 12 different people
built on each other and fit together
and i'm afraid that in writing it up i
understated the importance of those key
advances that you referred to by doctors
charpentienne doudna
that was not my intention
i felt terrible about it i made a
mistake
and when i make a mistake i own it and
try to do better
i should have written those paragraphs
differently to make my intention crystal
clear
i have enormous respect for doctors
doudna and charpentier and the important
work they've done throughout their
careers
and over my career i have tried to lift
up others again and again
and when i fail as i failed
i try to learn and do better and i
appreciate the question
and i take it extremely seriously
well thank you very much for responding
i i i appreciate your your candor now as
well i that that was very very helpful
mr chairman thank you i yield back
thank you senator loomis and i just want
to add to her um
her point about the smaller universities
uh that still have great scientists we
have that in
in alaska as well i i believe senator
lee
is on
yes i am all right thank you mr chairman
dr lander during our phone call a few
weeks ago we had a brief discussion as
you may recall about uh about your
stance on federal research relating to
ethics in certain scientific research
areas like
those involving the use of aborted fetal
tissue or embryonic stem cells
as i recall you indicated during our
conversation that as director of ostp
you would have little input in any of
these areas but
to be clear title 42 states that the
director of ostp is required to quote
develop
review revise and recommend criteria
for determining scientific and
technological activities warranting
federal support close quote
so
understanding this particular part of
the job description i i'd like to ask
you a series of uh of of questions and
i'd like you if possible to keep these
to a yes or no just given the limited
time frame that we have um a series of
yes or no questions regarding the ethics
of certain scientific research do you do
you support height amendment protections
um i
recognize the president's position and
support the president's
position on the hyde amendment
um so is that a no
sorry i
quite got which way yes and no when but
i i think my answer is i support the
president's position
understood do you support the use of
aborted fetal tissue for research
purposes
i think the role of ostp is to be able
to provide advice on what might be
learned
i defer to our elected officials to
determine how to balance the ethical
questions and the use of it and the
possible benefits that could emerge i
think science can provide to our elected
officials
the potential benefits and i very much
respect the importance of these ethical
issues and how much they matter to so
many people myself included and yourself
included and i respect these about the
use of embryos
what about the use of live embryos in
federally funded research you support
that
live embryos
yes
um
i i am not aware of
that
okay how about the creation of three
parent embryos
i i believe the creation of embryos for
the purpose of human research
is unethical we should never be creating
embryos for the purpose of human
research
okay so uh does that mean
uh do you support or oppose the the use
of germline genetic engineering to
create genetically modified embryos
um
i have i have been on record um
supporting a moratorium on the use of
germline genome editing to create
designer babies
uh i think there are deep
technical questions but deep ethical
questions of creating children with
genetic editing
do you support the creation of human
animal hybrid embryos
um
i have deep ethical concerns about
the creation of of such hybrids and
certainly
there are strong regulations already and
i think it's
very much worth looking closely at that
uh do you support uh allowing an embryo
to gestate in an artificial womb
environment for research purposes for
less than 14 days
um i think the 14 days are the are the
current federal guidelines and again i
defer to our elected officials and the
federal government's policies here but i
am very strong what about 100 14 days
sorry
how about longer than 14 days i i
believe that those lines are drawn for
very good reasons
okay
switching gears for a minute the
committee this committee is likely to
take up the endless frontiers act
sometime soon the commerce committee's
portion of that bill places a great deal
of responsibility on the ostp director
and the national science foundation for
implementation of a
100 billion dollar plus government r d
effort um intended to counter china's
expansion i'm concerned that this
conversation uh
were
is one in which we're only trying to
respond to the chinese communist party
with more government spending
should our biggest response to increase
china's investment in r d
be to just
spend more like china and will out
spending china through the federal
government
actually counter the ccp economically
senator we i
i think our competition with china is
incredibly important incredibly
important to the future of the country i
do not think we can respond by acting
like china we have to act like america
and so i think we have to have american
solutions to these problems
i i i'm glad to hear that we agree on
that and i've often wondered you know
how much how much money should the
federal government spend on research and
development in order to counteract that
that threat
the um endless frontiers act would
propose you know something over a
hundred billion dollars but if 100
billion why not 250 billion why not a
trillion
is there a point and can you help me
identify at what point
um federal government spending becomes
counterproductive
well i think senator that the importance
of making sure that we win in these
different technologies means that it is
appropriate to be
developing ways to move things from
fundamental research into industry by
filling gaps between those two taking on
those things that aren't yet a business
plan couldn't be something supported by
investors but are crucially needed by
the country
and i think there's finally are there
other other changes we could meet today
a minute over
thank you madam chair
thank you
i see no one is waiting in the webex so
before we close today's hearing dr
lander we have one more question for you
which we ask of all nominees
dr lander if confirmed will you pledge
to work collaboratively with this
committee
provide thorough and timely responses to
our request for information as we put
together and address important policy
issues and appear before the committee
when requested
if confirmed i will do all of those
things and i look forward to it
the hearing record will remain open for
two weeks until may 13 2021 any senators
that would like to submit questions for
the record for dr lander should do so by
may 13th
we ask that your responses be returned
to the committee as quickly as possible
and in no case later than two weeks
after the receipt thank you and that
concludes today's hearing
i just wanted to say
oh
[Music]
um
tab to find this and all previous
episodes
good afternoon and welcome everybody to
this afternoon's program at the
commonwealth club
my name is robert rosenthal and i'm a
board member and long time journalist
and i'm now a board member at the center
for investigative reporting
uh earlier in my career i did work in
philadelphia and we were not in the same
newspaper but we certainly just
reminisced about some places we loved in
philly
including cheesesteaks
without julie's
really heroic journalistic efforts at
the miami herald
we may never have known what we know
today about jeffrey epstein
and while of course much remains a
mystery about epstein
we know more about his victims and the
failure of the judicial system than we
ever did because of julie's reporting
based on a reporting
julie's new book was published this week
perversion of justice the jeffrey
epstein's story
and it's uh it reads uh i'm sorry to say
it's not fiction but it's true but it
reads like a novel and it's not only a
story
uh about what it really takes to be do
great investigative restor reporting
it's a story about passion taking risks
the challenges a single mom faced
doing this kind of work
it's a story about what's happened to
the newspaper industry in terms of its
downsizing
and really it's a story about the role
of the press and a democracy and when
people like julian and miami herald
did what they did it truly makes a
difference
so i'm honored to be here today with
julie and i really hardly recommend this
book for a mirrored
reasons
uh so before we jump in a quick note
about today's format i'm particularly
pleased that today represents one of the
commonwealth club's first hybrid virtual
programs since the club reopened earlier
this month
that means that we two things first we
have a live audience here in san
francisco hi everybody and viewers
around the country watching vi via
youtube
all of you no matter how you are
watching can submit questions to either
julie or me
if we are watching online please post
the questions in the chat format of
youtube or zoom
those will be brought to me throughout
the program for on-site questions we may
use one of the microphones
and we can go to the audience as well
cards will also be written and brought
up to me
so julie as before we start i just want
to frame what we're going to do today
and i know you've had a lot of
interviews so give you two minutes to
rest
but i wanted to read from the preface in
your book because it sort of frames what
we're going to be talking about today
and uh
i thought it would just
set up what we're doing and this is
julie wrote this in the preface
uh this was only written a few months
ago this book as i said came out this
week this is what julie wrote the
jeffrey epstein's story epitomizes our
nation's lopsided system of justice
and how victims of sexual assault
especially those who are young and poor
are discarded shamed and mistreated by
the very people who are supposed to
protect them
epstein got away with his crimes because
nearly every element of society allowed
him to get away with them
professional legal and moral ethics were
set aside for a broken system of values
that places corporate profits
personal wealth
political connections and celebrity
above some of the most sacred tenets of
our faiths our teachings in our
democracy
when i became a journalist i learned
that the most rewarding part of my work
was in writing injustices for those who
could not fight for themselves
few people seem to recognize that fc not
only beat the system but he was probably
still hunting terrorizing and abusing
young women and girls
i would face many obstacles on my path
to the truth
i would be attacked by the legal forces
who failed their solemos by the defense
attorneys who profited off of epstein's
crimes
by some of those within my own industry
who thought that what i was doing was
nothing more than a rehash of an old
story
so julie uh
you've been in this business a while and
like every great story it has a
beginning
can you take us to the point where you
first really got
hooked
into doing the story and also about some
of the events that already had
transpired that you may or may not have
been aware of
well in late 2016 we were um
i was in the middle of a
long-term investigation into florida
prisons
uh but it was winding down and i really
wanted to
to try to move on to something different
so i
you know i had done some work in the
women's prison and i knew that sex
trafficking was a real problem in
florida
so i started doing some research on sex
trafficking in florida and every time i
googled
those two subjects uh jeffrey epstein's
name popped up
i read a column by one of our former
columnist fred grimm
that really took the
criminal justice system and the
prosecutors in this case to task for how
they handled it
nothing that i read seemed to make sense
of it it just here was a man who was
accused of molesting countless girls and
uh you know he seemed to get away with a
slap on the risk
wrist so i
just started kind of picking away at it
and looking at it and as i was doing
that
um requesting some public records uh
donald trump nominated a man by the name
of alex acosta to be his labor labor
secretary
uh i was aware that a cop by that time i
was aware that acosta was the prosecutor
former miami prosecutor who had signed
off on this um
this
you know lenient plea deal for epstein
so i watched his confirmation hearings
thinking he was going to be grilled over
this deal and to my um surprise hardly
any of the senators really brought much
of it up and it was clear from the
little bit that they did question him
about it that they didn't understand
this scope or the breadth of this
horrible um
this horrible deal that acosta had
signed off on and just so frame it a
little bit because now you're talking
about a period that's uh eight years
after the deal is that right so that's
crap
this is
for eight years and then you start
poking at it again
yeah because it was one of those things
where i would read a story and i think
what how did this happen and none of the
stories that i read
answered how something like that could
happen
so i was curious about that fact
and then when this nomination happened i
thought
i wonder what the victims you know
this was a crime that happened 10 years
before this would mean that the victims
were now in their late twenties early
thirties
and uh you know the labor secretary uh
post was one with oversight of human
trafficking and child labor laws and i
thought
i wonder what epstein's victims think
about um this man who had allowed their
predators essentially almost off the
hook now taking over the reins of this
huge um department
so real the hook for you
was empathy and compassion and thinking
about these young women
and how they might be sitting there
thinking about what was going on
if they're aware of what acosta had done
in terms of cutting this plea deal with
and letting epstein basically almost
walk
right and then i also saw that epstein
you know even though his crime he had
already served the short jail sentence
that he had been given many many years
before having been released in 2009 he
went back to his jet setting life it was
almost i realized it was almost as if he
got to go back to his normal everyday
life
um making money and and hobnobbing with
all these important people
and in my mind i'm thinking i bet the
girls you know who suffered this aren't
living the same lives that they had led
and that
in my mind i'm thinking i you know i
felt
a gut instinct that they were still
probably suffering trauma from this
at this point from the from the court
filings and documents that you were
looking at because
had you begun actually
caught you know human sourcing yet or
you just were looking and reading what
you was on the record
i was just at that point just looking
and reading the documents because it was
a very old case and i was looking for a
hook quite frankly if i wanted to do it
you know you always have to
give your pitch it to your editor and
you have to have you know some kind of
reason for for looking into a case
that's that old and it was just
coincidental that akasa was nominated
right around the time i was poking at it
number one and
and that um
you know i i also saw that there was one
lawsuit a civil lawsuit that was still
lingering
uh
that it seemed like why
it i wondered why it was hanging on
after all these years and did you at
that point know the name of any of these
young women or they're all jane doe's in
the in the filings they were all jane
doe's so take us through
okay so you're you've got this your gut
your tingling there's something wrong
here you have a hook in that the u.s
attorney
who had basically let this guy off and
in the documents you were looking at i
believe there were dozens of young women
who had alleged
that they had been uh or that the
detectives had found were going to
testify that they had been sexually
abused by jeffrey epstein and when they
were minors is that right
that's correct so you had dozens of
cases it wasn't one or two or three or
four you you and
i believe the documents hinted that
there were many more
that's right it seemed um
there was
information in the fbi the little bit of
fbi information that we had was that
these the fbi agents who were
investigating it were interested in
traveling to new york and new mexico
which were two other places where
epstein owned homes and
while it didn't say
why it was clear to me that they were
probably trying to find out whether he
had been abusing girls in these other
places
so you have a situation where some of
the people in law law enforcement
probably you're wondering where they
coerced or went along with this and
probably others from your experience you
know might have been outraged
what steps then you do you then take to
begin
finding the human the sources who could
be who did you who did you then go look
for
well i reached out to first of all i one
of the other things i noticed about it
was that the
uh you know as a police rep most of my
career was meant uh spent being a police
reporter crime reporter so the first
thing i thought well the police you know
who handled who was the lead detective
10 years ago
who was the police chief and in doing my
research i learned that the lead
detective of the case joe ricari had
retired and so had the police chief mike
rider
and
yet they had never spoken publicly at
all about the case the only public
uh information we had were two
depositions that they had given
many many years earlier um i think in
like 2010
um so these were even dated uh
interviews and they were court
depositions which as you probably know
are pretty boring documents um and uh i
i set out really first to try to get
them to go on the record so this yeah
i hope this conversation isn't too
inside the newsroom because what i'm
really trying to draw out here is how
one reporter
one person who's got instincts and
passion and guts
uh
and a very strong will
can truly make a difference and it
applies to many things in life so you
have you then go you have a couple of
names they've never spoken on the record
outside whatever they did in a document
and
how do you go about finding them and
then convincing them based on probably
their own cynicism about no one's going
to do anything about this what's the
process and how long did that take
well that process took a lot longer than
i expected um
you know i think my editor was getting a
little antsy because it was taking so
long i was trying to explain look these
victims names aren't in any of the
documents
it's just going to be a a painstaking
process to go through all the documents
and basically what i did was started
reading everything and you know
uh
doing this as i said so many years it's
inevitable that they miss a name
you know or they have the first name and
not the last name or they have the
first name and then the date of birth so
it was this big puzzle and i did a
spreadsheet and i would put what
information i had on each victim you
know it would only be scraps of
information
and from those scraps of information um
i looked at some of the a lot of these
women had sued epstein in the years
since this happened um of course they
were all listed as jane does but i would
have to read each of those uh lawsuits
in order to get it i had a file for jane
doe juan jane doe two jane doe all the
way up to 120 something and uh
so i would just keep filling these files
and i use social media you know a lot of
these uh women for example if i found
one woman on facebook uh let's just say
she was um you know jan smith
i could look at her friends on facebook
and you know it's really kind of creepy
at times because epstein had a certain
kind of type he liked very um petite um
blonde hair blue eyed i mean they are
they looked very similar um so i would
just basically look at their friends who
all look you know that look like that
and slowly i began to piece together uh
i had a you know i just the list just by
now you know that in the initial go
round uh in 2005 six seven
when epstein was dealing with this and
basically got off very leniently
he brought in lawyers like kenneth starr
and alan dershowitz you knew you were
going up against
internship you know spaceship galactica
galactica right
did that i mean what did that mean
signal to you also
well it signaled to me that i better let
our executive editor know what i was
doing
uh
so i i
you know knocked on um
mindy's um mindy marquez uh
was our executive editor at the time
and um you know i said look uh do you
have a second i want to tell you what
i'm working on and
so we just talked about the case and i
told them this is this is gonna might be
a rough one because we're going up some
very powerful people and he has
uh illegal arsenal that
you know that potentially
would threaten to sue us
and but i told her the story and i told
her about the the women and he
ultimately said go for it and you would
and it so this is around what point 2017
yeah really
yeah and so you're you're basically
going through months and months of
reading documents trying to figure out
how to find these jane doe's getting
sources
mccarty ritter the the former law
enforcement the the chief and this is in
palm beach again
uh to try and speak to you
and that's months of work is that right
yeah
tracking down the women was the most
time consuming and trying to get them to
talk was the most time-consuming part of
it so let me let me ask you a question
because you know in the book you you
weave in
uh something that i found really
interesting and surprising
uh your own story
you know your family comes in you're a
single mom
your kids become almost
second you know characters
uh
and you also talk about your own
upbringing did did you
were you conscious of the fact that
there was something in there that
did you ever think i could have been one
of these girls
you know i didn't i wasn't conscious of
it when i started the project at all i
didn't become conscious of it until i
started interviewing women and
especially uh you know i interviewed a
couple of their moms and
the stories that their moms told me
reminded me yes of my own mother you
know in the struggle she had as a single
mom and
you know quite frankly i you know i had
a tough growing up and i had put it out
of my head it was sort of like a a
reckoning of my own
without me really planning on it that
way that i just started thinking about
wow i remember when my mom had to you
know work two jobs she was a waitress
part-time and she wasn't home a whole
lot and
you know we were left we were latchkey
kids you know and
you know
you know as i said it slowly dawned on
me that i had
a lot in common with these women but i
didn't do this story for that reason i
just
you know it was just it just kind of
happened that way
well you know some of the best
journalists you have tremendous
compassion and
and there are victims in any situation
you want to be able to tell their story
and hopefully make it relevant so other
people can understand what they went
through
and that really came through julie take
us through i mean the reporting here and
it's hard to explain i think to a
non-journalist audience that's you know
i don't know how many thousands of pages
or documents you read
trying to track people down
uh i know one of the heroines in the
story is the librarian
i think her name was uh yeah monica
yeah
yeah i i felt that i feel still feel
that librarians don't get a lot of
credit in our business
and they're very important um to what we
do
um the other real heroine also was my uh
partner emily michaud who was my
videographer and photographer who uh
worked on this project from with me from
the get-go and was a real uh important
uh you know it's important to un to hear
this story
uh we work we put together the
documentaries as well as to see the
story as much as it is to read the story
uh she made these women very um
three-dimensional and and very um you
know
no one could tell the story really
better than the women themselves and
these documentaries did that well and i
think i want to get to that sort of the
interview process but is was there a
point in this early reporting where you
suddenly felt outrage
but pretty much from the beginning you
know i i just couldn't
i was outraged from the very beginning i
just couldn't understand how someone
like that could have gotten away with
this
uh and that's what made me want to do it
because i to be honest with you i felt
like it was like an unsolved crime
that i had to solve and i thought i knew
a lot had been written about it but as i
said i don't think the answers were
really known so i set out to really
solve this mystery
and you knew i think that you had to get
as many of these young women now a
little older
on the record to tell their story
so can
could you can you take this
yeah can you can you take us through
how you found the first couple of women
and and what you know what and what you
had to do to get them their trust and i
think
again one of the most difficult things a
reporter a journalist has to do is uh
speak to people who've lost something
victims of something in this case uh
sexual abuse or rape is is really
difficult to win the trust and the
sensitivity you need to do that but you
just take it through through the process
and and that some of the first meetings
well i before i even met with them i
i
had it initially i knew that this was
going to be an issue where i was going
to be asking these women whom i had
never met before
about the worst
time of their life and i knew that some
of them had probably never told anybody
that this had happened they were very
young
and i was concerned that i was going to
perhaps re-traumatize them
so i you know i spoke with some people
who do these
kinds of interviews for a living
to get some insight into how to handle
it and one of the things that i
concluded was that i didn't need to
force them to talk about the abuse you
know the physical abuse that it was more
important that i
that i you know tell them look you don't
have to talk about this there's no
question that this happened you know
epstein never denied that he did any of
this that was the other thing he never
denied he did it he once compared
what he did to uh stealing a bagel you
know he just didn't think what he did
that he did anything wrong
so there was never a question that that
this had happened so i didn't need for
them to tell me about the rapes um i
just needed them to talk about what it
had done to them and how they
you know were treated by the criminal
justice system
take take us through the first interview
with with emily and what you know what
that was like and your own feelings
well first of all the one thing that i
did i i started thinking
this would be like any other story you
go knock on the door and um you tell the
person that you want to interview what
you want to talk to them about and then
i i it you know when i did that
one of the women's fathers answered the
tour and i thought oh my gosh this isn't
gonna work because i can't tell her
father why i'm there you know she might
not even know
so i i had i did another story before
that where i um wrote the victim of a
slain navy seal i wrote his father a
letter explaining what i wanted to do
and and it and the father did call me
and i got an exclusive interview with
them and uh
i so i wrote 60 letters you know to all
the women that at that time that i had
tracked down and um included what i
wanted to do i included a couple of
clips about how epstein um had already
tried to get his sex offender
registration lowered in new york so he's
trying to really
weasel you know uh out of any kind of um
restrictions that were placed on him
after he got out of jail so i i wrote
all these letters and i got one
woman
called me um michelle licotta who lived
outside of nashville
and she confessed to me that her lawyer
told her not to call me and her lawyer
told her not to talk to me
and
i just had a you know a talk with her on
the phone and i told her what i wanted
to do and
she said okay come and emily and i
didn't know when we set out for uh to
travel to tennessee whether she was
actually gonna go through with it
because we knew she had some misgivings
and um
we we sat there and we interviewed her
for oh gosh it had to be at least three
hours
uh
and it was just extremely emotional
um
you know
emily and i really i think didn't really
understand the depth
of the trauma that that she and and
other women had gone through she only
went to epstein one time by the way
and it just with that one time it it
really almost destroyed her life and to
hear her tell and that's one of the
powerful parts of the book i mean i
touched upon that and emily of course
did a brilliant job of it in the in the
documentary but you only get so many you
know minutes in a documentary and so
many inches in a story so in the book i
was able to really talk about that whole
interview
and
you know and with each of these women
their whole story because it's important
to understand that um yes these girls
took money but they were really um
misled
uh and they were really um
you know why don't you
go into the detail of what the method
was i mean i i don't want to assume
everybody understands what was happening
here how
how this his system basically worked and
how there was it wasn't just jeffrey
epstein there was a whole infrastructure
around him
and many many people were aware of what
were going on can you just just describe
that for us what was actually the
methodology
yeah
jeffrey epstein had a whole ecosystem
around him of people that helped him i
mean he was a guy that really didn't
even tie his own shoelaces he had
uh you know he had somebody to do
everything for him and so these people
uh that were part of his uh you know his
his his life
you know or this this system that he had
built uh were you know involved everyone
from the butler who answered the door
with where these girls were to a chef
who was in the kitchen who you know made
them snacks to the women of course uh he
had other young women who arranged his
schedule to the um
you know the
the housekeepers who cleaned up after
you know he did
these incidents and uh the pilots who
flew the jets you know where
he had two private planes uh the driver
he had a he had drivers you know that
they picked up the girls so it was a
whole ecosystem around him of people
that um that really aided
um and helped this
well also i think the book in the book
you really describe how in some cases
you the actual the first meeting where
somebody a young girl
she might be a runaway she might be in
distress she's somewhere she needs help
you had it was almost as if you had you
know
a wounded animal or you know i don't
mean that but just somebody and people
out looking
for
the girls who fit a physical description
that he he was sought after i mean they
were out hunting really that was by
design i mean he could have had the
most sophisticated expensive prostitutes
that his money could buy but that's not
what he wanted he wanted scared little
girls that was you know what he wanted
and he didn't even want them
um one one or two he wanted a revolving
door of them all the time you know that
was part of his sickness
and uh
so he like i said he he just had and
then you know the the
most insidious thing part of this of all
was when these girls of course became
like you know scared and they didn't
want to do it he said oh don't worry
about it you don't have to do it just
bring me your friends and i'll pay you
the same amount of money so he had the
girls that he victimized didn't want to
be victimized anymore but they needed
the money for whatever reason they they
were on the street or they were in a
foster home
um and
they just would bring go to parties and
bring their friends or bring not even
people that were their friends people
that they would meet acquaintances that
they met in the mall you know or
uh at the gym or wherever so
he had
you know he had a whole legion of of
recruiters
yeah and we're not even really getting
into
[Music]
the men the
in some cases the women who surrounded
him some of the most best-known people
politicians
businessmen
uh you know corporate leaders uh who
were part of this world in some way and
i guess that's still one of the on
unclear mysteries um
can you you know there's so much to go
to here uh
you know and i i want to sort of try and
keep it a little bit of chronology but
can you also you know one of the things
that also is quite revelatory in the
book
was your exploration of the two islands
in the virgin islands
can you talk about that and and sort of
what was going on there and how that was
part of this world of of jeffrey epstein
and his friends and what also his method
of
indebting himself to local officials and
government people either through
philanthropy or donations or building
something
uh this sort of almost 360 degree
system he created
right
well he couldn't have picked a better
place um
to
you know further his crimes than this
island that he bought off the coast of
saint thomas uh the only way you can get
to it is uh by helicopter or by boat
um
and
he
he
you know it's also a place where the
people on st thomas are pretty poor um
and
um the politicians um
you know
he ingratiated himself with it with the
government officials and the politicians
uh the wife of the then governor went to
work for epstein i think she worked for
him for like for many years like 10
years uh
so he and then he uh donated you know
tens of thousands maybe even um you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars to uh
build schools there uh you know donated
built you know the first
music school
uh soccer programs i mean you just name
it it was just anything that he could
throw his money at
so um inevitably you know uh these
people came to you know
know him as somebody as somewhat of a
benefactor and they you know turn their
eye you know turn their heads the other
way when he was bringing in all these
girls on his on his private plane he
would fly into the airport at st thomas
on his private plane
and then
go to a hangar you know an area that
wasn't real completely visible to
everyone
um
disembark with the girls and then they
would
usually hop on a helicopter that was
kept there and then they they would be
flown to the island and one of the
things you that you were i think still
looking for and maybe you're still
looking for are manifests
is that right who flew on these flights
and there's also who flew around and
you've been
unable to get a lot of those right in
other words who he was flying with
and homeland security is blocked at is
that still true
yeah because unfortunately when i
started doing this this was after my
series ran and i was trying to get
information on that and i first did the
public records request before epstein's
arrest i did get some of it uh but it
was heavily redacted and before i could
pressure and get anything more about it
he was arrested and then of course
uh then it was an open criminal
investigation and i wasn't going to get
anything
i'm told i need to just move my light a
little closer here it's getting dark
here in florida and and so let me just
move my light excuse me
this is better
okay how's that a little bit better
anyway
well you look good to me
i can see you
but so i mean so since the uh
is that because of his death though is
that stuff now sealed or can you can
anyone get at it
i don't want to open anything i don't
think they're going to give us anything
on that um
you know i cuz i i know he's he's gone
now but the case is still open and
theoretically i guess they're still
looking at other people besides even uh
maxwell who who is indicted and
connected with uh his his sex
trafficking operation
you know one of the things to switch
direction a little bit julie in the book
uh and i mentioned it earlier
what was your thinking as a
reporter i mean a lot of times
in traditional journalism you sort of
i'll call it behind the curtain you know
you don't get into your life your ups
and downs
the challenges of being a single mom was
was that a decision you wanted to make
was that your editor your book editor
can you get into because your children
as i said earlier
and there's some wonderful scenes there
as a parent you know uh
uh
why did you do that
well my editor um
i you know it was partially my editor
thought that this story
um and i i fought it actually i didn't
want to do that initially i said look
i'll do this i really don't
i don't want to be in the story you know
and
then as i was working on it i you know
this was around the time of you know
trump
um
and all the things that he was tweeting
out that weren't true and uh the
the journalists being painted is the
enemy of the people and
uh you know after this series ran i was
one of the biggest surprises to me was
how much
fan mail quite frankly that i got you
know journalists never get fan mail uh
but just a lot of um
you know thank you notes from people
saying you know finally this is what
journalism is and and this is why it's
important and it occurred to me that you
know journalists aren't always very good
at telling people what we do and how we
go about it we just do it and i do think
that at this time in history that it's
important that we explain to people what
we do because uh for you know because of
trump and because of all the things that
have happened i think uh a good deal of
america has become distrustful of
journalists
and so
i i thought maybe i should tell them
what i did so they understand this isn't
you know this isn't an effort
to um you know to cover anything up this
is an effort to find the truth and
that's i think what most journalists do
you know and and so i thought i'm going
to put a little bit of this in here
because
i just i think it's part it's important
for our country and especially given the
fact that newspapers you know small
newspapers all over this country are
disappearing you know and i don't think
the public realizes
how um devastating that is to our
democracy that we're losing small
newspapers all over the country
well i
hear here i agree uh
and your work certainly shows the
difference you can make
uh
the you know one of the and it's it's
really complicated to get into i mean
the perversion of justice you know
is i think a perfect title because once
you get into this and you see
all the things that happen and it's
probably pretty complicated to explain
it here in terms of the system
and the players you talk about and some
of the stuff you had access to and
explaining
decisions that were made to protect
jeffrey epstein and also
one of the things we haven't talked
about was the ferocity of his attorneys
going after the victims yeah and which
is
appalling when you read about it and i
don't can you talk a little bit about
that and that what that did to some of
these young women in addition to the
initial trauma
well just imagine you're 14 years old
and you did something horrible that you
are very ashamed of and the police find
out about it and they come and they
knock on your door and they you want to
talk to you and of course you got to
explain to your parents why the police
are talking to you and you have to
confess look i went to this guy's house
i i thought i was just giving him a
massage and here's what happened and
then when that after that happens the
next thing you know you have um you know
a man that you don't even know um just
either following you or or
knocking or coming into the little you
know bagel shop where you work and and
coming and your boss is standing there
and it's official looking man and he
said we need to talk to you and then it
turns out it's a private investigator
that's working for jeffrey epstein and
they want to sit down with you and then
they tell you look if you uh basically
they tell you if you work with us you'll
be fine and if you don't work with us
then uh you're not gonna be fine and
your family might not be fine
or or your father is followed and he
there's headlights in his rear view
mirror and he you know
they run him off the road i mean this
this was really happening with these
victims
and the fact that prosecutors knew that
it was happening and they didn't do
anything to stop it
is is just um
i don't even know what the words were
for it i was just so uh
shocked
have any of those people
you've been held to account i know
several lost their jobs after your
stories came out
but in the afternoon initial go around
really nothing happened to anybody
no
no
you know what the only people um really
who have paid a price in this whole
thing are women uh from the victims to
um
you know even the prosecutors uh the pro
and
the prosecutors
that advocated for them this both the
state lead state prosecutor and the
federal prosecutor were women right um
but um you know the cases went nowhere
because their bosses who happen to all
be men
um sort of you know excuse what he did
and said look these victims aren't
credible uh they're prostitutes uh you
know um it wasn't a big deal
um you know there were all these excuses
that were made
yeah can you i'm getting more maybe talk
about i mean in every story there's also
an editor who sometimes is behind the
curtain
your interactions with casey frank are
quite
candid
and your thoughts about editors are
pretty candid i didn't take any umbrage
but talk about casey frank and the
relationship you had and how that either
helped or hindered or you know the whole
back and forth
well you know it's
it's you know journalism it can be very
messy and especially when you have two
headstrong people i'm very headstrong
and you know i'm quite candid about
myself as well i said you know that i'm
a hard person to deal with myself uh you
know i um i wasn't always you know i was
an editor at one point like
not long because i wasn't very good at
it and
uh i
i was tough you know
to some reporters and i regret it um
and so it is this dynamic where you're
sometimes you know at you know at cross
purposes
and uh
casey's been my editor for for probably
the whole almost the entire time uh 13
years i've been at the herald we are
almost always on the same page with the
kind of stories that we think are
important but sometimes the way that you
know i want to go about it isn't the way
that he thinks i should go about it so
and i as i said i'm pretty stubborn and
headstrong and so is he sometimes so we
clashed and um i was honest about that
and
um
i don't know i just i i
you know in the end um in my
acknowledgements i said however you know
he
we would have never had some of the
stories that we had if that didn't
happen that the same thing that made us
clash i think were the was the very
thing that made our stories
um so important and so um
you know
i mean we just covered all the bases
because
we had to we had to come together in the
end for the sake of the story were you
able to share your your fears i mean
literal fears that you and emily had
during this process and what did he do
to either swage them or help you what
kind of did you set up a system in case
strange things happened or the knock at
the door that type of thing
well you know it's funny here
i had some you know i had some weird
things happen with the prison stories
that i had done i remember calling
casey's uh one time
you know after someone had showed up in
my apartment in the middle of the night
i was pretty scared during the prison
series the epstein series i don't know
for whatever reason i didn't it i it
didn't really spook me until af well
after well after the series ran and i
was deep into it
so i didn't really have a reason to talk
to him about that uh emily however uh
it was a lot different than i am she she
was a lot more um paying attention to to
what was going on i was a little bit
more busy about the story we're two
different personalities that way so
we're a good balance with each other but
she would be like are you crazy why
would you do that you know so and the
book goes into a couple of those
anecdotes about emily and i with her
throwing the furniture in front of the
hotel room door and me just falling
asleep because i'm thinking whatever
emily uh
i you know like i said it wasn't until
after
you know we knew that it was really
serious that that that now epstein was
going to be arrested or you know the
congress had asked for a
justice department investigation that's
when weird things started happening you
know people showing up uh van parked in
front of emily's house around the clock
people um showing up outside my
apartment which is not an easy
place to to you know it's not a place
that people would be walking by you have
to go in an elevator and come up and you
know it was just odd things look i i
firmly believe that um there were people
that were investigating emily and i it
just they had to because
uh
the case had just gotten so hot and
epstein from the beginning after the
series ran
was afraid that he was going to be
charged i just know that because some
people around him told me he was worried
he was going to be charged
you explain bruce springsteen's role in
your work
you know just whenever i have a lot of
anxiety i just i always turn him on and
uh just listen to him means you know
after a long day writing and
uh you know i i grew up as you you know
we mentioned earlier in philadelphia and
i spent my summers at the jersey shore
and it just you know he's a great
storyteller you know he's brilliant and
i think his stories just helped make me
um he comforted me in some way
and so especially when i was writing the
book i was listening i i would after a
long day of writing i just would turn on
uh serious radio and just play him the
whole entire night to the point that my
kids were like
rolling their eyes like please mom do we
have to really listen to bruce
springsteen again you know kind of thing
so it was it was kind of part of the you
know
the fabric of my life when this story
was unfolding and you know it's a very
dark story it's a very um
you know people said how did how did you
do this this is really like a uh you
know you could really get depressed
doing this and i think just it was
something that helps keep me going kind
of
yeah it is a dark story i'm going to get
back to darkness now uh near the end of
the book one of the chapters is
did jeffrey epstein did not kill himself
uh
so that's a statement and i so can you
explain and take us through
either the process of using that
headline or that title chapter chapter
title or is that something you believe
i this is what i think i i used it sort
of because that's what everybody was it
was sort of a thing that was all over um
you know social media and everywhere i
mean in our culture you know you turned
on tv it was there and that mardi gras
parade my son went to mardi gras and
they had a float of jeffrey epstein
jeffrey epstein did not commit suicide
it became this i don't know this mantra
and
you know i did look at this and people
would always ask me when i was doing uh
i was doing a lot of college talks at
this time journalism classes and people
would ask me and
you know i had to be honest with myself
i i really didn't think he had he was
capable of of committing suicide by
himself now could he have um could it
have been assisted suicide yes
um i i think if we want to think that
that he wanted to end it
i think someone must have helped him i
just don't think he was capable i mean
and i'm not the only one that thinks
this his brother thinks that his lawyers
think that uh the forensic pathologist
that was at the autopsy doesn't believe
that he killed himself um you know there
are just too many
strange things that happen i mean
uh he had three bones broken in his neck
and dr michael baden the forensic
pathologist at the autopsy said you
rarely in in that kind of a uh hanging
have
three bones broken in your neck keep in
mind the theory was that he
he um did this with the bed sheets um
cutting these uh up and then he
kind of
pulled himself against the bunk he tied
it to the top bunk and he would have had
to pull himself with such vote i mean
there really wasn't according to bottom
enough velocity enough
room there for him to have done this and
broken three bones and
you know the toiletries that were on top
of his bunk weren't even disturbed
so um and then you have two guards that
are asleep at the wheel then you have
video disappear then you find out that
you know the guy that was in the cell
with him was taking that taken out just
hours before this happened i mean it's
just too i you know i've done crime
reporting and especially prison deaths
for a long time
and my god just tells me that that this
was not you know
just a suicide that he did by himself
well the way you wrote that chapter is
certainly all these questions you're
raising are laid out in a really
coherent way now there is some there is
an inquiry isn't there is or is that the
us attorney's office is supposed to be
doing something is new york on is that
happening or is it do you have any idea
new york is looking at um you know the
two corrections officers that were on
duty
um
already struck a plea deal so they're
quiet here we go again with everything
that's being sealed and nobody's talking
about that part of it and then there's a
separate justice department
investigation by the inspector general
of the justice department that is still
ongoing i don't know why it's taking
this long uh
so that's still open so you know and
even if the ruling comes out whatever
that ruling is i don't know whether the
evidence will ever be made public
yeah that's the as you allude to what
what let's you know jump more to the
present now uh because slain maxwell uh
will you be covering her trial and what
do you think will be coming out of that
well
um
gail and maxwell is sort of taking a
page out of the jeffrey epstein defense
playbook and that she's hired some very
a team of very high powered lawyers who
have
uh justice
previous experience in the justice
department and
uh you know they are bombarding the
prosecutors with all kinds of paperwork
you know motions and
uh just anything that they can kind of
throw at the wall hoping that it's going
to um
you know they're looking for
some kind of a loophole there
they're they're going to inevitably
argue that she was part of that original
you know in the original uh deal that
epstein struck
in 2008 there was this strange
uh sort of codicil to the deal where
uh he uh his co-conspirators four of
whom were named there were four women
who helped him with the schedule
uh were given immunity as well as well
as some
unnamed people that we still don't know
who they were
and
that her lawyers will argue that she was
one of those people now whether that'll
stick uh remains to be seen
yeah i mean acosta really shows up in
this again and again and there's you
know the uh justice department i mean
one of the details in the book
you wrote
did a review and basically found him
making
uh
guilty of poor judgment but no ethical
lapses and then there's a footnote in
that report
that says that uh
many of his emails have vanished
yeah i mean they have they didn't say
anybody else has
disappeared
it's not just his emails it's his emails
during the period when this deal was
done
have vanished so
you know
i guess it wasn't like they said well he
had a major
loss of all his emails it was the emails
during the period when this deal was
negotiated that disappeared
yeah
so in epstein's will which he wrote a
couple of days before he was found dead
right he listed his net worth i think
what he's 578 million
now
i think you said it in the end of the
book and these numbers may have changed
that a victim's compensation fund was
created
and that i think you said 175 women have
filed claims as alleged victims and so
forth 67 million has been paid out
so
those women you were aware of or what's
the process there can you talk about
that
well we don't really know a lot about
them but i know some of the lawyers who
represented them and these are women
some of whom by the way um
um
have said that
epstein
essentially trafficked them out to some
of these important men
but they are afraid to come forward
i mean you look at someone like alan
dershowitz who has
attacked the woman that was um that
accused him uh for years i mean he has
sued her he has
i mean
he has made her life really uh miserable
and i even got
to her when this was happening i even
got um emails and a couple of phone
calls from some people
who knew alan dershowitz
and said
that they would never say anything about
what they know because they're we're
afraid of them you know and
that's what these women's uh these
attorneys who represent some of these
women said that they
they're never gonna go public because
they're too afraid of what the men
uh will put them through
yeah when you read the book the list of
men who allegedly were involved here is
fairly astonishing
uh
and the denial is everywhere and then
also
what seems to be some very strong
evidence from some of these women and
also the pattern the pattern is there
it's not like necessarily even one-offs
i mean you really establish patterns
here which you must have seen in the
reporting
yes i you know it took a while to put a
lot of it together because not all of it
was in one place you know there were
different um you know there was a state
investigation the federal investigation
and the fbi report
then the civil lawsuits and so there
were a lot of different pieces and and i
think that that's another thing um
another piece of that that i kind of put
together in this book because you know
when you're
when you're doing a piece like this
there's
so much information and you can't always
put it everything in the story so this
kind of delves more into some of those
details that i could include in the
original story
you know for you do you do you feel like
you're done with this or are you look
you still want to be engaged i mean now
you're i guess you're starting a book
tour or at least a virtual book tour you
i'm sure you're exhausted
uh
you know and you know i want to see it
through uh but i i'm also mindful you
know
one of the other things i talk about in
this book is how i was on other stories
you know some people said well it must
be nice to do that nothing else well
that's not how it worked i i was doing
the parkland uh shootings i was doing
the shooting at the fort lauderdale
airport um i was covering other things
when this happened and you know we just
unfortunately had this horrible tragedy
here in surfside and um
you know
when we're you know
when you work for a paper you know a
smaller paper you just don't have the
luxury of just going off on one
thing i probably have a little bit more
of that luxury than other reporters but
um
you know you really have to to
to join in on the coverage you just have
to yeah
for the audience some context you know
20 years ago or so julie would have been
what they called detached
just to work on this and had the freedom
to do it but these days as newsrooms are
about probably the fifth of what they
were so
sometimes it's all hands in even on when
she's in the middle of a huge and
important story like this so again
i just think it's uh speaks volumes
about
your persistence and your
work ethic and your determination uh to
do this and i you know i know what how
difficult that is and i respect the hell
out of it
um
you know there's some here's a question
from the audience uh and you've touched
on it a couple of times
but what are some of the questions
remaining mysteries you know about
what jeff epstein that you wonder about
and that you have any potential hope
anything will come out
the loose threads
for all that i mean uh you know i i i
think one of the things um for example
is
i you know didn't anybody keep track
here was a guy who who was a
convicted sex offender accused of
molesting girls and he gets out of jail
in 2009 and nobody's paying attention to
where he's flying his plane and who's on
his plane i mean it's just mind-boggling
to me
does anybody watch these
people when they get out you know and
make sure that they're not you know
getting other girls from you know
eastern europe and bringing them to our
country it just seemed to me that he
wasn't having any problems after he got
out of jail he returned to his regular
life and no one was paying any attention
to him so you know that's one thing i
think should absolutely be looked at i
mean why weren't they checking his plane
when he got off in st thomas and asking
those girls how old they were
yeah that one really jumped out and i
think in the book you also show that
there were there were in fact young
women or girls
brought from overseas
uh to new york
and then the who's who can you go can
you talk a little bit about the who's
who
uh of the mansion in new york and also
one of the details i think in one of the
hearings to
not give him bail when he was still
alive
was that the assistant u.s attorney
described how in the manhattan mansion
they were they found hundreds of
thousands not thousands hundreds of
thousands of photographs
of semi-nude you know 13 14 15 year old
girls
and i don't know what that indicated and
also a trove of diamonds
you know it is safe i mean uh but what i
mean the new york mansion also i mean
well we know you write about some of the
people who went there including bill
gates and i think you know other elected
officials
prince andrew and um
you know um
you know and the people that flew on his
plane you know bill clinton um trump
flew on his plane um you know all these
people were in and out of uh
you know his life over this time period
when he was involved with this sex
trafficking operation
um
you know
the victims some of them have accused
some of the men of being involved um of
course we you know
this is a crime that you know doesn't
really have any witnesses you know when
you're in a room with a man doing this
to you there's really nobody there
to corroborate it except for of course
epstein who's gone now and um
you know there's been a lot of talk of
videos whether they're whether he had
videos um you know compromise on some of
these men
i mean we really don't know for sure
i've heard different things from
different people
uh
but you know it makes you wonder whether
anybody else is really going to be held
accountable
are you still getting tips and leads on
this from people out of the blue
yes
i just got a couple this week because
the book is getting some press and i'm
hearing from people saying
you know call me i i know this so
i'll call them all and you know see if
any there's any truth to to you know
their tips um
usually
as you know when you have a story like
this you know i would say
80
90 percent of them are
are not good good information but if you
get one or two percent that make a
difference one of the tips that i did
get after this series ran was the one
about the st thomas airport um my air
traffic controller had called me or a
friend i should clarify it was a friend
of an air traffic controller who told
him that this air traffic controller had
seen him disembark his plane with a
bunch of girls well
talking about sources you you write a
chapter there about a couple of really
sketch characters uh patrick kessler and
mark dugan
i mean those two i mean
what do you make of that i mean it was
almost like they were planted or they
were just
what do you think i i just had to
include it because the story is so
bizarre it's almost like if you did a
movie about it you wouldn't believe that
these characters actually existed but
they really did and you know the new
york times did a whole um you know story
about the patrick kessler which i knew
about it as it was unfolding
but
you know quite a few people told me that
they thought he was a phony so i just
kept thinking
uh you know why is the new york times
still pursuing it because everything i
was hearing anything tell us a little
detail about what that what he was up to
he claimed that he had video that
somehow he had gotten a hold of these uh
long lost epstein video that he had uh
either helped epstein i'm trying to
remember the details but he had helped
epstein catalog them or hide them or
something to that effect
uh the name he was you know a made-up
name uh he
he basically uh showed some of the
stills from the video he had to
uh two of the lawyers that represented
uh virginia dufrese who's uh one of the
uh victims
and
it implied that you know that this was
finally evidence against some of these
famous men and it was these videos of
some of these famous men that were
allegedly involved and ultimately he
never produced it the lawyers wanted to
authenticate the videos that he claimed
he had and he never produced them and he
just disappeared so
you know
you know the thought was that he it was
just a phony
and you have several characters
throughout the book who
raise allegations
disappear and i and it's almost you i
think a couple of times you say that
it was almost could have been entrapment
also from from
lawyers i suspect that they were trying
to prep um david boyes who um
you know represented virginia and was
the nemesis and remains the nemesis of
alan dershowitz who
you know
right after that happened he filed a
motion in his court case against
virginia that you know
involving this patrick kessler thing
about how boys had tried to you know
use this somehow uh to
blackmail him or others which was really
uh my research and my you know interview
showed that was not the case i was
talking to david boyce while this was
happening and david was telling me the
guy's a fake so um
you know it's just i think just the
whole story is filled with these
characters and
these connections and in the middle of
it all are these
women that that really have never found
justice
and that's the sad part about this
yeah i think there are
uh
actually some hero lawyers as well or
who did the right thing i mean we didn't
really talk about brad edwards who i
think was really crucial to this in
terms of the civil suit
cases he filed and hopefully the reader
people will read the book and learn that
but i do want to and and we're getting
near the end a couple of questions
one near the end of the book you talk
about the reckoning
that's the chapter and
in that
some of the young women actually
it's not that they're
they find retribution or whatever but or
even healing but they're they're given
an opportunity can you talk about that
and that scene in that courtroom
yeah it was right after epstein um died
and
uh they were gonna it was just a
you know normally this kind of hearing
is just a formality it was to just for
the judge to drop the case essentially
there was no more case because he had
died uh but the judge wanted to give the
women an opportunity to say their peace
to speak about what had happened to them
so uh quite a number of them showed up
for this hearing and the first thing you
notice is they were very still very
similar in the way they carried
themselves and they looked they were you
know you could tell they had model
postures and they uh they were very slim
and most of them were blonde and um
so it was like you could tell because
they were all looked alike and i think
that you know i i you know quite frankly
i went to the ladies room one time and i
could hear them talking to each other
and they're sort of saying yeah i
remember you do you remember this and uh
they had this they were starting to form
this bond they had been through
something so horrible together
and some of them had never met each
other before but they knew some of the
same women or they knew
maxwell or they knew uh people that were
in that orbit that had um answered the
door or helped schedule them so they
were finding this common
ground that was and they were using it
to to support each other
yeah and that day in court they were
actually able to testify to what had
happened to them not in the specific
detail of the an act but just the
process in who they were brought to him
that they were victims they were
testifying as victims really for the
first time
and i think in the courtroom there were
dozens that day and only a few ended up
testifying is that right
that's right um well there were quite a
number who who who spoke out they not
all of them wanted to identify
themselves which was understandable it
was very emotional
you know some of them and i go into this
in my book some of the stories that they
told were were horrendous you know about
how they were taken advantage of i'm not
just talking about sexually but mentally
the mental aspect of this is is just as
important almost
almost as important a component of what
he did he mentally
manipulated them
well as a society now we're hearing more
and more about this unfortunately and uh
we this is the last question julie i
know you've been going all day and it's
evening in miami uh
is there going to be a movie and who's
going to play you
oh gosh i i
there's going to be a um
hbo uh adam mckay the director um
is working on a
uh series a limited series for hbo about
it and uh i'm helping with the the
script i'm being interviewed all the
time by the screenwriter and uh we
always joke on who's going to play me
and i i just
you know uh you know i don't know you
know i guess um maybe have a new career
on the on the big screen
i don't think so i don't think so i'm
not very uh articulate as you can tell
from this interview i'm oh you've been
great
well we're going to end it now and i i
really truly want to thank you for your
work uh you've made a big difference uh
you've had a great career and i'm sure
there's a lot ahead of you and you've
overcome
your persistence in overcoming obstacles
uh
as i said is inspirational uh for a lot
of people uh and journalists especially
uh
we could have gone much longer and i
just recommend the book for anybody and
i want to thank you for joining us today
for this really important conversation i
want to thank our audience here in san
francisco and online around the country
the program today will be available as a
video and podcast on the club's website
www
www.commonwealthclub.org
and i'm robert rosenthal and now this
meeting of the commonwealth club the
place where you're in the know is
adjourned have a good evening
see ya bye
here's a look at some homo
so i think he should stay
all right to sandra in east point
michigan hi there
um
there's a big difference in sexual
harassment and sexual assault
no i don't think cuomo should leave
donald trump sexually assaulted
18 women
and there was this woman on tv about six
months ago she had a radio talk show in
new york city
she was in a store across the street
from trump tower
and donald trump came up to her and he
asked if she'd help him find something
for his girlfriend he asked her to try
on these clothes so he could see what
they look like on
she said she walked to the to the room
as she went to
shut the changing room door
trump
pushed his way in slammed the door
shoved her into a wall and ripped her
now she didn't tell the police because
she would have probably lost her talk
show
and i mean donald trump is so much worse
nobody
i mean i don't think
white somebody doesn't do something
about him you know when he was at his
friend jeffrey epstein's house and this
has proven there was a witness to him
raping a 13 year old girl and then
threatening her life and then
threatening the witness's life now
so no cuomo shouldn't leave no
this is dumo next up in hiram georgia
who also says no
morning yes thank you yes thank you for
taking my call
resign for what is not only
an important thing
it is the only thing
we embrace that in american culture
robert e lee
symbolizes something different
he symbolized
the possibility of dignity
in the face of defeat
he symbolized the possibility that the
winners
the bernie madoffs the michael milkens
the ivan boskies the jeffrey epstein's
the winners are not necessarily
the good
and the people who wind up paying for
those deeds are not necessarily bad
that message
was wrapped up in the lee statues too
and we may regret losing that
in a dog-eat-dog world
there's one more factor
monuments
like the leafy.org
and book tv's coverage of the miami book
fair continues now with miami herald
investigative reporter julie k brown who
discusses her in-depth look into the
jeffrey epstein criminal case
this program will get underway shortly
[Music]
hello good evening and welcome to the
38th edition of the miami book fair
and my name is patrick nellis i work
here at the college in the center for
learning and it's my pleasure to get us
started for this evening i have a couple
of announcements
so one is that the book fair doesn't
just end tonight it carries on
throughout the year we've got
events all over town and live streaming
and so on so stay in touch with
the miami book fair on the web
furthermore we need to acknowledge the
hundreds of volunteers that make this
event possible and our major sponsors
without whom we could not run the book
fair the knight foundation the bachelor
foundation the meredith ann dasberg
foundation the green family foundation
stephanie anson
and stuart's spencer stewart t-mobile
and many other sponsors
i also need to do this every time can we
see a show of hands to the friends of
the book fair
great and let's give yourselves a round
of applause for being friends of the
book fair
the book fair needs friends uh find out
about the perks of joining us as a
friend of the book fair we have a table
downstairs i have a couple of
announcements one is please try to make
your phone quiet so it doesn't interrupt
and
we will take questions and answers
towards the end of the presentation we
have a microphone in the middle of the
room and we'll ask you to line up and
one question per customer so that people
can get an opportunity following the
talk the author
julie brown will be
at the author signing desk
passed on this floor past the elevators
i'll be escorting her down there after
the talk and you can purchase her book
at the table outside
of the room with this i'm going to
introduce our
our master ceremonies for this evening
who's going to introduce the speaker
this is maria meyer she's the interim
executive director of the women's fund
miami-dade
as one billion rising global coordinator
for miami she's worked with activists
across the u.s
to create the awareness and solidarity
necessary to end
the staggering statistics of gender
violence maria is a member of the south
florida human trafficking task force
and miami-dade human
trafficking coalition
so much
good evening to all here present
whether virtually or in this auditorium
i'm maria meyer very proudly
representing your women's fund
miami-dade and our mutual supporters of
the book fair and of the women's fund
from the shepherd broad foundation
together tonight we will focus here on
power
power of one writer's proverbial pen
the power of narcissism and unmitigated
privilege
and the power of investigative
journalism to focus a critical
magnifying lens
long and hard enough on the facts to
spark the collective outrage necessary
to leverage action
miami herald investigative journalist
julie k brown relentlessly pursued how
jeffrey epstein's years-long engagement
in exploitation and sex trafficking
remained unchecked
for decades he freely moved through high
society and political circles
leaving more and more survivors in his
wake
her version of justice shines a
spotlight on these crimes and long-time
avoidance of any real consequences
not legal not financial nor personal
it's a fascinating and in-depth look at
a gross miscarriage of justice
as director of the knight foundation's
journalism program karen redlett's
philanthropic focus is on investing in
new methods to advance excellence in
journalism and civic media
as a way to support informed local
communities
and that is what is about to happen here
please join me in welcoming her and
author julie k brown to the miami book
fair stage
hi julie hi hi everyone thank you so
much for coming tonight
um
let's get started by
julie and i used to work together at the
miami herald
but i'm not sure that
everyone knows her very well and also
there's quite a bit in this book that i
learned about her so
why don't we start by learning a little
bit about you um
so let's just start with where are you
from how'd you grow up
how'd you end up in journalism
thank you all for coming by the way um
it's good to be back in person at the
book fair
um
i
i grew up in a little tiny town outside
of philadelphia called sellersville
and um
you know my mother was a single mom with
three children and um needless to say we
struggled quite a bit um
and i think instilled in me some of the
things my mother went through as a
single mom i remember one time we came
home and all the furniture was gone from
our house because my mother couldn't pay
a utility bill
so
you know just the
you know
injustices that i felt that she suffered
um sort of instilled in me i think at a
young age that i wanted to do something
about it
so that's kind of led me into writing
writing was an outlet for me when i was
very young uh and
you know that the fact that you know i
would read you know stories about great
um people and how they
overcame obstacles in their lives and i
think that that made me also want to
write you know stories about people like
that or to in some way make a difference
in other people's lives
so you started your career career in
philadelphia
and uh what what was that like what were
you writing about what were you
reporting on
well i started actually in hunterdon
county i worked for every small paper
that you could ever imagine i started
really at the bottom you know doing
obituaries which are actually very good
training ground actually
because you have to learn everything
about a person and tell this story about
them in a very respectful way so i i
just really
went up the ladder you know and um in
the beginning i mean i couldn't support
myself on journalism salary and
i worked as a waitress you know sort of
like actors do starving actors i was
starving journalists so i worked a
couple of jobs just to kind of pay the
rent and
you know and then i finally got a big
break when i was hired by the
philadelphia daily news which was a
metropolitan
big metropolitan newspaper in
philadelphia and you know then moved to
the big city
and then you eventually ended up in
south florida
yeah so
um you were an editor for a while and
you talk about that in the book and then
you eventually went back to reporting
why don't you tell us about
what it takes to be a reporter how do
you get your stories you reported on
prisons for a number of years
well i i did a lot of
you know i always felt like one of the
ways that i could stay in this business
was to make sure that i could do
everything i could learn a little bit
about everything and um so i just tried
to be very nimble you know and just
every time they asked me to do something
i said yes because i feared i would be
able to keep my job if i if i uh worked
hard enough and just never argued so and
at least in the beginning of my uh
career i didn't argue a lot and i did
everything i was told to do that of
course as i became more experienced i
started arguing more but
but um
yeah it was um
you know i did you know running after
murder scenes in the worst neighborhoods
of philadelphia
going to fires in the middle of the
night car crashes i mean
probably almost everything i i've done
at one time or another um but i really
liked the crime
i really kind of got a niche with
covering crime and then from crime i
realized um you know that the police
didn't always do a good job
of investigating and so i realized that
i could find out things that the police
didn't even know and that's sort of
that's when i got the bug to be to do
more investigative work
so again you had been working covering
women's prisons and done really
exceptional work but you were looking
for something else and
how did you really find this story what
is it that you first saw that made you
really want to go deeper
what shocked you
well you know this was an old story i
didn't
contrary to what some people often um
say i didn't break the jeffrey epstein
story this had happened a decade before
i took it up and it did get a lot of
coverage in certain places um
particularly in palm beach at the time
that it happened originally but it
didn't get much traction nationally and
i think it kind of dropped off the radar
after everybody just kind of concluded
that jeffrey epstein got off or got this
very lenient sentence because he was
very wealthy and that's just the way our
system works
and i felt that
you know
that's not a good enough reason you know
i felt like there was more to it i
always suspected that there was
some kind of corruption involved in it
and then when donald trump was nominated
i'm sorry when donald trump was running
for president
a woman had filed a lawsuit against him
and jeffrey epstein claiming that he had
sexually assaulted her
along with jeffrey epstein as well so
you know there was an article that i
read in in a newspaper where they were
sort of taking the mainstream media to
task for not looking into
this whole story about epstein and trump
and this woman
and i
you know i had already known about the
case and i thought this does seem weird
maybe i should take a look so as i was
sort of starting to pick away at looking
at the case
uh trump got elected and then he
nominated alex acosta as labor secretary
and i knew that alex acosta was the
person who had signed off on this
sweetheart plea deal that epstein
received so i
thought at the time like i wonder what
these
victims who were
young you know 13 14 years old at the
time now they're in their late 20s i
wonder what they think about the fact
that the man that swore you know pretty
much let their predator off the hook
was now in charge of a large agency with
oversight on human trafficking and child
labor laws
so
my initial goal was just to try to see
if the victims would finally come
forward and talk to me but as i started
digging more and more into the story i
found
you know so much more there was so much
more to the story the victims how they
were treated but also how epstein
managed to manipulate just about every
part of this case
and and the prosecutors kind of looked
the other way as he was doing it or
relented
continually and let him get away with it
the thing about the the reporting is it
really
looked at the entire system and you
talked a lot you speak about that a lot
you wrote about that a lot in the book
um just
the different uh
the different uh
he would he would hire
um attorneys that were married to other
attorneys and so then somebody would be
eliminated there was conflict of
interest
um so tell me a little bit about the
process you know investigative reporting
there's a mystery around it and there's
also you you spend time digging into
records and it doesn't necessarily
turn something up or sometimes you go
down too many rabbit holes why don't we
get into the process of the work that
you did
well you know no one just wakes up one
day and decides to be an investigative
reporter uh you know there are a lot of
reporters that don't like doing
investigative work um there's a lot of
reporters that do great journalism
um in a certain like business journalism
or or aspects of um
you know journalism that i couldn't do
you know somehow i mean you have to
you know my
kind of i think the thing that led me to
do investigative journalism is because i
just always wanted to get to the truth
you know
and i felt like um there was so much
going on in our country and in society
where i thought
sometimes
we just really don't know how this
happened like how this
particular person ended up in this
particular place
and that always fascinated me and all
often when i looked into it there was
always a story you know and that's what
we do even though it's a lot of digging
it's also about telling stories because
that's what makes people interested so
you have to
your work is kind of twofold in that you
have to um
you know dig through these dense
horribly boring documents you know that
are written by people like lawyers and
it's the last thing sorry any lawyers
here sorry maybe yours but you've got to
kind of make sense out of it and you
know it isn't really easy to do that and
in this particular phase there was
tens of thousands of documents you know
that had been filed over the years
because after the criminal case ended
there were all these civil lawsuits that
were filed so
you know like a dozen civil lawsuits and
you know each one of them had like you
know 200 docket entries you know in the
system so
i realized at first i thought when i did
it i thought i could do what i always do
which is usually what a reporter does is
they take the motion for summary
judgment you know the complaint the
motion for summary judgment you know the
key documents that you know where
they're laying out their case and then
you can write a story off of that but i
quickly realized that it wasn't gonna
work in this case because i would read
something in the for example in the
motion for summary of judgment i'm like
what
where'd they get that and then i thought
i've gotta you know then i'd go to that
document and then that document would i
would be like
there's no way i'm sort of cherry
picking documents i said i've got to sit
down i got to read every single thing
because
by doing that i was able to put
take this story apart and put it back
together in a way i think that other
people hadn't been able to do so how
long did that take you
it took me a good
year and a half
to read all those documents and some
there were there were documents that you
couldn't get access to
that you needed the herald to help you
get right
fortunately um and you know i i i should
have mentioned uh the herald um a lot
sooner because i couldn't have really
done this without the support of the the
herald um especially since investigative
reporting by the way is the most costly
thing that a newspaper does
imagine you know your
you know one of the ways for example
that people get around
giving you
public documents is by charging a lot
for them so you'll say i want this
investigation on a copy of it and
they'll say well it's five thousand
dollars you know and then you gotta
negotiate with them and maybe you only
get half of it or you only get the first
10 pages or you only get the summary
but
it is very expensive to do investigative
work and that's why you should buy
newspapers because you're only paying
you know i don't know what it is now i
paid 10 a month for the online version
but you know
buying these documents that we buy that
you would never otherwise have uh access
to is part of what goes into the price
of the newspaper you know that's
actually in your twitter bio you said
real journalism costs money please buy a
newspaper
um
so
you know they're really highs and lows
there there are times where you're
you're you're digging deep and um
[Music]
you're
not finding things
um and there are times where you are
they're just some highs so
tell me uh in the in the reporting
process in this year and a half what was
a moment that was a big win and you knew
you were able to advance this and what
was the moment that was really difficult
well the most challenging part of this
case was finding the victims because
you know now they were in their late 20s
some of them had gotten married you know
others had gone to jail um there was you
know
they were first of all all their names
were redacted from the documents because
they were minor minors so how do you
find out who these women even are
so you know what i learned you know with
all the experience that i had by this
point was that inevitably when you get
these uh files that are redacted they
forget to redact things
so you know you might get a first name
accidentally unredacted here or a birth
date and i just put together a big
spreadsheet with everything i knew about
each of the victims and when it was all
said and done i had a list of 60 women
and
then you have to try to contact them and
so that was probably the biggest
challenge
um that i had was and that took a long
time finding them and and in the process
of doing that in order to find them i
had to find out a little bit about them
and i recognized the pattern with these
young women that their lives
had been dramatically
altered by what had happened to them you
know the abuse that they suffered you
know a lot of them had
fallen into drug addiction
or had ended up in jail
some of them had were victims of
domestic you know abuse
so i could see right away that this was
you know that these victims really
suffered an awful lot of pain in the
years that followed
so um the story just
kind of morphed into
you know originally going to be just a
reaction to
acosta being nominated and his victims
saying what they thought about it to
me realizing that this was a total
utter failure on the part of the
criminal justice system in a horrible
way
and so
you know and then you know you have to
kind of talk your editor into
letting you do more and to pay more and
that was a breeze right it was easy your
editor just said yes to everything i'm
sure yeah just do these five stories
first you know uh
so yeah it's it's it's you know i was
doing covering a hurricane in the middle
of this um we had um it was quite a
parkland parkland happened in the middle
of this and of course we dropped
everything and you know i was up there
doing stories in parkland so you know
you don't just
you know stop doing all the other work
that we have to do
um and i like i like doing that i like
going back and forth actually i think
gives you a fresh perspective when you
um kind of break away for for a little
while and then go back to it and then
you realize oh my gosh i still have so
much work to do
so and you you worked with a partner you
worked with emily michonne yes emily i
think emily is here somewhere oh yes
there she is um
yes i could not have done this without
emily she um
she's kind of my guiding force
because i could go off the rails
sometimes so
yes and you know
her work
um on the visual part of this we did a
number of documentaries that accompanied
the series which were interviews with
the victims and they in my view were
really the most powerful part of the
whole entire project because
this was
you know i i say now because the story
is now an international story and every
journalist in the world is practically
uh on the story but and i i say this all
the time to emily
no one will ever
capture the rawness that emily captured
and i'm getting chills just thinking
about it um
because
those nobody had cared about what those
girls thought before we met them and
you know to be there when they were
talking about it for the first time in a
decade
and the emotions that poured out of them
um
nobody's ever going to capture that the
way that emily did and um so that i
would encourage anybody to go online and
see the documentaries because they were
really a very very if not the most
important part
of the project and you know when you
said what was the moment when you knew
the moment that we knew was when we
interviewed the first victim and i still
get teary every time i talk about it
because it was just a moment that we
knew we had such a good and important
story and um
we just knew you know that was a big
breakthrough
so the story was published
sorry
take a moment yeah go ahead sorry
so the story was published november 28th
2018.
um it's november 21st today so yeah
three years three years ago yeah three
years ago um and
at this point three years ago um
you were being lawyered those lawyers
again
lawyers are reviewing everything
including uh
the videos the documentary videos that
um emily worked on with you
and um
what's happening i there's
something happened on thanksgiving day
well emily was making pies because we
just talked about this because she's
we're almost thanksgiving i said are you
gonna be making pies with her family and
the lawyers were working on it over the
holiday because it was supposed to run
that next weekend and they called her
and told her she had to rework one of
the whole videos so she had to drop
everything and she went she reworked the
whole thing like a trooper of course she
called me screaming and yelling but
but um
yeah
it's just what we do you know um
it's um it's just very challenging work
but it's very important work and i think
if you keep your eye on what the goal is
um
you kind of push through it you know all
the challenges all the arguments with
the editors and
you know
you know the resources the lack of
resources the fact that they you know
they don't want to
you know pay for this or pay for that
and it's just it's hard sometimes but
you you know you just take deal with it
you know like a professional
so i would love for you to read from the
book
exactly what happened on the day that
you published i know that
you were hoping that
it would
be a splash for a day if you were lucky
so i would love it if you would read
that section page 276.
story was published uh online and uh
yeah they put the whole series out
online um right away on um
i think it was a thursday
and i went in real early that morning
because i knew it was going to launch
and we were going to do a lot of social
media on it
and
you know
your exhaust i was absolutely exhausted
because
you know we had been editing it for
weeks and working on the video and
you just at the point where you just
wanted to be all over
i want this to be done i want to go home
and go to bed
so
that
the launch time for the online version
of the story kept changing but we
finally finally landed on november 28th
at 7 00 am
i went home that night and tossed in bed
unable to sleep i finally gave up and
got up about four am
i headed to the gym at five and climbed
on the elliptical trainer
i remember praying the entire time i was
on the machine that my story would at
least last one day online before being
forgotten
i went home showered threw on jeans and
a t-shirt and drove to the doral
newsroom just after dawn
i stopped and bought sixty dollars worth
of bagels and coffee for the crew that
morning hoping i had enough money in my
bank account to cover the expense
when i walked into the newsroom i looked
at the large digital screen in the
center of the room that lists the
herald's most read stories that morning
at the top of the list was a story about
a woman who had farted in a dollar store
the headline was woman passes gas in
store then pulls knife
it was getting thousands of hits
i almost never paid attention to the
stories at the top of the board they
were often click bait that we in other
newspapers used to lure our readers to
the other more serious journalism on our
website
at about 8 a.m the three parts of the
series along with the massive grass
graphic all the videos a timeline and a
piece called how we got the story were
launched under the headline
how a future trump cabinet member gave a
serial sex abuse abuser the deal of a
lifetime
i began tweeting out the stories
i hardly had any followers on twitter so
it was a short task
our two social media talents noel
gonzalez and adrian rui were busy
blitzing the stories across the internet
universe i had a bagel watch the board
with my stories at the very bottom of
the list then began packing up with the
intention of going home to sleep i was
relieved my work was done
the newsroom was starting to get busy as
more staff arrived for work
suddenly reporter rene rodriguez shouted
over have you seen the board
i walked over and my stories all three
of them were climbing fast the first one
had thousands of hits
well it's never going to top that fart
story i said walking back to my desk
before turning off my computer i looked
at my twitter account i suddenly had
thousands of followers
then the unbelievable happened
it beat the fart story
the room erupted in applause
my phone started ringing and my computer
mailbox was filling up with
congratulations
the first call i took was from my
greater
writer which i always mispronounced his
name writer he was more he was more than
elated
finally he said someone had put together
the epstein story in a way that would
make people understand the scope of his
crimes and worse how prosecutors helped
epstein get away with them
writer's words meant the world to me
that's it
so have you seen alex acosta at all
lately have you no no not no not at all
i don't think anybody has seen him
actually yeah so i haven't had any
sightings let's put it that way
so um
[Music]
look this story it it has connections to
two former presidents it has connections
to a prince it has um
prestigious uh attorneys all over it
and
coming up next week next week
after thanksgiving there will be another
trial
there is a chapter in here um there is a
chapter in the book about um how this
ended for jeffrey epstein and i know
that's something people always want to
know from you what do you think happened
so what do you think happened
well i don't think he committed suicide
um i know a lot of people disagree with
that but uh i you know i covered prisons
for a long time and i know the way that
corruption happens
and this was a textbook case of you know
a suspicious death
and um there were just too many holes in
the whole story i mean he
uh you know he had just come off a
suicide watch he
you know they took the guy who was a
cell cellmate out just hours before this
allegedly happened he you know the two
you didn't just have one guard fall
asleep you had two guards fall asleep
the cameras weren't working um you know
they take the body remove the body
without even taking photographs i mean
it the whole thing
just
it it just doesn't make any sense
coupled with the fact that epstein was
the kind of person that believed he was
above the law
he really had gotten away with this the
first time
and this was an old case
um he conceivably could claim that you
know the these charges were based on the
plea bargain that he had agreed to with
federal prosecutors in florida and
therefore he was already the charges
were already disposed of and he was only
in prison for like a month when he
allegedly committed suicide he was
hiring lawyers up until you know that
week he was hiring new lawyers so the
whole thing um
just doesn't make sense that he would
have
done it to begin with but not only that
but done it by his own hand which this
was a man that didn't do anything on his
own you know he had you know people
practically tying his own shoelaces you
know and for him to break three bones
not one bone but three bones in his neck
and do it by somehow leaning forward by
tying something to the top bunk
and he would do that it's just
it's just unfathomable to me that it
happened that way now do i think that
it's possible if he wanted to do himself
any he he probably would have hired
somebody to do it he wouldn't have he
wouldn't have done it i just don't think
he was capable of doing it on his own
so will you be covering the trial that's
upcoming for
elaine yeah yeah
yeah okay
um and um
we are going to open it up to
folks for questions as well so if you
have questions um
i am what are you what how are you
preparing for that how are you preparing
to report on that
yeah you know that's a really good
question this is going to be a real
challenge because it's going to be a
media circus and we're i'm probably
here's a real funny thing i can't get
press credentials
for this trial i can't get them
yeah
they won't give me press credentials and
she's probably wouldn't be
trying she wouldn't be in jail right now
if it wasn't for me but i can't get
credentials because i'm not a new york
uh journalist so you have to be like a
new york journalist to get credentials
in the uh courthouse so i'm i'm just
praying that i'll be able to get in the
courtroom and
you know hope for the best you know
and um please if anyone if anyone does
want to ask questions we have a mic oh
hello
don't you go to the mic so if you can
line up in the middle and behind the mic
we'll go one person at a time one okay
hi thank you so much i'm very inspired
by all your hard work
and um
my question is are you
were you afraid of any threats of
retaliation and is there anything
that ever happened as a result i'm never
afraid emily is the one that kind of
makes me worry because she's the one
that has she's the voice of reason in
our team
because um i just
i just don't think about it until it's
pointed out to me like i would always
tell people um no i wasn't worried but
now that you bring it up now i'm worried
you know um
you can't you know when i was covering
the prisons i was far more worried about
my safety than i was with this case
i was able to
essentially do this story under the
radar
jeffrey epstein had no idea what he was
what he was confronting he really didn't
know i mean we contacted him but i think
he just thought this is just some little
reporter from the miami herald and
what's she going to get that nobody else
has already gotten so
uh you know i think that that worked my
favor that i worked for a small local a
really small but a regional newspaper
and not the new york times if it was the
new york times knocking on his door as
much as i did
he probably would have paid closer
attention to be honest with you so
no i i didn't really worry until after
the series ran and then we had a couple
of um
suspicious things happen which i'll have
to get my book and you'll have to read
it in my book
thank you
hi julie um
since
you believe and so did the guy who
destroyed the uh
the the painting at uh
basil last year
uh
that he didn't commit suicide
uh are you gonna are you gonna track and
see what happens see
if you can find out
you know you know what i don't know how
much of this how much of my life should
i dedicate to this story
you know there's so many other stories
you know i in my mind this story was one
that people you know that had been
forgotten and that there was still some
justice to be done
and i don't know i kind of tend to think
that my job with this story is almost
over and then i need to find another
story like this one that or you know
that people aren't paying attention to
you know
i think you know it's been like three
years
four and a half since i took it up so i
kind of think that maybe it's time for
me to let other people take up that you
know we'll be talking about this like
the jfk assassination there will be
documentaries going on well after we're
all gone about who killed jeffrey
epstein that's my thought
okay thank you
my basic question is
do you think that jeffrey epstein was
blackmailing leslie wex wexner who's the
head of the limited
and how did epstein push out harold
levin
the former money manager for
wexner bexner
you know when i did this series um i had
you know there was so many angles to
this case you know all the powerful
people that he knew and you know how did
he get his money and um you know there
was just all these rabbit holes that i
could have you know jumped down and um
i had to at some point sort of define
the story and
do you know a certain piece of it
because there was no way i could do at
all and so i didn't really look into
that part of it to be honest with you i
mean now we know a lot more about
that um you know all his connections and
all the people that he probably had uh
the goods on so to speak and certainly
wexner is in that category uh you know
he he wexner has already been on the
record as saying that epstein's stole
millions of dollars from him he never
reported it
why do you not report it you re you
don't report it because epstein has
something on you and it's it's you know
what he has is is far more damaging than
you know the whatever it is the 50
million that he stole from me so he you
know epstein also was very good at
making people
feel that he had something on them where
or that he had you know connections you
know i don't know how deep his
connections were to some of these people
but because he had
or he talked about it or he had
photographs of him with all these people
and all these people allowed him
themselves to be with him it gave him
some credibility that he probably
wouldn't otherwise have had if he was
just a regular you know
multi-millionaire but he used these
people to some degree to give himself
you know leverage over even more
important people
so he was a good con man so it's hard to
know how much he really the how much
dirt he really had versus how much he
led people to believe that he had
julie first i just want to thank you for
being such an inspiration to young
journalists
shorter than the guy before me
you are truly an inspiration and my
question for you the part of the book
that i just loved so much was you know
the challenges of being an investigative
reporter here you have this amazing
story and still you're pulling teeth uh
to get the article written so
in in light of where we are today with
newspapers do you have thoughts on
structural changes or foundational
changes in the news business
that could help save
newspapers large and small through
throughout the country
oh gosh if i knew the solution to that
man
i'd probably win a pulitzer prize for
that um
you know it is such a tough battle
because our attention is just focused so
many other places now with the you know
the internet and social media and
everything it is absolutely crazy i i
don't know really what the answer is i
you know the only thing i can say is i
think people still want to read
good stories and good journalism and
i don't think that'll ever go away you
still need the content you know you
might get the headline by turning on
your tv but you're really not going to
get a good story out of it and you know
of course all all of you are here
because you're you're readers you know
so you probably i'm i'm preaching to the
choir here you probably all understand
all that but there's a whole
another part of our world that of people
that just don't you know they don't read
they really don't they just turn on you
know tv
and they hear something from sean
hannity and they think that that's all
based on fact and that's all a story uh
or
you know anderson cooper whoever
your persuasion is but it it goes both
ways i mean this is a world where i
think our education system really has to
do a better job i think that that's
where it starts you know with our
education system and
thanks
hello
hi i dabbled with the herald a few years
back so it's nice to see another
reporter
um
so
i'm kind of curiously have you ever seen
any of the uh
versions of the epstein story that have
been adapted to popular uh television
shows like say law and orders version of
it and what your opinion of theirs is
no
i've never seen it i don't really watch
a whole lot of tv i really you know i'm
kind of i had to force myself sometimes
to watch certain things that are news
related because i know that i should
watch them but i'm just not a good tv
watcher i think i have a short attention
span
hi julie um
thank you
no there's no oh there's no one else um
i wanted to ask about um
how you navigated
um the controversy of the story and in
particular the fact that uh there are a
lot of
conspiratorial
theories going around about it because
it seems like uh
discussing whether or not uh epstein
killed himself is sometimes equated with
discussing whether or not he was a
government agent or discussing whether
or not the clintons did it or anything
like that so
how do you navigate that kind of
controversy and how are you able to
pursue
the right sources when there are so many
competing theories out there
well i i think it's important to
you know whenever you do a story as a
journalist you have to make sure that
you have some facts to back it up and so
when some of these stories come
you know come up one of the you know
these conspiracy theories
you just go to people like an expert
that knows about the bones in the neck
you know like i interviewed michael
baden who i have a lot of respect for
he's a
really um well-known forensic
pathologist and he was president of
epstein's autopsy and i i've worked with
him for years on
the deaths that i covered in the prison
system and
he explained in very clear detail about
why he didn't feel epstein committed
suicide so and i have a lot like i said
and also i have a lot of experience
covering crimes and just
common sense things didn't happen in
this case that would happen you have to
treat this as a potential crime scene
from the very beginning because you
can't go back and collect the evidence
after it's all gone you know and they
didn't do that and i know that these uh
officers in this system are trained to
do that you know and so
you know i guess really the the short
answer to this is that you have to
use uh real experts and real facts uh
you know i don't think you should ignore
ex conspiracy theories but once you find
like two problems wrong with it you can
pretty much figure that it's a you know
it's not true
thank you
i just i just really wanted to add there
um
you know julie really does spend a lot
of time in the book
talking about all the work that goes
into this all the records we talked
about it during this conversation
um
there are theories and there is deep
reporting um that is backed up and then
lawyers review everything before this
published and you know julie and i
talked a lot about and it's very much in
the book how um many people don't
understand the process and and what
these stories go through
to even get published though yeah i i
one of the reasons why i really didn't
set out to write a book about journalism
or about me especially not me
but my editor kept saying
you know
like i would write something and she
would say well but how did you do that
i'm like i don't know i just did it well
you need to explain how you did that and
uh so
you know you don't think as a journalist
how you do something you kind of just do
it i guess all of you probably have
careers or jobs where if somebody right
now told you how do you do that explain
to me every detail you probably couldn't
do it right away you probably would
really have to think about it
and as i started thinking about it and
adding some of that in the book it
occurred to me that a lot of people
don't understand
you know the work that goes into
investigative journalism and and the
sacrifices that you really make you know
in time and in money and then
um you know so i thought in a way that
maybe it would be good to find to get
that in into the public eye so that they
understood
um you know just the struggle
um thank you so much for your uh work
with this spoken your courage and your
persistence i'm sure it took a lot of
that and you know um the conspiracy and
just this creature that was jeffrey
epstein and whether or not he took his
own life i i feel like a bigger story is
even the perversion of justice right and
i'm curious to know if there's any
way of taking it forward you know so
it's not just a slap slap on the hand
but policy change or what might happen
from here yeah that's a very good
question i'm glad you asked if because
that was the whole reason
really why i did this story because i
don't think
i didn't think that
that the coverage of this case
um did enough um
to explain
the broken system of justice we have in
this country and
i i i think i just was actually in an
interview right before this where where
i was asked a similar question and
my answer was i'm hopeful
that
you know the younger generation of
people in our system you know police
officers lawyers prosecutors fbi agents
understand how our system has been
broken for so long and work on fixing it
you know i'm hopeful that they're you
know that that a younger generation
um will do more now that we know we have
so much more information you know
cameras are out there everywhere we know
now about the the
the level of police brutality
particularly involving people who are of
color people who are poor we now know
that you know there was a long time ago
when i started in journalism that
whatever a police officer said you would
just take his gospel and you would write
it now we don't do that as much anymore
we know that it's not always
the way it happened so we'll go out and
we will now interview other witnesses
and we will get different stories so i
think that that has come because our
society is changing we're starting to
finally understand that um we need to do
you know we need to do a lot to fix our
criminal justice system
and make it fairer and make it more just
for everybody because these girls were
poor girls i mean one of them told me
you know the reason why jeffrey epstein
picked
somebody that he thought nobody would
listen to and he was right
he picked these girls because he felt
nobody would believe them
and you know that's part of what is
going on in our country and we have to i
hope you know that that it changes and
then our younger generation will you
know
look at things differently
can you talk about his surveillance
system how extensive it was
what
he had on it
and what you think happened to it
well he had uh cameras and practically i
mean he had a whole room in his new york
mansion of cameras and as i understand
it from people who were there
he had cameras almost in every room
and there's been an awful lot of
speculation about what would have
happened to that film now remember when
this crime first happened in 2005 2006
technology was not what it is today so
whatever kind of footage he probably had
from back then god knows what kind of
shape it was in i mean i've had quite a
few people come to me with uh here's
this i you know claiming that they had
jeffrey ep seen video footage and it's
so grainy that there's no way you could
tell who's in the who's in the footage
so you know we really don't know if he
if he really had any even if he was
taping people we don't know if the
footage is exists still or it's even
usable um so it's hard to know exactly
what kind of condition that stuff would
be in and certainly um if it existed the
fbi has it and
my feeling is if they did get anything
like that they're gonna bury it and it's
not going to come out
so uh oh we have time for one more
question one more question okay
um i've found in my reporting that
sometimes the line blurs between being a
journalist and almost a therapist to
your source and i can imagine that being
especially true
with these girls who'd been or these
women now who'd been so traumatized when
they were young and no one had ever
believed them
how did you win their trust how did you
approach them as subjects for this
reporting
well i did some homework beforehand
because i knew that this was going to
this had a good chance of
re-traumatizing them and i didn't want
to do that
i had a lot of experience interviewing
crime victims any i had even interviewed
rape victims before but these were
victims who had been abused when they
were very young
and so i
you know i interviewed um you know
people who work with those kinds of
trauma victims
uh to try to get a handle on how best to
approach it i think ultimately what
emily and i did was we just let them
talk
we didn't really
you know what happened next you know
tell me that tell me that we didn't have
to because once they started talking
it just spilled right out they had been
waiting
too long to tell that story and you know
i described the first victim who i got
teary about before and and
you know that interview was incredibly
i mean it was so emotional and powerful
and i just swallowed my pain you know
that you see me now i just like you
swallow it when you're you know you
don't you know show emotions you just
keep going and it wasn't until i got in
the car and she called me and thanked me
that i i did i cried i broke down you
know because i knew that
we had such a responsibility to tell
this story in in a respectful way i felt
a lot of pressure at that moment you
know and hoped
um
you know just hoped that i would do them
justice you know
julie i think it would be
really great if you just closed reading
from the preface
page
14.
[Music]
the jeffrey epstein story epitomizes our
nation's lopsided system of justice
and how victims of sexual assault
especially those who are young and poor
are discarded shamed and mistreated by
the very people who are supposed to
protect them
epstein got away with his crimes because
nearly every element of society allowed
him to get away with him
professional legal and moral ethics were
set aside for a broken system of values
that places corporate profits
personal wealth
political connections and celebrity
above some of the most sacred tenets of
our faiths our teachings and our
democracy
when i became a journalist i learned
that the most rewarding part of my work
was in writing injustices for those who
could not fight for themselves
few people seem to recognize that
epstein not only beat the system but he
was probably still hunting terrorizing
and abusing young women and girls
i would face many obstacles on my path
to the truth
i would be attacked by the legal forces
who failed their solemn oaths
by the defense attorneys who profited
off of death off of epstein's crimes and
by some of those within my own industry
who thought that what i was doing was
nothing more than a rehash
of an old story
in my lifetime there has never been a
more urgent need for journalism or a
more important time to play a role in
giving voice to those who have none
i believe that at this moment in history
when world events test our resilience
and when propaganda conspiracies and
lies threaten to undermine
all that our nation holds dear it will
be journalists who hold the corrupt and
powerful to account
as journalists we cannot put aside this
important mission even if we think the
story has already been told
because this was one story that wasn't
finished
so thank you julian karen and good night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and that wraps up our coverage of the
miami book fair you can watch all of
today's programs at any time by visiting
our website
booktv.org and clicking the book fairs
and festivals tab
weekends on c-span 2 are an intellectual
feast every saturday
madam president
the majority of it as consent the quorum
call be suspended without objection
madam president has been a great source
of debate over the past couple years
over a very basic question
how was jeffrey epstein able to take his
own life in federal prison on august 10
2019.
last week we found some answers in the
new york times it pointed out a series
of stunning failures within the bureau
prisons
according to the times i quote the newly
obtained records offer no support to the
explosion of conspiracy theories that mr
epstein's death was not a suicide
but
they do paint a picture of incompetence
and sloppiness
by within by someone within the bureau
prisons
that incompetence and sloppiness was
evident from the moment jeffrey epstein
entered the metropolitan correctional
center
on his intake sweeping screening form mr
epstein was described as quote a black
male
close quote with no prior record of sex
offense convictions
a five-second google search
would tell you that not only was jeffrey
epstein white
he was one of the most notorious sex
traffickers in recent history and what
about the night he died he'd already
attempted suicide in the weeks leading
up to his death so you would think that
the officials in the bureau prisons
would keep a close watch over this
potentially suicidal inmate in fact the
opposite happened
jeffrey epstein was left alone
unmonitored in his cell
the two officers on duty were allegedly
dozing off and scrolling on their phones
and the next morning epstein was found
dead with a bed sheet tied around his
neck
because of these failures the survivors
of epstein's despicable crimes
we'll never get to see him brought to
justice
six months after epstein died former
attorney general bill barr
hand-picked michael carvajal to lead the
bureau of prisons
it could have been a new beginning for
the bureau a chance to get to the bottom
of widely publicized neglected
mismanagement and to hold the
appropriate parties accountable
but that fresh start never came because
since day one director carvajal of
bureau of prisons has shown no intention
of reforming that institution
consider the case of the warden who ran
the metropolitan correctional center the
night jeffrey epstein died
how did director carvajal respond to
that warden's failure of leadership
well if you can imagine it he actually
rewarded him
director carvajal appointed the same
warden to lead a different facility the
largest federal prison in the united
states
fci fort dixon new jersey and it seems
that warden hasn't learned any lessons
in leadership since mr epstein's death
just last month an inmate in fci fort
dix was attacked from behind and stabbed
in the eye
these are not isolated incidents for
years the bureau of prisons has been
plagued by corruption
chronic understaffing and misconduct by
high-ranking officials and the nearly
two years since director carvajal took
control of the bureau he has failed to
address the mounting crises in our
nation's federal prison system it is far
past time for new reform-minded
leadership in the bureau of prisons
a few weeks ago the associated press
published a breathtaking investigation
into the bureau they concluded that it
is quote a hotbed of abuse graft and
corruption
and has turned a blind eye to employees
accused of misconduct
since 2019 madam president more than 100
federal prison workers have been
arrested for
charged with or convicted of crimes
including sexual abuse murder
and introducing contraband into prison
altogether these crimes account for
two-thirds of the criminal cases against
all department of justice personnel
even though bop employees comprise less
than a third of the workforce
i want to share a few of the stories
from the associated press report at one
federal prison in mississippi an
official responsible for investigating
the misconduct of other staff members
was arrested for his own misconduct he
was not only accused of stalking and
harassing his fellow employees
but he was allowed to remain in his
position
he was even authorized to continue
investigating one of his accusers
in california a warden of a federal
prison women's prison was arrested and
indicted earlier this year for molesting
an inmate
they even kept lewd photos of the victim
on his government-issued cell phone
he allegedly told the woman that she
shouldn't even try to report the assault
because he was quote close friends with
the official who would investigate it
the list goes on it's a recurring
pattern of misconduct by officials
within the bureau of prisons who believe
that they can abuse inmates and break
the law with impunities in some cases
that's exactly what they've done the
details in the ap investigation are
shocking
and for those of us who've been
following director carmel hall's tenure
they are the latest disturbing examples
of failed leadership time and again he
has categorically failed to uphold his
chief responsibility as director and
what is that responsibility protecting
the health and safety of inmates and
correctional officers
today the bureau suffers from chronic
and significant understaffing director
carvajal has failed to contain outbreaks
of covet 19 which has led to tens of
thousands of inmates and staff
contracting the virus and when it comes
to reforming our federal prison system
he's failed
in 2018 congressional democrats and
republicans came together on an
overwhelming bipartisan basis to enact
the first step act it was an historic
piece of reform legislation to create
new pathways for prison inmates to
better themselves while they serve their
time so they could return to society
once released nearly three years later
the bureau presence still hasn't
implemented most of these reforms one
example under the first step act
low-risk inmates are eligible to earn
time credits reducing their sentences
they do this by completing programs
designed to prevent them from committing
another crime
last month the inspector general at the
department found that bureau prisons has
not applied these earned time credits to
any of the approximately 60 000 eligible
inmates
now the senator district committee which
i chair is charged with overseeing the
bureau of prisons we've tried to get
answers from dr from director carvajal
and his team we've repeatedly requested
information we've asked for details
about the inmate banking system now
there's a heck of a story
purportedly has little oversight by the
bureau of prison has allowed inmates to
avoid paying child support restitution
to crime victims
other obligations the bureau reportedly
allowed larry nassar
the so-called doctor who abused hundreds
of young gymnasts before he was
sentenced to life in prison to spend
thousands of dollars from his bureau
presence account on himself but pay only
three hundred dollars toward the debt he
owes his victims
the bureau has delayed responding to our
questions or just flat out ignored him
it's past time to replace director
carvajal this can't wait any longer the
associated press's revelation shows us
that lives are literally at stake i know
attorney general garland understands the
urgency i'm calling on him today to move
immediately to dismiss director carvajal
and to bring real reform to direct to
the bureau of prisons madam president i
yield the floor
during the prosecution of former
colleague ted stevens
the inspector general was unable to
investigate the unethical
non-prosecution agreement with sex
offender jeffrey epstein
an absent approval by the attorney
general or his deputy the inspector
general cannot investigate professional
misconduct by high-ranking department of
justice political appointees
this lawyer loophole of all places is
unique to the justice department
the department of justice i want this
clear for the record is the only
only agency in the federal government
whose inspector general cannot
investigate professional misconduct by
agency lawyers
i hope that's clear
inspectors general investigate the
activity and conduct of lawyers in every
other federal agency other than
the department of justice
instead doj lawyers get special
treatment
they aren't subject to the investigation
of every other federal lawyer instead
they are under the supervision of the
department's office of professional
responsibility known as opr
now i don't dispute the skill or
dedication of opr
the problem is not their qualifications
it's their independence
listen to this
unlike the inspector general opr reports
to the attorney general who can control
and even terminate investigations
this doesn't happen in any other federal
agency
this creates an unfair double standard
where every doj employee is subject to
inspector general scrutiny so if you're
an fbi agent inspector general is going
to be watching your conduct to make sure
it's proper drug enforcement
administration agents in the department
of justice subject to the inspector
general u.s marshals
subject to the inspector general federal
prison guards inspector general
they can all be investigated by the
independent inspector general except for
the lawyers
and it enables the appearance if not
reality of politicization in cases where
the alleged misconduct involves
high-ranking department attorneys
for years
literally decades across administrations
other senators before us and senator lee
and myself now
have worked to close the lawyer loophole
with our inspector general access act
he advocated for this bill when bill
barr
was the attorney general of president
trump
i'm advocating for this bill when
merrick garland is the attorney general
of president biden
you'd be hard-pressed to find a bill
with broader based bipartisan support
our original co-sponsors included and
he's here today on the floor
my colleague senator grassley the
ranking member of department of justice
pardon me the judiciary committee
senator leahy feinstein rubio klobuchar
cruz coons blackburn
blumenthal and hirono to name a few
last year we considered this bill in the
judiciary committee and we dis we
reported it out of the committee
after a debate
and the vote was 21 to 1
to bring this bill to the floor
unfortunately it didn't pass last year
it passed the house
it passed again this year in the house
this broad support reflects a basic
principle
no attorney general from either
political party should be insulated from
independent scrutiny by the inspector
general and no attorney general should
have veto power over the inspector
general's authority to investigate
department of justice attorneys whether
that attorney general is a democrat or a
republican
mr president i'd like at this point to
yield to my colleague senator
lee the senator from utah is recognized
it's important to remember that
every agency within the federal
government
has an inspector general inspectors
general play an important role
in every agency and they're there for
the purpose
of independently reviewing
the actions of those who operate that
agency
everywhere you you look these inspectors
general serve with
independence and what we see from them
is work product that's publicly released
and can be digested by the public it's a
helpful resource not only for the
american people but also
to us personally as members of the
united states senate who in our capacity
as senators have the ability in fact the
duty of exercising oversight over
federal agencies
with respect to the u.s department of
justice a body that
really is all about law
and
has
a lot of lawyers to put it very mildly
you end up with a dichotomy a dichotomy
that can't be found anywhere else
in every other federal agency the
inspector general is able to do his or
her job to conduct research to do
evaluations issue public reports and
those reports allow us to exercise our
oversight responsibilities they also
allow the american people to know what's
going on in the agency in question
we've got a difference within the
department of justice if you're a lawyer
within the department of justice
you're covered
by the office of professional
responsibility
now
i want to point out a couple of
differences
within the office of professional
responsibility between opr as it's
called
and the office of inspector general
these don't reflect
any idea that one is bad and the other
one isn't they're just different
the office of professional
responsibility
does operate on a confidential basis it
operates
in secret and i don't use that term
denigratingly it's there to perform a
spiff specific highly specialized role
see
lawyers
uh have a separate set of ethical rules
and standards they are expected to abide
by the department of justice employing a
lot of lawyers wants to make sure that
there is some degree of consistency and
discipline within the practice of law
they want to make sure that
the the the relative interests of the
the privacy the professionalism of the
attorney
can be balanced with their other
investigative demands
but the inspector general has a
different function
inspector general isn't there
to evaluate whether or to what extent in
what way
any of the highly specialized sometimes
complex nuanced
rules of professional responsibility
affecting lawyers in the practice of law
are concerned no the inspector general
has a much different role so that's one
difference
is that one has a public facing role the
other one has a private facing role
affecting the individual attorney or
attorneys under investigation
secondly
and this one
is perhaps even more significant in its
impact
the inspector general
operates independently of the attorney
general the head of the office of
professional responsibility by contrast
reports directly to the attorney general
of the united states
and could be fired by the attorney
general of the united states this is a
big difference and it's a difference we
don't see replicated in any other
federal agency
not with lawyers not with any other uh
regulated professional class that i'm
aware of nor should we
because if we were to do that
we would end up creating problems
so this is not about a perceived
inadequacy or perceived cultural
corruption within the department of
justice created by the office of
professional responsibility that is is
not at all what i'm saying in fact i
i believe the people who operate the
department of justice the lawyers of the
department of justice
including those who operate the office
professional responsibility by and large
do their job to their job well and
faithfully
but insofar as we allow them to do their
job
in such a way that it precludes
any
ability
by the inspector general of the
department of justice to penetrate
section 8e of the inspector general act
insofar as it it insulates
the operations of
the u s department of justice
from investigation of the sort that
we've come to expect and rely on from
the office of inspector general
it's going to be a problem within the
department of justice in particular it's
a big problem i i think this would be
unwise in any federal agency for us to
say okay
the ig can do anything that the ig needs
to do unless there's a lawyer involved i
think it would be dangerous anywhere
because
you you do have lawyers involved but
it's especially dangerous the department
of justice
because so much of what they do is law
is necessarily performed by people who
are lawyers
what happens is that we see countless
dead ends
where because
the office of professional
responsibility has jurisdiction
the inspector general may not tread
they hit dead end after dead end
and in the absence of evidence of actual
criminal misconduct
they can't proceed nobody else can
penetrate it
it ought not take
evidence of
criminal
accountability of criminal liability
to enable the inspector general to do
his or her job there are myriad
circumstances where someone might engage
in unseemly unethical unwise
behavior within the department whether
they are lawyers or whether they are not
and separate and apart from whether
those deviate from the
professional standards imposed by the
state bar
of any state by the rules of any court
or the professional standards for
lawyers operating within the u.s
department of justice there is an
adequate independent free-standing
interest that the american people have
in being able to gain access to that
information but alas since 1988
section e
of the inspector general act has
precluded this visibility
this needs to stop
is my friend and colleague the senator
from illinois has stated uh so well
moments ago
this belt is not uh either republican or
democratic it's not liberal or
conservative
i i i have been a proud supporter of
this bill sponsored this bill during a
republican administration
because i believe that regardless of
who's in power we need visibility into
the department of justice visibility
that we have in every other federal
agency everyone
we lack it here
we like it here with respect to a whole
lot of what the department of justice
does because of this loophole in section
8e
what benefit does this bring to the
american people to the extent there are
benefits there
i respectfully submit they don't even
come close to offsetting
what we lose in terms of visibility we
need this we need it now
as much as ever
i implore my colleagues to support it
senator from illinois is recognized i
thank senator from utah for his
co-sponsorship of this bipartisan
measure
i i want to yield at this point to the
ranking republican member of the senate
judiciary committee i can't think of a
single member on either side of the
aisle who has been as outspoken as
senator grassley of iowa on the role and
the importance of inspectors general i
yield the floor to senator grassley
for
bringing some common sense to the
principles of checks and balances of
government
in this particular case it's not checks
and balances between the legislative
branch and the executive branch so much
as it is injecting another uh
level of checks
on
abusive authority within the executive
branch so i strongly support this act
and the bipartisan work of u-2 senators
to bring greater accountability to the
attorneys at the department of justice
congress created inspector generals to
be independent they don't just
investigate whatever their agency or
congress might want them to do
the law says that inspectors general
shine a light on waste fraud and abuse
in federal agencies sometimes
transparency is very uncomfortable but
it's extremely necessary you're not
going to get real accountability if you
have an agency's employees policing
themselves right now the only folks who
can investigate the justice department
attorneys or other justice department
attorneys
this system erodes public trust
and creates clear conflict of interest
for example the justice department
attorneys reviewed the plea agreement
given to serial
child sex offender jeffrey epstein i
note that many of my colleagues here
found that internal review
substantial substance substantively
inadequate
those are words from my colleagues
had the inspector general conducted the
review he might have gotten somewheres
with it just like he did with the
behavior fbi agents in the larry nassar
case
what if
we had left the investigation
to the fbi to police itself
this is why the justice department
inspector general
has identified
as the agency's number one top
management challenge
quote strengthening public trust in the
justice department
one way to fix that
is to make sure
the independent inspector general
has the same authority over all
department employees
why do fbi analysts nda agents
require more independent scrutiny than
departments attorneys
this is so simply
or so simple that even a lawyer could
get this
i heard rumors that my friend senator
cotton may be objecting to this
a person i agree with 90 percent of the
time it seems to be very
uncharacteristic he and i believe alike
that there's two ways of doing business
in the united states
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness or let the bureaucrats run
everything and i know senator cotton is
a person that doesn't think bureaucrats
should run everything and in this case
nothing's reviewable by people that make
a decision not to produce this that's
the height of irresponsibility are you
president
i thank the senator from iowa for his uh
spirited support of this effort and if
biden could get all the democrats
he'd
he'd get it he'd get it through
let's get to calls trent in monroe
louisiana independent
hi guys listen um
i'm 65 years old
jim wallace has been in my life since i
was a teenager
oz guinness i bet you know oz right
i do yeah and i know jim too yeah
just one of the most brilliant
sociologists philosophers in the world
evangelical i've spent a couple of times
dinners with him and
i think you'll vouch for what i'm about
to say that i'm not a liar and then i
was a friend of gary norris for a long
time he was probably the most systematic
thinker on the hard right
and i remember talking to gary one time
about the fact that um
the guy who wrote
the
the end times novels i forgot his name
all of a sudden but he'd said that you
know he thought there was 4 000 people
who ran the world and gary looked up at
me from his computers and now it's a lot
less than that
so here's my here's my story
i'm
i'm 50 years old i'm grinding away in
the middle class and then i marry into
flannery o'connor's family and suddenly
i'm through the looking glass and i'm in
the world of some of the ruling class
managerial elite and i was talking to my
wife one day when the jeffrey epstein
thing hit and she said oh i know jeffrey
and i said yeah i'm going to look at
talk to the doctor about your medication
well she said we were we were friends
for a long time she said
we would talk every day about culture
and art and she said until i started
talking to him about the life death
resurrection and
ascension of jesus and then that kind of
turned him off and and the relationship
with him well another family member
spent a lot of time with jeffrey flying
all over the world
and what i came out of those stories
thinking was that you know stanley
kubrick's last film eyes wide shut
and martin sheen made a film even before
that called the believers that talked
about how the ruling class
is involved in some really black warped
occultism
and so we're talking you know 150 000
feet but you know that the christian
right is concerned about conspiracies
and i don't see you guys in the the
think tanks
really talking about this stuff another
friend in the family
i'm going to leave it there peter wayne
do you have any reaction to that
yeah i mean i can't speak to to
obviously some of his own personal
stories about jeffrey epstein i mean
just i i have no idea of the context but
let me make a general point i mean other
than jeffrey epstein was
engaged
in in wicked acts um but yeah more more
generally about the ruling class and the
conspiracy theories i mean every society
has a ruling class i mean that's just
the nature of
of life in this world the question is is
the ruling class particularly malicious
malevolent evil
or tied up in conspiracy knots
um i would say on on the pattern of
conspiracy uh theories the the danger is
not
the fact that we're uh that the right or
anybody else is ignoring conspiracy
theories it's very much the opposite i
would say that we've just had a
president
in donald trump
and now his supporters and many people
in congress republicans in congress who
have been spinning conspiracy theories
that are made up whole cloth which are
very dangerous
the most i would say uh malicious of
which is that the election was stolen
which it clearly was was not and that
donald trump is the right player i mean
this is a guy who fanned the flames of
an insurrection violent assault on the
capital less than a year ago in an
effort to overturn a free election and
yet those people have
weaved together conspiracy theories
um which which has turned this whole
thing on its head so when it comes to
and that's not the only conspiracy
theory i think they're good conspiracy
theories about uh about covet and the
vax vaccines
which um which have been shown to to to
be well it's basically a medical miracle
and if they're conspiracy theories about
that the anti-vaxx movement so that's my
perspective on conspiracy theories in
general i mean of course one has to be
alert to those things conspiracies do
exist
but uh but right now uh you know c.s
lewis once said that
when you're in the midst of a flood you
don't reach for a fire extinguisher and
i think saying that we're not focused
enough on the conspiracy theories that
exist is reaching for a fire
extinguisher when the flood is
are the conspiracy theories that are
naughty frankly
jeffrey in auburn new york democratic
caller
good morning um merry christmas merry
christmas uh
i'd like to preface my my um
all others it's 202
748 8001. go ahead and start calling in
and of course having this conversation
in the wake of another high profile jury
trial we saw yesterday the british
socialite galen maxwell convicted of
luring teenage girls to be sexually
abused by american millionaire jeffrey
epstein
the washington the usa today wrap up
noting the verdict captain month long
trial featuring sordid accounts of the
sexual exploitation of girls as young as
14 told by four women who described
being abused as teens in the 1990s and
early 2000s at epstein's homes in
florida and new york and new mexico
jurors deliberated deliberating for five
full days before before finding maxwell
guilty of five of the six accounts
and that was just the latest high
profile jury trial of the year 2021 a
reminder of some of the others it was
back in april that officer former
officer derek chovin was found guilty in
george floyd's murder
what is the solution that's the problem
the solution is what the woodson center
is doing first of all we must give voice
to the people in our in
that are suffering the problem for
instance whenever you generalize about a
group
all women all blacks and then you try to
apply remedies it only helps those in uh
that are elites
for instance we talked about
women
jeffrey epstein about the terrible abuse
of those women
five years ago six years ago jevaldo
rivero did a two-hour documentary
on the plight of
black women in prison being raped
regularly by their guards it was a
two-hour documentary
the private mo all of the victims were
black and all of the victimizers were
black guards and and officials yet it
did not provoke any outcry
there were no demands for justice for
these poor women
because it did not the fit the racial
narrative
and so but here's so i i mean not the
bushes and the clintons i'm sorry sir
the bushes and the clintons it's like
you can see how the swamp or the steep
state if you're not on jeffrey epstein's
guest list either the powers that be
won't uh they didn't like the
unsettlement of the presidency it didn't
seem to have unsettled so we're looking
at an issue that's relevant to the real
problem the real problem is these
entrenched government officials that
have been there for 50 years like they
say it's like uh it's godzilla versus
mothra but it's really the same beast
it's a two-headed monster is there
anything in this monster of big
government is is destroying the little
working-class guy and we can't afford
this this this high-end living for the
clintons and the bushes you know is
there anybody in this government right
now
they've come back with a big on their
face big tech has now aligned itself you
know
and and we're in trouble with this
election process all right that's
anthony p and insisting of their
staffing uh capabilities to be staffed
up the death of jeffrey epstein was in
blp
custody almost two and a half years ago
was attributed in part to staffing
shortage i look forward to the pending
report from the inspector general on the
circumstances surrounding his death i
expect that the report will include
recommendations to make all efforts to
staff up throughout the bureau
it is my hope that this hearing
uh that we will take additional steps to
ensure blp carries out its mission to
confine offenders in prison and
community-based facilities that are safe
here since depending on the dosage and
the package size if you want to read
more of that the wall street journal is
where you'll find that story we'll go to
tommy in kentucky democrat slide
yes
i would like to question why the
jeffrey epstein maybe uh hasn't been put
more in the news
and i wonder about
all these uh politicians that's backing
trump
uh if you check matt getz
jim jordan
a few others you'll see that
they have been some kind of sex scandal
their self with underage uh people
and i wonder why that is important more
okay diane from mechanicsbuilt
mechanicsburg pennsylvania republican
line good morning
good morning pedro
critters giving you a front row seat to
democracy
and now oversight of federal prisons the
director of the federal bureau of
prisons testifies before a house
judiciary subcommittee on the bureau's
response to the pandemic vaccine
mandates for prison employees and other
topics this is about two hours
the subcommittee will now come to order
without objection the chairs authorized
to declare recesses of the committee at
any time good morning again and welcome
to dave's oversight hearing of the
federal bureau of prisons i'd like to
remind members that we have established
an email address
and distribution list to circulate
exhibits motions or other written
materials that members might want to
offer as part of our hearing today
if you would like to submit materials
please send them to the email address
that has been previously distributed to
your offices and we will circulate the
materials to members and staff as
quickly as we can i would also ask all
members to please make your microphones
to mute your microphones when you're not
speaking this will help prevent feedback
and other technical issues
you may unmute yourself anytime you seek
recognition i now recognize myself for
an opening statement today's hearing on
oversight of the federal bureau of
prisons is a follow-up to the hearing
the subcommittee held on january 21st
2022
and it was our commitment to our members
uh that they would have
uh the actual representative at this
time
of the federal bureau of prisons to be
able to
hear directly from the leadership
uh and to uh secure answers
the hearing last week proved the
bureau's implementation the first step
act the impact of covert 19 on vop the
bureau's response to the pandemic and
the implementation and use of
compassionate relief within the bureau
among other topics very crucial topics
in the
line of justice and accountability
during that hearing many questions were
raised and many of our members thought
it best to speak directly to the
director of the op therefore i'm pleased
to have director michael caraval
here today so that we may delve deeply
into many issues faced uh by the bureau
two years into the pandemic covet 19
remains the most pressing and impactful
issue facing the bureau of prisons as
the virus continues to wreak havoc among
many of the girls facilities and i'm
uncomfortable as to whether or not they
have met the challenge and met the task
from the outset the viruses had
excavated the increased health risk for
people living or working in confined
spaces which is especially true for
prison system where social discipline
must be balanced with the need to ensure
safety and security we continue to hear
horror stories of blp facilities
struggling to contain the virus for
instance we heard
last week from senator chris murphy that
approximately 40 percent of inmates at
the danbury federal correction
institution connecticut were in either
isolation or quarantined with only 80
correction officers available for
service which means that every officer
on duty is responsible for three prison
units we in the congress must
collaborate uh to ensure that the
remnants of the past
can be corrected by this administration
that has a new approach new commitment
to the reformation of this system
then on monday we learned that federal
medical center cardwell the women's
facility in fort worth in texas my state
has the fourth highest covet positive
numbers of any bureau facility in the
country with 248 inmates and 46 members
who are covet positive eight women have
died of covet 19 at fmc carswell since
the beginning of the pandemic while 18
inmates have uh died of covet at fort
worth mail facility in the past two
weeks the number of covet 19 positives
in the blp system has fluctuated between
6 000 and 9 000 inmates in that same
two-week period five more inmates in bop
custody have died of covet 19 bringing
the number of inmates to die of covet 19
related illnesses to 284. it appears
that there are just too many inmates in
the viewer's custody to control
successfully reduce the spread of kovac
19
and
uh it
uh appears uh that there has been a slow
and ineffective utilization of
compassionate release which should be uh
complied with with discretion that the
bureau has the prison says several
mechanisms within the authority to
reduce the number of inmates in its
custody compassionate relief the cares
act
and the first step back modified even by
then attorney general barr although
using overly restrictive criteria blp
released thousands of prisoners under
the cares act who have reestablished
themselves their families and in their
communities and importantly have not
reoffended
the bureau and doj should be commended
for their decision to rescind the
previous administration's opinion that
would have called many of these
individuals back into custody
unnecessarily i think it's important to
note that these individuals that had
been released were more released on
their application for compass relief as
opposed to the blp assessing their
prisoners and determining that they
could be released which causes the
problems that we have now however as the
thousands of prisoners continue to test
positive for cover 19 and others die bop
has failed to effectively utilize its
authority to request compass release for
inmates i think they're just waiting
some may die from january 1st 2020 to
january 30 2021 during the height of the
pandemic the bureau of prisons filed
less than one percent of the total
compassion relief motions filed
throughout the entire country in an
attempt to respond to this issue and to
help alleviate the rise of spreading uh
covet we expanded compassionate religion
and later expanded the past release
again to allow inmates to file their own
motions 30 days after they first made a
request with their warden
notably as few as one quarter of the 284
inmates who died in custody of
covet-related illnesses actually filed a
motion for compassionate relief raising
questions about the efficiency efficacy
of the process
one is jeff
uh
one is left to wonder how justice was
served by the process for the 62 inmates
to file for competitive release
themselves or through council and those
pre-existing medic and whose
pre-witnessing pre-existing medical
conditions were cited by the bureau
after they died of covet-related illness
while in custody why couldn't there be a
response the bureau not only grapples
with inmate infections and death but
also with staff
uh member infections and death in the
last two weeks the number of covet 19
positive staff members have reigned from
900 to almost 2 000 and seven staff
members have died of covet-related
illnesses while staffing shortages have
long been a problem for the bureau of
prisons has made a bad situation even
worse statistics do not build well for
the state of operations for bureau
facilities across the country as staff
members become infected or are required
to quarantine due to exposure code 19
directly affects the remaining staff's
ability provides safety security general
and covet related medical services and
recidivism reducing programming to
inmates i do want to take this moment as
i conclude my remarks uh to be able to
uh
uh
give appreciation to the corrections
officers and staff
that operate with compassion hopefully
sensitivity uh and strength as they work
every single day
98 facilities remain at level three of
the modified operational levels which
include social distancing in all areas
of bureau facilities
but as of monday all federal prisons are
under a national lockdown for two
inmates died during a fight involving
multiple inmates of u.s penitentiary
beaumont
including those in gangs although
details are not forthcoming due to the
ongoing fbi investigation this incident
raises concern about the safety and
security facility particularly in my
backyard beaumont which has been
compromised by long-standing staffing
shortages the consequences of staffing
georgia and blp have been witnessed time
and time again the death of jeffrey
epstein was linked in part to the hours
of overtime that officers guarding him
were required to work and augmentation
which required an employee was not a
corrections officer to guard him i went
to that facility i saw the need the
freezing coal uh and the needs of those
employees that were there they begged
for help and did not get it epstein's
death precipitated the closing of the
metropolitan corrections office our
chairman has worked very hard on this
issue and so i hope as we go forward
that we will listen to
the issues we know that some issues are
being investigated by the oig
we understand that
the conditions in many of the prisons
are not what they should be
we know that the patent risk assessment
tool which is at the core of the
implementation the first step act and
other uh patents other programs uh has
not been effectively utilized we hope to
answer that question on the pattern uh
program uh that indicates that the
national institutes of justice
identified errors in pattern version one
um
that i understand are being addressed to
revise the version of uh pattern if
inmates are assessed under the current
version of the two
were disadvantaged by those errors they
must be reassessed under the new version
prison is a place of accountability and
punishment but it should also be a place
of redemption restoration
service and certainly a place that is
decent for staff to work at
and so i look forward to this discussion
with our director uh and i look forward
to continuing uh to try and restore the
federal prison bureau in the way that it
should uh perform without objection i
will submit into the record the
following documents written testimony
submitted by allison k
uh guernsey for the january 23 2022
summit committee uh hearing entitled the
first step act the pandemic and
compassionate relief what are the next
steps for the federal bureau of prison
letter from allison k gurney dated
february 1 22 2022 and two accompanying
attachments written statements submitted
by dr homer ventures for the january
21st 2022 subcommittee hearing uh the
first step the pandemic compassionate
relief what are the next steps for the
federal bureau of prisons
i now recognize the distinguished
member from arizona the ranking member
for his opening statement thank you and
welcome mr bates
thank you madam chair and i first thank
you madam chair for holding this hearing
and i also thank you for um bringing in
director of prisons uh director carvajal
because i think
that that uh your swift's response to
many of us who requested that his
presence be here and i i appreciate your
response to that madam chair and it's uh
we're grateful for that
and i welcome director carvajal as well
thank you for your service sir we're
glad to have you here today the federal
bureau of prisons is tasked with
protecting society by by confining
offenders in the controlled environments
of prisons and community-based
facilities bop's duty is not merely to
provide housing food and security for
federal inmates but also to help inmates
become law-abiding citizens upon release
all americans have an interest in bops
mission because the vast majority of
federal inmates well above 90 percent
will someday be released into our
communities
regardless of our efforts to reduce
recidivism
the eop's job is not an easy task
and it has only become more complicated
due to covet 19.
in response to covet 19 bop undertook a
number of steps to safeguard the health
safety
of inmates
bureau of prison staff and the public
bop prioritized inmates from home
confinement who did not pose a
significant risk to the public
restricted the number of visitors and
limited the movement of inmates among
detention facilities
these are reasonable measures but my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle want to go even further they've
tried to use covet 19 as a reason to let
more convicted criminals back onto our
streets they even wrote attorney general
william barr urging him to quote use
every tool at his disposal to release as
many prisoners as possible close quote
they even passed legislation in the
house that would pay states to release
inmates in state prisons and local jails
think about that
my colleagues across the aisle want to
use our tax dollars to incentivize
stations to put more convicted criminals
on the streets
earlier
the consequence of these actions have
deadly real world results as we have
unfortunately seen
in march of 2021 eric reinbold was
released from bop custody after being
granted compassionate release based on
covet vulnerability
by july just four months later reinbold
was accused and charged with murdering
his wife
and just a few weeks ago in oregon
clifford up the grove was charged with
first degree robbery first degree theft
and fellaini felony fleeing and unlawful
use of a weapon
up to grove had been granted
compassionate release for covet related
reasons
the previous year
in spite of these and numerous crimes
that have been committed by inmates
released early
my colleagues across the aisle are
calling for more inmates to be released
regardless of their crime or prison
sentence
democrats on this committee want to open
the jails and defund the police they're
turning a public health crisis into
public safety crisis as well
i
i tell you director carvajal to please
pass on our appreciation to our to your
officers
and employees they have a tough job
and i want them to know they have our
support
to that end i understand that many bop
officers have voiced concern over the
biden vaccine mandate
i strongly oppose any efforts to mandate
covet 19 vaccines and have introduced
legislation to prevent federal agencies
from imposing coven 19 vaccine mandates
i look forward to hearing from director
carvajal today
and i also request that madam chair that
that we soon have the dc director of the
us marshal's office in for a hearing as
well
um i think some of the evidence that
came out of last week's hearing would do
well for both sides of the aisle to hear
from the marshall's office and i
appreciate that uh you again bringing in
director carvajal it's good to have him
here and i thank you madam chair and i
yield back the balance of my time
i thank the ranking member for his uh
statement
i acknowledge at this time the service
of our chairman
in the service of our ranking member uh
mr jordan and thank them for their
leadership of this committee
it is now my pleasure to introduce uh
today's uh witnesses
or witness uh and that is uh michael
carvajal
uh who is the director of the federal
bureau of prisons he began his career
with the bureau of prisons in 1992 as a
correctional officer at the federal
correctional institute three rivers
texas
uh he is in essence uh a committed uh
dedicated servant to the federal bureau
of prisons he served in position of
leadership in texas kansas louisiana uh
before coming or becoming the regional
director of northeast region in
2016
mr carvajal became the assistant
director for the correctional programs
division in 2018 and held that position
until he was appointed
director in 2020 in the last
administration
uh let me again um take note of his
service and as well the many corrections
officers that i've had
and staff uh the privilege of meeting uh
throughout the system as i indicated our
task here is to provide a reform and
restoration and
uh
continued improvement
on the institution of the federal bill
of prisons we welcome you mr
carvajal director carver hall
and
we thank you
for your participation i'll begin by
swearing in eyewitness i ask our witness
to turn on your audio
and make sure that i can see your face
and raise uh your right hand
while i administer the oath
do you swear or firm under penalty of
perjury that the testimony you're about
to give is true and correct to the best
of your knowledge information and belief
so help you god
yes i do
thank you let the records show the
witness answered in the affirmative
thank you
uh please note that your written
statement will be entered into the
record in its entirety accordingly i ask
that you summarize your testimony
in five minutes to help you stay within
the time frame there is a timing light
on your screen
uh when the light switches from green to
yellow you have one minute to conclude
your testimony when the light turns red
it signals that your five minutes have
expired i now recognize director
carvajal for five minutes thank you
you're recognized
thank you and good morning chairwoman
jackson lee and ranking member biggs
other distinguished members of the
committee it's my honor to speak today
on behalf of the 37 000 bureau prisons
correction professionals who work day in
and day out to support our critical law
enforcement mission
the bureau's work is incredibly
challenging and has been exacerbated by
the covet 19 virus our management of the
pandemic has been highly scrutinized
despite the fact that we have worked in
lockstep with the cdc in shaping the
guidance for the benefit of everyone who
works in a correctional environment
the bureau is one of the first federal
agencies to offer covet testing and
vaccinations
and in january 2021 the cdc recognized
the bureau for leading all jurisdictions
and federal entities and its rate of
vaccination utilization approximately 80
percent of our staff and 70 percent of
our inmates have been fully vaccinated
and we continue to increase those rates
after issuance of the cares act the
bureau began screening and transferring
vulnerable and eligible inmates to
residential re-entry centers and home
confinement
the bureau has transferred more than 37
000 inmates to community custody with
more than 9 000 of those transferred
pursuant to the cares act
after review of medically vulnerable
inmates for potential placement and home
confinement continues
based on assessments and the balance
with our law enforcement mission
another common criticism is that we are
under staff the narrative is routinely
misrepresented without reference to
factual data we have approximately
eleven hundred correctional officer
vacancies however seven institutions out
of the 121 make up almost 40 of these
vacancies
increasing and maintaining our staffing
levels within appropriated funding
levels is remains our priority
last calendar year we hired over 3 000
staff and at one point advance hired 1
000 staff above our funding levels we
have proven that we can hire employees
and although hiring is not an issue at
the majority of our locations we are
routinely outbid by competing state and
local corrections or law enforcement
agencies who pay a higher wage
accordingly we continue to work with the
department to consider the use of
additional incentives so that we may be
more competitive
another area of misguided criticism is
the implementation of the first step act
the bureau worked with the department on
the development of the risk and needs
assessment system and supported the
national institute of justice who
developed the approved risk assessment
tool called pattern
staff were trained on the first step act
including the new pattern tool and we
worked with the union to negotiate
policies to support implementation of
the law
we recomputed the sentences of over 150
000 inmates to ensure that they received
good conduct time under the new law
we are delivering more than 80 different
programs based on individual inmate
assessments we hired additional staff to
expand our re-entry programs and we
initiated additional activities to
support inmates who have mental health
issues disabilities or other special
needs
we've expanded programming for female
inmates drug treatment and vocational
training
over 75 000 inmates participated in
first step act programs by the end of
2021 in spite of the constraints caused
by the pandemic we are modernizing the
inmate education platform to include the
use of tablets for better program
accessibility and we've created an
online system to directly connect the
community volunteers to blp facilities
additionally we're exploring ways to
provide inmates with id cards compatible
with state requirements under the real
id act
we engaged external experts to evaluate
our inmate programs and we're working
with nij to engage academic consultants
to review our risk and needs assessment
system
we're also developing a stronger data
analytics platform to enhance monitoring
and evaluation of our programs and our
spending
the blp worked in concert with the
department to finalize the re
the rule regarding first step back time
credits we applied the rule
retroactively and immediately released
almost 4 000 inmates from home
confinement and rrcs
we are releasing approximately 1 600
inmates from blp facilities and
transferring nearly 2 500 inmates into
pre-release custody in some over 8 000
inmates have had their time credits
applied towards pre-release custody or
supervised release
the bureau supports and has always been
complete committed to the implementation
of the first step act and we are
statutorily compliant
last year the governmental
accountability office reported
highlighted areas where the bureau
needed to improve and in response i
established a task force to address
these identified areas
as a result of the task force's work
eight of the priority recommendations
identified are now closed
our work in this area continues
chairwoman jackson lee ranking member
biggs and other distinguished members of
the committee this concludes my
statement
madam chair i think you are still on
mute
because my
very delicate fingers i press it and it
doesn't seem to want to open up so let
me uh let me try to hit it real hard
um
let me
do something a little different uh if i
might
um and i'm not sure is miss bass here on
yes yes i'm here spanish i'm going to
yield to you for beginning
at this time and and i will i'll follow
thank you very much miss bash is
recognized for five minutes
thank you very much uh madam chair
uh good morning director carvajal i'm
glad to have you here before the
committee today and um i'm sure you are
aware that two weeks ago the
subcommittee held a hearing on matters
pertaining to the bureau of prisons the
first step act and the covenant covert
epidemic i was glad to hear from several
experts on these topics but i'm afraid
i'm still left with a few questions
questions that i believe you might be
the one to answer and let me just take a
minute to uh thank you for your service
to blp and then also to acknowledge uh
your quick responsiveness uh on several
occasions when i reached out with
particular uh specific situations
um one of the ways the cares act
attempted to address the covet epidemic
within our prison system was by
providing
the bop with additional authority to
grant compassionate release for
incarcerated persons who met a number of
criteria to demonstrate a low risk of
reoffense as opposed to the way it was
described a few minutes ago
democrats asking for the prison doors to
just be opened up indiscriminately can
you tell me how many people within the
bop have been granted early release
under this program
and i wanted to know
for those people that were granted
how many reoffend it
i know there have been
individual cases but i want to know if
you have any numbers overall
are percentages of how many people were
reincarcerated due to a technical
violation such as missing a cur a curfew
or a phone call
or how many people were released and are
unaccounted for
how many people offended again with
violent crimes
okay uh thank you congresswoman bass and
i appreciate the opportunity to uh to
make some distinctions here i think that
there is uh often confusion i'm going to
try to clarify what is going on here
first off as i stated in my opening
remarks we released over or transferred
over 37 000 under the cares act to home
confinement and committee placement
compassionate release is a separate
entity the bop does not hold the
authority to independently raise someone
from our custody under the statute and
our current policy we make a
recommendation to the court the court
makes the final decision not the bureau
of prisons the bureau of prisons doesn't
take a position on the motion and of
itself and as you stated there is
criteria we use our policy criteria to
evaluate and ensure that each individual
case
is as compelling as an extraordinary
compelling circumstances that they're
fully considered these are
individualized cases we also take into
account public safety and victim impact
but i stress that we do not
independently do that
and the court makes a final decision uh
we do not track uh data i don't have it
in front of me for compassionate release
because when when the inmate receives a
reduction in sentence they are no longer
in our custody
i can answer the other part of your
question of the 37 000 that we
transferred to home confinement in the
community approximately 9 000 of those
were specific to the cares act
320 approximately 320 that i'm aware of
had have committed violations have been
brought back to secure custody eight of
those were new crimes that i'm aware of
one uh one was a serious crime i don't
have the details in front of me i'm sure
we could get them for you
so you said again
320 could you repeat that again
yes 320
of the inmates under karzak home
confinement have reoffended and been
brought back to secure custody and so
you don't know of those 320 how many
were technical violations that brought
them back you said eight committed new
crimes could i assume that the rest were
technicals or not yeah i i can clarify
that i appreciate that uh congresswoman
bass most of the the most common offense
about 160 of those 320 were for abuse of
alcohol or drugs uh some of them were
escaped they weren't they weren't where
they were supposed to be most of them
were violations of that nature some was
misconduct eight of those were new
crimes committed the rest were technical
violations
and can you talk about uh in my
remaining seconds vaccine distribution a
one among staff
how many staff have been vaccinated and
also inmates sure our staff we have
approximately 80 of our staff which is
about 30 000 staff that are fully
vaccinated we have about 95 000 inmates
93 to 95 000 inmates it's a moving
target changes constantly that's about
70 percent of our population we continue
to offer the vaccine and the booster to
all inmates and of course
people can change their mind at any time
if they choose to come back and get it
we make the vaccine available and for
the 20 of the staff that are not
vaccinated what protocols do you have in
place do they have to get tested weekly
or what what's in place yes prior to the
mandate we were offering uh weekly
testing uh it was it was voluntary
obviously when the mandate came out we
mandated weekly testing for unvaccinated
uh
there was a
preliminary injunction issued in january
by a judge we're observing that we
ceased enforcement of the vaccine
mandate
and all processes with it but we
continue to encourage staff and inmates
to become vaccinated and as a study
that's a moving target but we average
about 80 percent staff 70 inmates
thank you my time is expired
fingers are now working uh ranking
member biggs and it is uh my pleasure to
yield to you your five minutes for
uh your uh questioning of the director
thank you very much
uh thank you madam chair director carver
hall again thanks for being here today
a federal court issued an injunction to
block implementation of president
biden's vaccine mandate for federal
employees were any bop employees fired
for not receiving the vaccine prior to
the injunction being issued
congressman i don't have the the uh the
exact numbers off my head but we can
certainly follow up and get that
information back to you
so director are you saying that yes
you believe some were fired but you
don't have the exact number i do believe
some were a congressman but i do not
have that information uh in front of me
and i can certainly get it back to you
thank you and will you know if those
those employees will be rehired
congressman again uh i'll i'll consult
with my uh human resource uh directors
there's processes so we're observing the
processes uh and they do have due
process so we can get back to you with
that exact information thank you very
much
other federal agencies are creating
databases to attract employees who
request religious exemptions to
president biden's vaccine mandate for
federal employees has the bop created a
database to track religious exemption
requests
uh again congressman with with the
mandate we were exploring and reviewing
and approving as necessary religious and
medical uh exemptions we have ceased
that process uh because of the
preliminary injunction and we're
following the guidance given to us okay
so i just want to make sure i understand
this
i'm sorry i didn't mean to interrupt i
just want to make sure i understand this
so you you were constructing a database
and you're not now is that what i
understood
that's what i understood so yes
congressman we obviously we track it we
have a process to to keep track of the
information uh so yes there is a
database uh along with everything else
we do it's tracked for accountability
purposes so that we know what status is
and things of that nature we've ceased
enforcement of that okay
i appreciate ms bass's line of
questioning because i i have a lot of
the similar type questions so
uh in my opening statement i mentioned a
couple of examples of individuals
released from bop custody because of
covet 19 and they committed serious
crimes afterwards is is
blp tracking recidivism rates to see if
individuals who have been released
because of covet 19 have committed
crimes
after their
release well congressman uh the the
recidivism data that we use our
recidivism our recidivism rate for the
bureau of prisons is 43 the states
actually own the recidivism days of data
we work with them uh i don't know
that enough time is the last since we've
since the passage of the cares act but i
would have to ask specific questions
about that but again
there is a difference between someone we
release in tracking them uh and someone
who's still in our custody and home
confinement
so
so i i understand um that the court
makes the final determination on a
compassionate release
petition
and are you tracking
those who had been released on
compassionate release at all for
recidivism rates
congressman i don't want to misspeak
again when we release someone from our
custody we do not the bureau of prisons
does not track them they're released
from our custody they're returning
citizens uh the state again owns the
recidivism data we work with them and
other uh other entities to get that but
i can have my staff get back with you
i'm not a i obviously don't know the
exact procedures but we can get that
information for you
so okay i appreciate that and so and i
wish you would and and uh reach out to
my staff um and but and in particular
for instance i want to make sure i
understand this so in arizona if if
if someone is given a compassionate
release you guys don't track it but the
arizona uh law enforcement department
questions maybe the department of public
safety somebody's tracking it and gives
you data is that is that your
understanding
yes congressman it's a collaboration of
of uh us working with the state and
other law enforcement entities there's
there's a lot of moving parts there
again way above my head but yes that
data is obviously being tracked
yeah and i i guess i've been asking
about compassionate release and i assume
the first step back
uh
same thing on the recidivism issue
yes uh obviously there's interest in in
you know our first step back data and
we're working with nij and outside
consultants to review data and things
like that we're working on a platform
i know one of the criticisms early on is
that we didn't have that data again
there's a lot of moving parts it isn't
because we don't want to track it
there's there's a lot of entities here
we have to collaborate with other local
state and federal law enforcement
agencies to appropriately do that
well director i hope that that we can
get that information
sooner rather than later and
whatever we can do to help facilitate
that please let me know and i'll have my
office reach out to you and if you have
yours reach out to mine i think this
information is critical because i think
everybody wants to understand that uh
thanks again for being here madam chair
my i my time has expired i yield back
i i thank uh the chairman uh the ranking
member uh very much and um i will now
yield myself the customary five minutes
uh my time is short uh mr
uh karbal
and um
uh carl hall thank you so very much and
so i appreciate your your respect of
that uh following the deaths of two
inmates in the u.s penitentiary in
beaumont texas on monday all blp
facilities have had a lockdown can you
explain the decision to institute
uh the lockdown the national lockdown
and how long it makes confined to their
cells
during the 24-hour period if you can
just give a brief answer on that we'll
take a longer one
in writing
director
yes congresswoman
decision to lock down the entire agency
is a serious one we did it because we
felt we needed to to find out what's
going on i won't get into specific
operational things but the groups
involved there's approximately 2500 in
our custody spread throughout the agency
we need to make sure that we uh separate
them and and secure them i'm hoping that
the lockdown will be short-lived we do
not like keeping inmates again in their
cells and we will do our best to get
them out as quickly but keeping safety
of everyone in mind thank you if you
would give this committee an update on
the moment that the lockdown stops we
would appreciate it for all of the
members following up beaumont lowe um in
texas a low security facility currently
has 10 infected inmates 942 inmates who
recovered from covet that seems very
high out of 1 974 total inmates
including the camp and the correctional
institution which includes low um uh low
um offense individuals that is almost
half of the inmate population that has
been infected with covet 19 20 staff are
coveted positive right now and 40 have
recovered how many inmates were placed
into home confinement from fci beaumont
low how many inmates were released under
compass relief from fci beaumont low are
older inmates at low security facilities
such as fci beaumont low given priority
to be assessed for release under the
cares act compassionate relief or first
step act if so what age inmates are
given priority if not by age are any
inmates at fci beaumont low given
priority to be assessed for release you
can ask answer the um the last uh
question first please
director
yes congresswoman i don't have the exact
data for every specific institution that
beaumont low we can certainly get you
that data i know we have it i just don't
have it
thank you do you use the cares act uh is
that ongoing
uh to be utilized uh to date since it is
still um operable in law do you use that
absolutely we continue to screen inmates
for appropriate placement of cares act
uh and under the cares act uh with your
discretion uh individuals do not have to
meet the 50
um
time of their sentence is that correct
that is one of the criteria along with
others is only four hard criteria but
it's correct that they right that they
do not have to meet a 50 uh
incarceration rate of their sentence
in instances like that we do have the
discretion there usually is a higher
level review if the staff at the
institution feel that it is appropriate
outside of the cares act we have
procedures in place to review cases such
as that yes but you have that authority
mr manafort and mr cohen to your
knowledge did not have 50 of their
sentence is that correct
i'm not going to talk about individual
uh specific cases uh congresswoman but
we have procedures in place we have a
committee that reviews them and i can
certainly go through that process if
you'd like thank you i would appreciate
it if you could provide us in writing uh
if you're not going to discuss it on the
individual's release under the 50 rule
um let me ask you what are you doing to
prevent more covet 19 death in the vop
facilities
congresswoman we uh we have been in
lockstep with the cdc and other entities
from day one we're doing the same thing
that everyone else in the country in the
world is doing we're learning from and
learning how to mitigate this virus as
stated earlier that uh the you know it's
hard to social distance inside a prison
we've learned from that that's why we
appreciate the ability under karzak to
transfer people out because we were able
to lower our population in those low
security facilities as the one you
described
who it's harder to maintain we're
following cdc guidance we do everything
in collaboration with them and frankly
our pandemic plan actually assisted in
writing the the uh the correctional
guidance for the pandemic thank you
thank you director um and i'll get the
rest in writing thank you very much are
you aware of the racially disparate
impact of the pattern risk assessment
tool and that inmates of color may be
more likely to be stored as high risk
than light
uh and with this in mind you've have you
considered revising the threshold cutoff
between risk categories which would
enable more individuals to earn credits
for an early release and maximize the
benefits of the first step act and take
away the racial disparity that we see
very clearly director
as congresswoman uh that i want to
stress one thing the pattern tool the
bop did not develop it's developed by
nij and approved by the attorney general
we are aware of changes we appropriately
make those adjustments and we score
inmates anytime there's a change and we
work with the department to do that we
are the end user of that tool we did not
create it
finally do you think it would help
inmates on
the compassion relief if bop filed the
motions rather than the inmates
congresswoman as i stated earlier we
don't have the authority to
independently release someone we work
with the
department of justice and we make
recommendations to the court the
judiciary makes the final decision and
we do make staff available to gather
documents we work with the attorneys we
work with the public defenders
and the courts to ensure that all the
documents are available so that we can
go it's just not a quick process that's
what people need to understand the
compassionate pro release process is a
difficult uh one and it has to be done
individually each individual case has to
be fully considered under its unique
circumstances it's not a fast process
thank you my time is expired thank you
very much we will pursue that with you
um i now yield five minutes to the
gentleman from ohio mr chabot
thank you madam chair and i want to
thank you director carvajal for being
here with the committee
today before coming to congress uh over
a quarter century ago now
i served as a local elected official on
cincinnati city council
and on the county commission hamilton
county ohio and in those two capacities
i was very involved with our
incarceration at the local level
um things like double selling inmates to
help with the overcrowding situation
that we had and then work release
programs where we got inmates out uh
picking up trash on the highways cutting
down weeds two for one type programs and
and those types of things so uh when i
got here to congress and then and on to
this committee the judiciary committee i
wanted to continue in that
uh effort and one of the closest things
was was uh prison industries are now
unicorn which i wanted to discuss here
in a second but i also got involved and
worked with for example a
former representative uh rob portman who
is now united states senator and he was
one of the principal moving forces for
the second chance act which we worked uh
with him on and then the uh the first
step act which we passed some time ago
and i work with
adam schiff you know in a bipartisan
manner on the justice
reinvestment initiative
to make sure that members
we've sent out letters over the years
urging members to support funding for
that particular uh program
and and uh so before i
ask you about unicore prison industries
i just wanted to say that uh most of the
inmates we have at the federal level
this is certainly the case at the local
level as well
these inmates whereas most of them for
the most part do need to be removed from
society because they've committed a
crime and yes punishment is involved but
the fact is the vast majority of these
folks are going to be out on our streets
someday
uh and so we're a lot better off as a
society if we recognize that
and if possible reform some of them and
get them job skills that they can
actually
uh
work in the private sector someday to
keep them from coming back now it
doesn't work perfectly um but it can
work and and i strongly support those
and we'll continue to do that but back
to the prison industries uh which
then transformed in in the unicorn this
is the program that we have
uh where the prisoners at the federal
level actually are in work programs so
they're learning a skill
that they will hopefully be able to
carry over into the private sector and
which should help recidivism rates so
people don't which means uh that people
don't come back to prison and the
recidivism rates are far too high as we
know people do tend to come back but
this is one where the rates tend over
time to be better when you actually get
these people a skill and they're often
times we might think of the stereotype
of people are making license plates or
something but it it could be furniture
it could be a whole range of things so
um i'd just like to give you a little
time here if you could uh
tell us how that program's going what
your experience has been
how has it affected recidivism rates is
it a positive thing uh
those types of uh thanks mr director
yes thank you congressman unicor
absolutely is a benefit to the agency it
was established by congress in 1934 the
sole mission of unicor is to train and
employ inmates for exactly what you said
to give them a skill to return
productive members of society
uh you know the about the the last uh
recidivism review they did on unit core
which is several years old uh 24 inmates
that work for our federal prison
industries were less likely to
recidivate 16 of them were more likely
to be gainfully employed upon release so
it is it is a good program we like to
say it's one of our number one if not
the number one uh evidence-based program
because it teaches the skills you spoke
of uh you are correct approximately 95
of people in our custody are going to
return to society so that so it's
important to do that
our we have a board of directors they
take their statutory responsibilities
very seriously they do minimize the
impact to any given industry certainly
we do that through public comment board
hearings things of that nature for those
that think that we are taking from local
industry uh there's procedures in place
to stay compliant with that
thank you very much and i don't have a
lot of time left so this let me ask one
other thing i know that um it's one of
the greatest challenges that you all
have when inmates are there hey they're
criminals so they got there because they
committed a crime and they can prey on
each other or they can make it very
dangerous for the guards so some a
program like prison industries is that
also a mechanism
for
you know a tool for maintaining kind of
good behavior and making sure that it is
a less dangerous environment than it
otherwise might be
absolutely congressman one of the
biggest things that we battle uh
in a prison is idle minds so anything we
can do to keep it people productive and
learning a trade or a skill is our goal
thank you very much i think my time's
expired that mountain chair so i yield
back
since time has expired and let me for a
moment uh thank the members who are here
today uh i will yield to ms dimmons in a
moment but i want to acknowledge
congress uh woman dean congresswoman
scanlon congressman cicilline
congressman lou congressman cullen uh
congressman biggs congressman chabot
congressman stouby congressman
tiffany
congresswoman massey congresswoman
spartz congressman fitzgerald and
congressman owens thank you for your
presence here today my pleasure now to
yield uh five minutes to the gentlelady
from florida uh you are now recognized
miss demings thank you so very much for
your service well good morning and thank
you so much madam chairwoman thank you
for the exceptional work that you are
doing um in this particular area uh
director carvajal it's great to see you
and thank you for
uh joining us um
i just want to first of all just make it
quite clear that uh we all understand
um that there are some people who need
to be locked up
but we also understand that many of them
will integrate back into society and it
is incumbent upon us to make sure that
they have the training tools techniques
that they need uh to be successful we
all
um
understand that um director you spoke a
little bit about uh unicore and how
successful it has been um could you just
talk a little bit more about
uh that program and how we can even
improve
upon the success of that program how can
congress be a better partner in helping
those that will be coming back into
society
yes i appreciate that congresswoman uh
i think uh speaking about it and being
able to support the program in and of
itself oftentimes we're criticized that
we are taking uh jobs from the local
communities as i stated earlier we have
a board of directors who oversees that
uh it is a great program the more that
we can keep inmates teaching them the
trades and working the other thing that
uh that i that i think that hits home is
that we're teaching them the soft skills
of reentry uh some of these folks have
never had an actual job in a factory and
you know punch a clock so to speak uh
and they're also earning uh they're
earning a decent living for being
incarcerated part of that is paying
their financial responsibility a lot of
them are able to
help support their families uh again
teaching that soft skill which is 50
percent of our mission re-entry i i have
to stress that our we want the same
thing we want people to go back to
society as productive members of society
and we're committed to doing that half
of our mission is keeping people safe
and secure the other half which we're
equally committed to is making sure that
they get the skills to go back and be
productive members of the community
director thank you for that you also i
talked about in your opening statement
some of the challenges
that you have in terms of meeting staff
and our requirements that you're being
outbided by other state and local
organizations i'm certainly or agencies
i'm certainly sensitive to that um could
you talk a little bit more about you
know what
look increased salaries is probably the
answer but
could you talk about some of the other
maybe creative ways that you are looking
to not only recruit
um cos but to uh retain them
yes thank you congresswoman very very
much a priority for us it always has
been uh again i stated earlier that uh
there's a narrative out there that we
can't hire that's not true we proved we
can hire we have several locations that
are chronically difficult to staff in
those cases as you stated we have a hard
time competing with local industry or
other correctional agencies uh we don't
set the pay bans for that uh you know
opm does that we are working with the
department on other types of incentives
we use recruitment and retention
incentives we use relocation incentives
all of those are things that that we
work with uh to get approval from the
department and support going to opm to
be able to look at these areas uh some
of the hard to staff places
as congresswoman uh
stated earlier beaumont
beaumont is an arrest of u.s pay scale
it's really hard to compete with local
industry there when they they frankly
can get paid more working down the
street and that's one of the challenges
beaumont is a great facility i spent
four years of my career there
so it's not the facility it's the it's
us being able to compete with a location
and director finally i remember hearing
some concerns about
centered around officer safety because
of staffing shortages where personnel
that weren't necessarily trained
as
correctional officers if you will
were being utilized in that capacity
could you
um talk a little bit more about that and
if that's just a rumor set all of us at
ease about it
yes congresswoman i absolutely
appreciate the opportunity to set the
record straight on here uh first off we
would not put untrained people in there
we are very fortunate as a correctional
agency it's one of the things we pride
ourselves on that all of our staff are
correctional trained correctional
workers they receive the same training
regardless of where they work so we have
uniform staff that are correctional
officers and the nurses the food service
people the teachers everyone goes
through the exact same training that is
that gives us the ability to utilize
these staff safely okay so that
narrative is is inaccurate when you hear
it we are challenged with staffing and
i'll tell you that we are funded at 90
percent
during my tour as a director our
priority has been staffing we have
funded
all of the positions that we get money
for as i mentioned earlier at one point
i hired a thousand over my staff went a
thousand over we're able to do that
because our human resource know our
attrition rate so we try to get ahead of
it but it's a constant challenge there's
a lot of moving parts it's a very large
organization 38 000 staff is a lot of
people to keep track of
thank you so much director madam chair
i'm out of time i yield back thank you
you know lady yields back her time has
expired thank you so very much my
pleasure to yield now five minutes uh to
uh congressman stewbe
you're recognizing
thank you madam chair um director thanks
for thanks for being here obviously the
committee has a lot of questions and we
appreciate your attendance today
on july 1st of last year i wrote a
letter to both you and the director of
the dc departments of corrections about
the treatment of the january 6 suspects
your office responded on july 21st the
d.c department of corrections has so far
refused to answer and we're almost a
year after the the fact that i sent the
letter
uh director i recognize that many of the
most egregious examples of mistreatment
of january 6 inmates happen not in your
system but in the dc jail
it has been reported that january 6
inmates in the dc jail who are not
vaccinated for coven 19 are forced into
solitary confinement for 14 days after
meeting with their attorneys
yes or no does bop have the same policy
in your facilities
no congressman we do not
well i'm glad to hear that and that also
highlights how out of step and illegal
the policies of the dc jail regarding
january 6th inmate says
it's also been reported that january 6
inmates in the dc jail have not been
allowed haircuts or to attend religious
services unless they are vaccinated for
covet 19.
yes or no does bop have the same policy
oh congressman we treat all of every
people in our custody everybody has
equal access and is treated with
dignity and has access to everything
equally
further shows
thank you for your your response this
further shows how egregious the dc jails
mistreatment of january 6 inmate says it
has further been reported that january 6
inmates in the dc jail have been denied
medical treatment and this was largely
the basis for a federal judge finding
the warden in contempt in your
experience as a career law enforcement
officer and a prison official is this
acceptable conduct by a correctional
institution to deny medical treatment
congressman i'm not going to uh
comment on what another correctional
agency does without knowing all the
information i can just stress to you
that in the bop which is who i represent
everyone has equal access to medical
care programs
community placement things of that
nature
i would say
dc corrections
so well i did and they're not answering
my questions so i'm just highlighting
the differences in how you run your
agency and how they're running theirs
additionally i would like to ask for an
update on the statistics provided to me
in your office's response to that july
1st letter if you know the answers
offhand that would be great but i
understand if you don't have that in
front of you or you don't know
but i would like your commitment today
to follow up with my office on the
following first the number of january 6
inmates in your in bop's custody that
are awaiting trial and the number of
such inmates who are in special housing
units
second the number of january 6 inmates
serving sentences and the number of such
inmates who are in special housing units
i would ask your commitment today to get
me those responses
yes congressman i can get you those
responses we do i'm aware we have 19 in
our custody eight of those are pre-trial
as to their specific housing today i
don't want to misspeak but i will
certainly follow up with that
information uh with your staff okay i
would appreciate that you said 19 in
custody and how many in pre-trial
confinement 19 in custody eight of those
are pre-trial uh
i don't know their exact status today i
don't want to misspeak
if you could provide the details of that
not just to me but i'm sure the members
of this committee
would also be
interested in that information
i've got a little bit of time left so
one more question your office response
to my letter was noted that judges quote
routine routinely make recommendations
to the bureau regarding placement of an
inmate at a specific institution or
enrollment in programs and you're also
your office also noted that the bureau's
policy requires and i quote a good faith
effort to follow these judicial
recommendations
i would point out that such judicial
recommendations are often very much of
the discretion of the judge and while i
generally have faith in our judiciary to
fairly call balls and strikes on purely
legal matters on discretionary issues
such as this it is obvious
obviously possible for personal biases
to come into play
so my question is this if a judge makes
a recommendation on the terms of a
january 6 inmates custody and that
recommendation was influenced by the
judge's political leanings
bop would be compelled by policy to make
a good faith effort to follow that
recommendation is that correct
congressman uh recommendations that are
made by the judiciary we certainly
respect them and work with them uh but
there's a lot of moving parts inside our
agency we make the final determination
it is simply that a recommendation we
give it the
look but ultimately we make those
decisions based on the best place to
quarter and keep people safe and secure
thank you madam chair my time is expired
this time is expired thank you and it's
my pleasure to now yield uh five minutes
to the gentlelady from pennsylvania
congresswoman dean
i thank you madam chair for uh hosting
this important hearing and i thank you
director carvajal for your work
uh i was happy to hear uh last april
before a senator judiciary committee
that vop was working to expand mental
health treatment and vocational training
and life skills i also hope the vop is
expanding
uh substance use disorder treatment
recovery therapy
and the rest
uh one thing i have in mind in
particular are educational opportunities
we know they make all the difference in
helping to break this cycle of
recidivism and reincarceration which is
why i introduced elijah cummings the
prep act
legislation that would ensure that
incarcerated individuals receive
educational opportunities they need to
successfully re-enter their communities
re-enter their lives after completing
their sentences
can you give us a information on the
number of people today enrolled in your
system in educational opportunities
yes congresswoman
the information uh the current
information is we have over 75 000
inmates enrolled in uh one of our 80
evidence-based recipient reducing
programs or productive activities uh
even since cobit although we were
hindered by the pandemic and we had to
slow things down over 151 thousand
inmates completed programming of course
the literacy programs the ged
we offer many trades we have over 200
career technical educations we've done a
lot of work with expanding programs
specifically for the female offenders
we have dedicated staff just to to make
sure that we
process that population special and
unique needs
we are working with the department of
labor to expand apprenticeship programs
because we know that vocational trades
help people get jobs when they go out
and some of the things that the prep act
would do would be higher education
college credits
what percentage of inmates are enrolled
in educational programming
congresswoman i don't have the exact
numbers off my head but i'll certainly
uh follow up i'm sure we can get you
that information
okay terrific if you would share that
with the committee that would be great
uh what programs are in place regarding
addiction and substance use disorder
what percentage of inmates struggle with
either mental health or addiction
uh and how many are being offered
treatment
congresswoman we we have many
drug abuse programs available we have a
residential drug
abuse program that is uh
one of our best evidence-based programs
we also under the first step back we
expanded our mat treatments it targets a
specific subset for the opioid
people with opioid use disorder and we
currently work on expanding those
treatments i don't know the exact
percentage it is a high amount of people
that come into our system with drug and
alcohol abuse programs i don't have the
exact percentages but we can certainly
get them to you
i would really appreciate it if we could
get the percentages and also to
understand if it if treatment
is universally available throughout the
system
we know that there is a high correlation
of
addiction substance use disorder
and incarceration
onto the solitary confinement in the few
minutes that i have left we read reports
we hear from inmates and their families
on the dangerous side effects of
solitary confinement the serious lasting
psychological damage uh contrary to the
very set of questions i just uh asked
you
uh pre-pandemic uh it was conservatively
estimated that 60 000 to 80 000 people
were confined to solitary and we
understand that solitary may have been
used uh
as a substitute during covid for
isolation medically required isolation
can you give us an update on the use of
solitary confinement and importantly i
hope uh on a recognition that it is a
failed practice
as congresswoman we average around 9 000
inmates at any given time in our
restrictive housing units about 8 000 of
those
are for administrative uh purposes
pending placements conducting
investigations sometimes they're
separations for their own safety there's
a there was eleven hundred in their
spending disciplinary action we try to
make that we we try to use alternative
sanctions and we try to limit the time
that someone spends in restrictive
housing uh one of the things that we've
done to address this issue for just some
of the reasons you stated is that we've
expanded our what we call a reintegra
reintegration housing unit program which
allows that group of inmates who tend to
spend time in restrictive housing a
general population type atmosphere uh a
smaller
general population so that we can remove
them from restrictive housing so that is
something that we monitor daily uh we're
committed to ensuring that everyone in
there has access to programming they do
medical and everything else we also
ensure that we make rounds daily and
check on the inmates they have constant
inmate contact
director i thank you for your questions
your answers and i look forward to the
information coming to the committee and
i yield back
thank you lady her time has expired and
i'm pleased to yield five minutes to mr
tiffany miss tiffany you're recognized
for five minutes thank you and good
morning madam chair uh
first of all director um
can those that were fired as a result of
not taking your uh staff
on as a result of not taking the vaccine
can they get their jobs back
congressman we have processes for all
that and i'm certain that we will follow
them and ford does
the appropriate due process
following opm guidance and regulations
and all the rules and laws
[Music]
is prison ministries allowed in the
bureau of prisons
yes congressman they are have they been
in during colbit
uh i i'm
well we had to restrict through our
covet operations obviously people coming
in for their safety and for ours we
don't want to introduce covet into our
environments so it's been restricted but
we worked on that we have a matrix out
there operational if the institution ceo
if they fall into that criteria they can
make those adjustments daily uh so
for any given place congressman i can't
answer that today but we can certainly
get you the information if you're
interested in a specific location please
do that with the explosion and crime in
the united states the last couple years
have you seen an increase in the inmate
population in the bureau of prisons
actually congressman our population has
decreased over the last several years
is part of that as a result of
the covert releases that you've done i
think you detailed those numbers earlier
yes congressman it is and please keep in
mind that we're on the back end of the
criminal justice system so it takes time
to go through this the system so i would
defer some of that information probably
to uh the uh the doj
we we get them at the back end of it
thank you very much
whether you're vaccinated or
unvaccinated you can still contract
covid19
why are we still releasing inmates
congressman if i understand your
correction uh or your your question
correctly uh under the cares act is that
what your question is why are we
releasing inmates under the cares act
yeah
yes
because it is a statute we're following
it the guidance that we were given so we
follow the law congressman
do you think we should rethink that as a
congress that sets this policy or can
can
uh change the policy congressman i would
defer to uh you you and your and the
members of congress to answer that
so
we had the two stabbing deaths um down
in i believe it's the beaumont facility
in texas
prior to the stabbing incident if these
two people
would have had coveted
is it possible they could have asked for
release
under under
under the law well congressman i want to
make sure i paint the right picture here
we're going to appropriately review
everybody by the criteria but the level
the security level where this incident
happened and the fact that these
individuals were members of security
threat group and at a high security the
chances of them being released were
probably very slim because one of the
criteria is you cannot have a crime of
violence and it appears that these two
these individuals were involved in
violence
precisely why prisons exist there are a
small fraction of people as these that
are going to continue their criminal
activity
so it's not
completely ruled out that they could
have gotten released
congressman that's why we have the
criteria and we utilize our good
discretion and judgment and follow that
statute
federal prison inmates are keeping large
sums of money as much as a hundred
thousand dollars each in government-run
deposit accounts effectively shielded
from court orders including people like
um the pedophile larry nassar the boston
bomber mr tsarnaev what specific
specific plans does the bureau have in
place to ensure victims get what they
are owed
okay congressman good question first off
i want to stress something that
currently the bop does not have the
authority to seize funds independently
from an inmate without their consent we
are working with the department of
justice to change that rule that will
allow us to automatically encumber funds
or a portion of their funds to to pay
fines and restitution our inmate trust
fund collects about 6 million annually
to make sure that they pay restitution
but i stress again that we don't
independently have the authority to
retrieve funds we work with other law
enforcement entities in that case the
united states marshal's office the
united states attorney's office and the
courts in those in those matters when we
have to do that yeah i think that's
something madam chair that should really
be looked at the other thing that i
would urge madam chair we need to hear
after hearing mr stooby's questioning
and i'm so glad the representative from
pennsylvania was concerned about
solitary confinement we need to have a
hearing on the january 6th detainees we
need to have a full
full airing of what is going on with
those january or six detainees because
they're being uh submitted to conditions
that many on this committee including
the other side of the aisle find
reprehensible it's time to have a
hearing on january 6 detainees i yield
back thank you gentlemen the gentleman's
time has expired and i'm pleased to
yield to the gentlelady from uh
pennsylvania uh ms scanlon you're
recognized now for five minutes
thank you madam chair appreciate you
having this hearing today and thank you
director carvajal for for being with us
i was hoping you could help me clarify
just for a minute kind of the baseline
um population that we're talking about
here
sorry
um so as i understand it the inmate
population for the bureau of prisons
from
1940 to 1980 was around 24 000. is that
right
uh yes ma'am if i if my memory serves me
correctly yes i don't have that
information right in front of me i'm
actually pulling it off your website
here um but so then the population
doubled in the 80s to about 58 000
doubled again in the 90s to 136
000
and continued to climb until 2013 at
which point the bureau of prisons was
housing about 217 000 people is that
right
that is correct okay and so what is what
is your current census of inmates in the
bureau of prisons
uh i'm not sure i understand your
question congresswoman so are you
currently housing about 153 000
yeah yes i'm sorry i i just didn't
didn't hear you about 153 134 000 in our
120 bureau facilities there's about 6
200 in four private contract facilities
100 in rrcs and the 5400 i mentioned on
home confinement for cares that
okay thank you i was having trouble
figuring out where all the numbers were
yes those are rough estimates they
change daily
okay and and i think everyone on the
committee knows that by the time we got
to you know 2013 or so we had
widespread agreement everyone from the
koch brothers to the obama justice
department saying we are over
incarcerating people in this country and
it's a huge financial drain as well as
a huge waste of human capital and a
human rights problem
um now there's been some emphasis on the
purpose of the bureau of prisons to be
punishment but it also has a
rehabilitative purpose doesn't it
yes congresswoman i'd like to stress
something that uh we're not here for
punishment the taking of their time by
the courts of the criminal justice
system that's the punishment we're here
to house people that are remanded to our
custody and more importantly to prepare
them to re-enter society keep them safe
while we're here we're not here as
punishment that's not how we look at
this agency
okay and and i'm particularly interested
as some of my colleagues have been in in
the rehabilitative function the the
efforts that are made to
ensure that when people are released
from prison they're able to successfully
re-enter um and and that they're not you
know worse off than they were before
they went in because that doesn't seem
to serve society well at eid either um
what is the current recidivism rate to
your to your knowledge from uh the
federal prisons
it's about 43
okay you might want to update the
website it says 34
um has there been a significant change
in recent years
uh no ma'am i'll have to have my staff
look at that at that website i'm never
i'm not familiar with it being in the
30s okay it's on the home
page um
okay
so
um
with respect to we've
my colleague
ms dean talked a little bit about some
of the educational programs i recently
had a constituent reach out about a
relative's participation in the bureau
of prisons drug abuse rehabilitation
program or rdap
um and they've encountered problems
getting all their earned credits counted
towards release
because um the program was paused by
covid19 and eventually this
constituent's relative was able to get
the credits but they had to go to court
um and that's not a particularly uh
cost-effective method of dealing with
this for anyone um
i know that rdap was paused at many
facilities is that still the case and if
not
is it back up and running at all
facilities where it was previously
offered
yes congresswoman as i stated earlier
covet covet certainly impacts our
institutions we have
operational matrix that dictates how
they operate we have been affected by it
i know that
certain inmates have been affected we
expect our staff to work with them
i'm not i don't not familiar with a
particular case you're talking about but
we can certainly get back with you on
that specifics of that case
uh but otherwise we we go
we go to the point of trying to work
with them so that they can benefit from
uh home confinement finishing the
program getting their time credits the
whole goal is for them to get the time
credits again i'd like to stress that
we're not trying to keep people in
except unless they need to be in if they
are earning time credits we want them to
go back to society as appropriate okay
one last question i'm running out of
time i was very interested in the effort
to put more apprenticeship programs in
there so that people have hard skills
that are going to enable them to become
employed when they get out how um what
is the trajectory on that how many
places have apprenticeship um programs
and what efforts are being made to
expand that
has expired uh director i'll allow you
to answer the question thank you thank
you congresswoman we can get back with
you with that specific information we
are working with department of labor to
grow that program
okay thank you appreciate it yield back
thank you gentlelady for her questioning
uh now it's uh my privilege to yield
five minutes uh to
uh mr massey gentleman is recognized for
five minutes thank you madam chairwoman
um i want to thank you
director carvajal for your staff being
responsive to one of my inquiries about
how many vaccination exemptions have
been granted at the bop
it looks like as of january 20th there
were 4
738 exemptions most of them were
religious exemptions
instead of asking you i want to inform
you that this has had a very negative
effect on the morale of the officers the
fact that they are required to live
under a vaccine mandate and the inmates
are not
it's kind of interesting that the the
inmates have more rights than the
officers themselves
they also resent that they've had to
apply for religious
exemptions when in fact they should have
been granted a medical exemption but at
least some of them have been able to get
the exemptions
and you may want to check in on whether
you've completely suspended this mandate
because there are officers who are still
required to do the weekly testing if
they're not vaccinated per the mandate
and also to certify that they have a
religious exemption even as of this week
they've had to do that
so but i appreciate the accommodations
that you have made because it will
negatively affect morale and recruiting
if we do
keep this vaccine mandate in place
i want to ask you
how many
correctional officers were budgeted
for the bop by congress
i think i'll give you my number it's not
a gotcha the number i have i'm just
trying to see if it's correct is 20 446.
that yes congressman again this this i
appreciate the opportunity to clarify
that specific correctional officers what
we call the correctional officer that
work those posts is approximately
fourteen thousand uh the twenty thousand
you're referring to is six thousand
additional
support positions that fall under the
correctional officer series this is a
classification issue and it's often
confusing uh that encumbers other
positions that work in correctional
services but the actual true
correctional officers that we look at is
approximately fourteen thousand
i have to have the six 000 been hired
we have a currently congressman about
1100 correctional officer vacancies
right now uh almost half of those are at
seven locations that are hard to fill
okay
um there's one facility in my district
the ashland fci where five years ago
they had 130 officers and now they have
100 and they're told they're going to 98
yet they've got more inmates
and
we see that augmentation is being used
there
so i'm concerned that the inmates are
going up and the officers are going down
because i'd like for it to be a safe
environment and i think if it's
understaffed
it's not safe
also they're utilizing overtime
virtually every day at that facility and
it would be cheaper for the taxpayers if
we had
more slots filled
um and i've heard that augmentation is
being used there to backfill some of
those slots and i'm not going to debate
whether they're trained enough you've
already addressed that you assured us
that they are
but what is augmentation and where do
those people come from when they go
serve in roles that correctional
officers might otherwise fill
oh i think you're muted director
sorry
uh augmentation is a necessary tool that
we use in our agency uh
to make sure that we complete the first
part of our mission first and that's to
keep everyone safe and secure in order
to be able to do the second part of our
mission which is give people a chance to
return
as you stated we often use we try not to
do it but it's certainly a tool that we
have to use
we use people from other disciplines
such as teachers nurses things of that
nature we try to limit that those
decisions are based
upon a roster locally the ceo makes
those determinations uh uh i stated
earlier we have approximately 11
1100 correctional officer vacancies i'd
like to stress congressman that
we are
funded at 90 percent
we have 38 884 positions we are funded
for 35 161. that's about 3723 vacancies
that about 500 million dollars were
short
our correctional officer fuel rate is
got as high as 94 it's currently 92
percent so our goal is to fill every
single position that we are funded for
but i can't spend money we don't have
okay i would like you for you to look
specifically at ashland fci and my
concern about augmentation should be a
concern we all have is when you take
people away from being teachers to being
guards or other services then the
teaching doesn't happen and then we
could see higher recidivism because we
know that vocational schools and
education correlate to recidivism so i
would hope that you can get those slots
filled that we can get more slots we can
rely less on overtime and release on
pulling those teachers away who are so
important for and the other people who
are important for complying with first
step pack so thank you ma'am chairwoman
for indulging me and i yield back thank
you the gentleman's time is expiring
it's my privilege now to yield five
minutes to the general lady from georgia
and i thank her for her very powerful
remarks this morning
at the national prayer breakfast then
lady from georgia miss macbeth is
recognized for five minutes
thank you chairwoman
lee and good afternoon director carvajal
i thank you for being here today and i
thank you for your service as the
director as you will soon be leaving the
bureau and we just want to thank you for
your service during this subcommittee's
last hearing we had an opportunity to
review implementation of the first step
act
and um you know at the bop and the
impact that cobit 19 has had on the blp
operations
i use that opportunity to inquire at
that time into the blp's policies
addressing the treatment and care of
pregnant women specifically the blp's
alignment with national guidance for the
health and safety of pregnant women
since that time i was pleased to hear
that the bop has taken actions to better
align its policies on about five of the
eight care topics that the gao found to
be to not fully be aligned with the
national guidance recommendations and i
hope that the bureau will continue to
work
to ensure that all eight of those care
topics are met so that the health and
well-being of pregnant women uh at the
blp facilities is is you know they're
fully protected and cared for today
however i do want to examine how bop is
handling its re-entry services the
successful re-entry of citizens into
society is integral to any recidivism
efforts crime in our communities and the
financial health of these offenders
rejoining society however it's kind of
difficult to uh
i guess actually to assess recidivism
patterns unless you were properly
collecting the data on it for example
the last federal justice statistics
publication or recidivism of federal
offenders that i was able to locate was
published in june 2016 and the latest
publication on the employment statuses
of released federal offenders was
published last december but covers
federal inmates released back in 2010
so further the latest blp publication on
recidivism that i was able to find was
from 2006. so director carvajal what
steps has the blp taken to improve its
data collection to more effectively
track the progress of incarcerated
individuals as they transition from
prison to re-entry centers or home
confinement and does the blp have plans
to create
standard metrics to evaluate re-entry
outcomes such as job placement
recidivism so that the bop facilities
can share their best practices
yes congresswoman i appreciate your
interest in this this is very important
to us uh
it's a it's a very complicated process
for the gathering of recidivism data we
work in conjunction with the states and
other uh law enforcement entities we are
not sole owners of that data uh i will
tell you that my staff are working with
other components to set up a platform uh
and we're committed to working on
bettering that platform to get that data
to track it
and sir then once that is done or
initiated and completed could you just
please i would love my staff we would
love to have what that platform looks
like and what it entails if you would
yes yes we can do that congresswoman
thank you thank you so i'm also curious
to know how many re-entry coordinators
that the board of prisons have uh per
prison or per prisoner how many
vacancies are there for these jobs
you've made mention of you know the
number of
vacancies that you have but how many
vacancies are for these jobs and what
steps has the board of prisons taken to
fill these positions
yes congresswoman uh we are we are
committed to filling all our vacancies
as i stated earlier we strive to do that
i don't know the exact number of
re-entry affairs coordinators but those
are those are positions that we strive
to fill
as we do all of our positions and as i
stated earlier we are we are
filled every position we have funding
for and we're committed to continue to
do that i can get to the exact numbers i
can get back with you on that i don't
have in front of me
no we really appreciate that effort i
think my colleagues and i would be
really interested to have that
information um and i really appreciate
that um well as has been stated by many
of my colleagues before me you know
we're very very concerned about um you
know actually you know people say that
criminals have rights and yes they do
have rights just as victims have rights
and we just want to make sure that when
those
those that are incarcerated do have the
ability to have fair treatment while
they are incarcerated
because at the end of the day they're
human beings too and thank you so much
madam chair i yield back the balance of
my time
the lady has yielded back uh thank you
it is my privilege now to um yield
um
five minutes uh too
by my
gentleman mr fitzgerald you're
recognized for five minutes
thank you
thank you madam chair sorry about that
uh my colleagues on the other side of
the aisle introduced several pieces of
legislation that would eliminate bail in
the federal system and make states that
utilize bail for pre-trial release
ineligible for grants under the edward
byrne memorial justice assistance grant
program
[Music]
these uh reforms continue to be pushed
in the wake of the traffic tragic events
uh where violent criminals are released
either on bond or uh when they're
involved in some of these uh terrible
crimes
of which some of my colleagues have been
talking about this morning
jurisdictions in california maryland new
jersey new york
and in my own district
which i represent milwaukee county has
modified their bail practices to
eliminate
or de-emphasize the use of monetary bail
systems
coupled with
i think
some of my colleagues
desire you know which has been going on
for a year discussions about defunding
or dismantling
uh the police departments or bail reform
efforts
uh
you know it it's troubling i think it's
making some of the communities less safe
or it's sending the wrong
signal or message
to some of these individuals that
ultimately commit these crimes
additionally the pre-trial integrity and
safe safety act would provide grants to
states if they eliminate their money
bail systems
um
and then things like the minnesota
freedom fund of which you know even vice
president
uh harris was involved in for a period
of time so uh this fund and others uh
that are similar have kind of
contributed i think to this overall
uh concern
and then uh right in my backyard in uh
the fifth congressional district in
wisconsin
uh we had um the national attention
given to the waukesha christmas
parade murders that happened
uh daryl brooks the individual which was
released on a thousand dollar bond
after running over uh a woman with a
vehicle this is prior to the parade
and then he was released on bail despite
having a lengthy criminal history uh
including a charge for aggravated
battery and an outstanding warrant in
nevada
after skipping bail for a sex-related
crime
uh and then as you know he subsequently
drove his car through the christmas
parade in waukesha wisconsin
killing six individuals one of whom was
a eight-year-old boy
uh bail reform policies such as cashless
bail
uh have that have been supported by some
of my colleagues
uh actually do more harm than help
in what i would consider the
some of the minority communities
that
that could have benefited from
i think some of these reforms as we
discuss them at the state and federal
level
uh so
director i guess crimes that are
considered felonies are being treated as
misdemeanors or civil infractions
uh
you know
in controlling
kind of the the criminal and the justice
system
from the perspective of
uh the benefit always goes kind of to
the criminal
what's the fallout and i know you talked
about this earlier but
um under the first step the act calls
upon um prisons to create rules around
evidence-based recidivism reduction
programs and productive activity
uh
can you comment i mean there has to be a
relationship between those incarcerated
and certainly the set of statutes both
at the state and federal level and how
they affect that what's the interaction
uh
during your period of time as as
director
congressman i'm not sure i understand
your question uh you know we're
committed to re-entry that's 50 part of
our 50 part of our mission the other is
keeping people safe and secure we don't
control who comes to our custody that's
on the front end of the justice system
uh the courts determine that uh so when
they come in here our our mission is to
keep everyone safe and secure and ensure
that they have equal access to
programming as stated before 95 of those
people return to society
just one more quick one then one of my
uh experience as a state legislator
as well as i think in in kind of the
relationship that i've tried to develop
with the federal system within the state
of wisconsin
uh one of the things that's always
linked is the literacy rate compared to
recidivism
you know we find that if an inmate can
read at an eighth grade level they're
far late
likely to recommit is that something you
guys have looked at or checked into and
is it something that you monitor
as congressman we we have lots of
literacy programs high school
equivalency ged
and we encourage inmates that's part of
the risk and needs assessment when they
come in
we we assess them and we
address their needs we assign them
programs to address their needs that's
precisely what the first step act is for
we were doing that all along we've had a
risk in needs assessment we just
formalized it under the first step back
thank you manager i yield back
thank the gentleman for his
questioning uh now i'm pleased to yield
to the gentlelady from st louis missouri
vice chair of this committee uh
congressman bush you are recognized for
five minutes
st lewis and i thank you chairwoman for
convening this important hearing i add
unanimous consent to enter into the
record the experiences of 17 women
across five federal facilities which
have been provided by the national
council of incarcerated and formerly
incarcerated women and girls
without objection so honored thank you
in these emails women in federal custody
detail horrifying accounts of not being
allowed to get out of their beds all day
because of coded lockdowns being forced
to eat expired food
having little to no access to medical
services to treat cancers and other
underlying conditions
having to pay two dollars to file a sick
complaint
this is all happening under your watch
these are complaints coming from not one
or not not two facilities but five
different facilities which makes clear
that these issues are not isolated but
they're systemic
these women cannot hold you accountable
mr carvajal they cannot but we can and i
would like to use this opportunity to
ask you questions that they cannot
directly ask you out of fear of
retaliation so mr carvajal yes or no are
you aware of these complaints across so
many of your facilities
congresswoman i'm not aware of those
particular complaints but i'm certainly
interested in hearing from you or your
staff so that we can look into them
because i find that if that happened i
find it unacceptable
thank you thank you our staff will be in
touch thank you for that um are
complaints filed by people in blp
custody being logged and am i able to
access those logs
we absolutely keep the log of complaints
we take all allegations seriously we
have an office of internal affairs we
follow the process we work with the
office of inspector general uh and when
needed other law enforcement agencies
it's certainly
the fbi and investigatory agencies we
take all of those
complaints and allegations seriously and
we look into them
am i able to access the laws
congresswoman if you'd like i could have
my staff reach out to you see if you
have particular information you're
interested in and if we can we will
provide that to you thank you
thank you um in the midst of a raging
pandemic that has made incarcerated
individual
individuals uniquely vulnerable rather
than allowing people to serve their
sentences from their homes with their
families and away from the trauma and
abuse of the blp system
the federal prison population has grown
keeping them in prison it is an act of
cruelty in april of last year you told
the senate judiciary committee that 50
to 75 of those incarcerated have been
reviewed for home confinement and that
24 000 out of over 150 000 people in
federal custody have been placed in home
confinement as of today have all of
those incarcerated been reviewed for
home confinement now instead of the 50
to 75
councilman we review all eligible
inmates for home confinement of the
cares act uh we did that we've placed
over 37 000 inmates 9 000 of those more
than 9 000 were specific under cares act
placement those are 9 000 inmates that
would not be out in community custody at
this point in their incarceration and
our population is actually reduced uh
congresswoman
okay well we looked at the website
earlier today so is the website
inaccurate
i'm not certain which information you
were from we went to the bureau the
federal bureau of prisons website um so
uh
two weeks ago
i along with representative bonnie
watson-coleman we sent a letter seeking
clarification from the bureau on the
implementation of the office of legal
counsel's new guidance for those on home
confinement under the cares act
we asked for a response no later than
february the 7th of this year can we get
a commitment from you that such a
response is forthcoming
mr carvajal
congresswoman i'm aware of your letter
and we are certainly working on
answering it understand please that
there is a clearance process of which i
do not control but we are committed to
getting you a response to your letter
thank you my office will be in contact
i yield back
general lady yields back thank you very
much it's uh my pleasure now to yield to
the gentleman from iowa uh mr owens for
five minutes mr owens you're recognized
for five minutes
we will then
we'll then be happy now to move to the
gentleman from rhode island mr sicilini
we're pleased to yield mr cicilline in
five minutes you're recognized now
thank you uh madam chair and thank you
director for being here i too uh uh
joined the letter that congressman bush
just referenced and very much look
forward to your response to that
we held a hearing on january 21st
to learn more about the bureau of
prisons response to the pandemic and
specifically discuss compassionate
release as a tool to reduce prison
occupancy and keep people safe and so my
first question is i have a piece of
legislation that would expand
compassionate release availability
during a public health emergency and
given all the evidence we've seen about
successful reintegration through
compassionate release during covet it
seems to me that it makes sense to fully
utilize this tool
and so my first question is what is the
bureau of prison's current policy for
considering compassionate release of
individuals at high risk of serious
illness from covid19
congressman uh the compassionate release
process is sometimes uh confused with
the the home confinement of which we we
use it's a quicker placement the
reduction in sentence process is is much
more difficult it wasn't designed to be
a timely process each individual has to
be reviewed and unique extraordinary
compelling circumstances so directed so
is it my understanding that you don't
use compassionate release or recommend
commercial release relating to people
who pose uh have a serious risk of
illness with coca-19 you don't use that
process at all
under the cares act we
we review everyone for placement at home
confinement but yes we do if they follow
a reduction in sentence
uh motion we do evaluate it and assess
it under our policy we just don't
independently release someone from our
custody we make no i know you don't my
question is do you use compassionate
release of individuals at a high risk of
seriousness from covin and what is your
current policy in terms of applying
compassion at least to such individuals
that's not a hard question
if they submit a request we go we follow
our policy in the statute and review it
if it's appropriate we make the motion
if not it is denied okay um healthcare
workers across the country are obviously
experiencing incredible burnout after
two years fighting on the front lines of
this pandemic i presume that
correctional staff feels similarly
especially during outbreaks in the
facilities and given the statistics i've
seen on overtime and infection rates and
considering the ongoing risk of coca-19
and continuous stabbing shortages
and bops expanded authority to lease
individuals to home confinement why is
blp not utilizing mitigation strategies
like compassionate release more fully to
reduce the number of incarcerated
individuals in the federal prison
we are utilizing a congressman we make
recommendations to the court as
appropriate the court makes a final
decision not the bop if if the motion is
made up of the inmate under the first
step act which they can do that after 30
days we don't take a position on the
motion we're not party to those cases
it goes through the system
director um my colleague congressman
dean raised questions about solitary
confinement and the number she
referenced uh i concur with and the
number increased 500 percent in 2020
with about 300 000 people in solitary
confinement at any one time
the policy of using solitary restrictive
housing as a substitute for cdc
recommended medical isolation has caused
unbelievable harms to incarcerated
individuals and so my question is what
steps has the bop leadership taken to
ensure that it's following the
appropriate guidance like the cdc
guidance place people in medical
isolation not solitary confinement or
restrictive housing during this or in
any future public health emergency
congressman we uh we follow the cdc
guidance uh in some cases we go above
and beyond i'd i'd like to clarify
though that
medical isolation is often
confused with solitary confinement there
are instances when inmates placed in
restrictive housing are isolated also
medically isolated in those cases it's
appropriate we don't we don't place
people uh from the general population
who are in place in medical isolation we
don't place them in restrictive housing
if there's a case where it's an issue
where we're out of space or something uh
they're appropriately
attacked they're not treated
there's different rules for that
director in february 2020 the un special
rapporteur on torture issued a statement
related to the use of solitude
confinement in united states prison
stating that and i quote the severe and
often irreparable psychological and
physical consequences of solitary
confinement and social exclusion are
well documented can range from
progressively severe forms of anxiety
stress and depression to cognitive
impairment and suicidal tendencies this
deliberate infliction of severe mental
pain or suffering may well amount to
psychological torture end quote so my
question is the bop aware of the mental
and physical damage of solitary
confinement on the individuals in their
care and do you have policies in place
to try to reduce use of solitary
confinement and will you furnish this
committee with all of the background and
supporting documents to reveal to us
really the status of the use of solitary
confinement in your efforts to mitigate
it
i think you're on mute mr director
sorry yes congressman that's a lot of
information we will certainly get that
to you i will tell you that uh we are
committed to to continue to
appropriately reduce our use of
restrictive housing in some cases
there's a reason for it we do but we
have policies in place
making rounds making sure that they have
access to programming and earning time
credits
we can get you all that information and
we can answer any questions you like
regarding that i appreciate that and
just directed one point the making
rounds is not you know the fact that you
check in some on somebody while they're
experiencing what has been described in
psychological torture isn't sufficient
so i look forward to that information i
thank the chairwoman i yield thank you
the german's time is expired uh thank
you and uh my pleasure now to yield uh
to the distinguished gentleman from
california among many of our members on
this committee uh and uh we yield to you
mr luke for five minutes you're now
recognized for five minutes
thank you uh chairwoman sheila jackson
lee for holding this important oversight
hearing thank you director cargaho for
your public service
approximately how many coven 19 vaccines
did the bureau of prisons the minister
congressman we've administered to date
over 290
over 292 000 doses to both staff and
inmates uh 80 percent of our staff give
or take 80 percent are vaccinated and
about 70 percent of our inmate
population it's a moving target because
there's always people coming in and out
every single person is offered the
opportunity to be vaccinated
did anyone die as a result of getting
the covert 19 vaccine
congressman i i do not know that i would
have to get you uh information from my
medical doctor i'm not i don't have that
information in front of me
sir you would have been told if someone
died after getting covered 19 maxine
wouldn't you have
i'm sure i would have congressman i just
don't have information in front of me so
once you get back to us but i'm going to
tell you you would have been told if
that effect happened
now did you see that the cdc came out
saying that if you get a covert 19
vaccine and a booster shot
you are 97 times less likely to die than
if you're unvaccinated from covet are
you aware of
that yes congressman
okay
so i want to
agree
with the former president
who said
that cover 19 vaccines are one of the
greatest achievements of mankind
and i want to talk about the religious
exemptions
i have to be catholic
the pope
was also called the vicar of christ
has said that getting a covert 19
vaccine is a moral obligation
what i want to know is
with the bureau of prisons giving any
religious exemptions to folks who are
catholic and if so what possible basis
could that be um
congressman i don't personally review
those exemptions we have processes in
place and i'm certainly i'm certain that
we can get you that information we have
actually
ceased because of the preliminary
injunction we've ceased a process of
religious and medical exemptions uh for
the time being
if you could get me the information that
would be great
and now a chairwoman uh
like to enter two articles for the
record the first is from forest magazine
june 19 2020 it's titled
bureau prison special tactical forces
under scrutiny for use in dc protests
and training mishaps
the second article is titled the story
behind bill barr's unmarked federal
agents from politico and stated june 5th
2020. so director carter hall like to
ask you
were
bureau prisons personnel used to crack
on protesters
and were they in fact unmarked
congressman we did assist the department
of justice and other law enforcement
components uh
during those protests uh initially and i
answered this i was asked this question
during a press conference uh initially
within the first few days our staff were
not properly marked in essence for
people on the civilian side to recognize
them they had local institution logos we
corrected that within a couple of days
we appropriately marked them to show
their review of prisons personnel it was
an oversight
and when it became when it came to our
attention we appropriately marked them
they all now when deployed if deployed
they're appropriately marked to indicate
they're operating in the federal bureau
prisons that they are federal officers
so
for any
future occurrences they will all be
identified am i understanding that
correctly
they were that we corrected the issue
before the end of that and and we have
deployed them since and they are all
appropriately identified as federal
bureau prisons
officers there are also allegations uh
that there was excessive use of force
that some of them may have used tear gas
and other um actions that
were not appropriate
so my question goes to training these
feudal prison folks they're trained to
deal with
prison issues do they also get training
on dealing with
crowds who are exercising their first
amendment right to free speech
this congressman uh i i know that some
of those things are under current review
so i don't think it'd be appropriate for
me to comment on them uh uh we i can
check back with my staff or step the
status of that and we can answer your
questions offline i don't want to
misspeak in this forum uh if that does
still matter the matter's still under
review
thank you if you give me the information
it's important because i've introduced a
bill with congressman earl blumenauer
that will prevent the attorney general
from randomly deputizing actually the
u.s marshals randomly deputizing bureau
prison folks and then sending them out
to cities to crack down and first
amendment
free speech folks who are accepting that
right with that i yield back
close my fingers again but thank you
very much uh mr lu for your
um questioning and it's certainly my
privilege now to yield to
uh another
important distinguished member of this
whole body and that is uh mr cohen of
tennessee mr cohen of tennessee you are
recognized for five minutes
thank you madam chairman and thank you
for holding this hearing up if i ask any
questions that have been asked earlier
mr carvajal
let me know i've been at a hearing of
the helsinki commission we had the
polish foreign minister and uh been very
involved in those issues
these are important issues as well and i
wanted to make this hearing and i'm
happy i can the pandemic has highlighted
many of the failings of our federal
prison system and the bureau of prisons
has unfortunately failed to protect the
health of those within their custody
and their staff from coven 19 or address
chronic understaffing
the blp has also lacked transparency and
vigor and implementing important
criminal justice reforms such as the
first step act mr carvajal hall
what lessons have you learned during
your tenure and what advice do you have
for your successor to address some of
these issues that we've seen within the
bureau of prisons
mr carvajal
congressman yes sorry yes sir i'm trying
to mute here well
if you're asking about the lessons
learned from the pandemic first off we
followed cdc guides from day one uh we
learned that we need to protect the most
vulnerable the elderly i isolate the
sick quarantine
the exposed the same lessons that the
rest of the country in the world have
known restrict movement communicate
better
those are some of the lessons learned
and i think that we've
got good processes in place we work with
the cdc we've invited them into our uh
institutions they have visited us and
our pandemic plan is worked in
collaboration with the cdc
well let me ask you about the first step
back that was one of the the few uh
successes mr trump had that in the
operation warp speed
um that seemed seemed like it should
have been pursued with vigor and it
wasn't uh why was first step acted
trying to get individuals that
should be eligible for release not not
operation warp speed for the bureau of
prisons
congressman i'm not sure i know what
you're referring to we are fully
compliant that's totally compliant with
the first step act and we have
implemented a risk and needs assessment
way ahead of the time it was due uh we
formalized it we've released inmates
under the first step back they're
earning time credits i'm not certain
what you're referring to was january was
their date late january that you needed
to have a certain report in on folks
that would be eligible for release
maybe you got it done i don't know but
at one point it wasn't done
well we were awaiting the finalization
of the rule of the process which i don't
control we submitted that draft rule
under the last administration at the end
of uh january 20 and it was finalized in
january we met we are statutory
compliant with the first step back
congressman excellent well that's good
um i led a letter along with
representative bonnie watson coleman
biden administration urged them to avoid
the reincarceration of those released to
home confinement of the cares act
allowing those released to apply for
commutations of their sentences
in your view was home confined under the
cares act successful number one and do
you agree that those released have
largely proven their ability to
successfully assimilate back into their
homes families and communities
congressman we're always committed to
returning people to society 95 of our
people will go we we understand and
support the karzak we've done so we've
released over seven thirty seven
thousand two home confinement nine
thousand of those under the cares act uh
only 320 of those have reoffended and we
follow the statute and the rules so we
uh we follow the laws that are
implemented and we continue to do so
the department of justice office of
legal counsel published a memorandum
concluding that the
board of
bureau of prisons was not required to
return those released to home
environment under the cares act the
prison once the emergency uh period
ended but has the bureau of prisons
under your guidance begun taking steps
to effectuate the department of justice
memorandum and new interpretation of the
law
so that the people who are home
confinement would be able to remain on
home confinement and
apply for commutations
yes congressman i'm i'm aware of the olc
opinion we're working with the
department uh we are not we have not
nailed down the how when we do that we
will make it uh we will be as
transparent as possible to make sure
that everyone gets the information but
we certainly take the information and
guidance of the attorney general will
continue to follow the laws
thank you sir let me ask you this uh
you were the head of the bureau of
prisons were you not when mr epstein
allegedly committed suicide
no i was not congressman you weren't
okay you were there though when michael
cohen was arrested and brought back and
put in solidarity confinement when he
tried to exercise his first amendment
rights were you not
i believe that did happen under my tour
yes
did you have were you asked
did you have anything to do with that
were you made aware of it
the desire to have him brought back into
custody and put in solitary confinement
no congressman i was not made aware of
that prior to i was briefed on it
afterwards because he's a high publicity
case has any high publicity but i was
not uh directly involved in that
decision
well thank you
based on mr last question madam chair uh
since mr epstein committed suicide and
and the
security there was awful it has have you
seen to it that miss maxwell's got
better
care or supervision to make sure she
doesn't do anything to end her life
i'll let the director answer the
question
time has
yes
expired
uh i don't want to discuss specific uh
security issues on any individual but we
appropriately uh ensure that people in
our care have the appropriate
supervision and security
thank you sir thank you madam chair
thank you very much
uh this has been um an important uh
hearing uh insightful
uh approaches by our members on both
sides of the aisle uh and so uh as we
come to a conclusion uh mr biggs uh as
ranking member do you have any uh
additional points that you might want to
place on the record at this time
thank you madam chair uh first of all
thank you director again for being here
and i look forward to uh the number of
responses that you indicated to me that
you would have your staff get uh get to
me i look forward to seeing those and uh
madam chair i'll yield back to you
um i thank the gentleman very much um
director um just uh one final point that
comes uh
out of the testimony of dr homer venters
uh who is uh
an adjunct faculty at the nyu college of
global health who was with us uh in our
previous hearing uh his investigation
revealed a disturbing lack of access to
care
when a new medical problem is
encountered we've heard those questions
line of questions coming from several
members uh this process called sick call
in most uh casserole settings relies on
the ability of incarcerated people to
submit a written or electronic concern
and then be seen in a face-to-face
encounter with a day or two in the first
bop facility that he had the
time to had the opportunity to visit as
he inspected the metropolitan detention
center in brooklyn new york it quickly
became apparent that not only were many
people reporting that their sick call
requests including cover 19 symptoms
were being ignored but that the facility
was actually destroying their original
request which violates basic
correctional standards
as this is an accountability hearing and
it is a recognition that there should be
um if you will
um accountability and
uh the uh
exercise of punitive measures we all
have concluded that these are human
beings deserving of restoration and
dignity
men and women can you comment on that
kind of action
yes congresswoman i appreciate you
allowing me to clarify that first off i
am aware of the report we looked into it
we followed up i won't discuss
uh that specific incident but i will
reassure you that each of our
institutions has an outpatient hair
clinic it's overseen by a board state
certified physician and a medical
director we have outside oversight we
have joint commission triple ahc
aca we've received the same reviews that
any outside clinic or nursing home would
have our mortalities are reviewed by
independent reviews so i'm not sure
uh i mean we get oversight if there's a
mistake made or something of that nature
we're going to look into it and do
something about it correct the issue
thank you director what i would ask
specifically um is
some of the questions that may not have
been answered more thoroughly our staff
will get with you so that we can get uh
answers in writing and that in
particular at the metropolitan detention
center in brooklyn new york
um your memory or it may not come to
your attention i'd want a direct
response and answer on that matter
and i thank you for that
i'm also going to
suggest that there is a board of health
oversight for the department of prison
uh federal view of prisons i know that
you do have a number of other agencies
but i think one that is specifically
focused on helping
the bureau
going forward will be very helpful let
me finally uh submit into the record man
is 16th to die from covert 19 at fort
worth prison cases spike and women's
facility so as i conclude uh director uh
let me say i'm not sure of whether or
not you'll appear before this committee
or
a committee in the other body but let me
take this opportunity to show uh our
appreciation from a person who has
chosen as his career
to serve the nation and obviously coming
into the bureau many many years ago you
have continued to make a commitment to
serve this nation so it is my privilege
to be able to say thank you
for your service it should not go
unnoticed
you've served under many administrations
democratic and republican uh and you've
chosen to commit yourself
uh to hopefully the lives and the
ultimate liberty of individuals that we
hope will be restored and will enter
into society and never to return again i
hope that is your vision you've stayed
and as i thank you
i want to make sure that we thank the
hard-working officers who go by the go
by the appropriate a mixture of uh
reform uh accountability and compassion
so thank you again for your testimony
this morning uh this concludes and your
service to the nation this concludes
today's hearing thank you to our
distinguished witness for attending
without objection all members will have
five legislative days to submit
additional written questions for the
witness or additional materials for the
record the hearing is now adjourned
i hope that was her thank you very much
thank you congresswoman
c-span is your unfiltered view of
government we're funded by these